SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE AND
EDUCATION FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE UNCERTAIN -- WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND START -- TO I GUESS IS
A SUBCOMMITTEE OF ONE FOR RIGHT
NOW WE'RE GONNA TAKE ISSUE
NUMBER SIX FIRST BECAUSE I HAVE
A COLLEAGUE PRESENT -- TO WHO
WILL NEED TO PRESENT AND MAY
HAVE OTHER PLACES TO BE ISSUE
SIX IS A NEW CAMPUS STUDIES SO.
THERE HUESO -- SIR.
PLACE OF HONOR.
GOOD LUCK GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
A LOT ME THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS [inaudible]
THE COMMITTEE -- THIS IS
REGARDING A TWO MILLION ONE TIME
FUNDING IN -- PROPOSAL -- FOR
THE POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN CHULA
VISTA AND MY DISTRICT AND SOUTH
SAN DIEGO.
THIS -- WOULD ACTIVATE A THIRTY
A THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE
ACRE CITY OWNED.
OF PARCEL.
THAT IS WITH THAT HAS BEEN
SPECIFICALLY SET ASIDE AND
STONED AND PREPARED FOR
UNIVERSITY THAT YOU'D THE CHILL.
CITY CHILVERS TO HAS BEEN
WORKING -- VERY HARD FOR SEVERAL
YEARS TO ATTRACT A STATE
UNIVERSITY OF SOME SORT THE UC
OR STATE.
UNIVERSITY FOR THE PURPOSES OF
SERVING THE SOUTH BAY.
SOUTH BAY SAN DIEGO HAS A
POPULATION OF A MILLION PEOPLE.
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO A UNIVERSITY
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE HAVE A A A A VERY --
SUCCESSFUL.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OF PROGRAM BUT
EVEN THAT PROGRAM.
A HAS A WHOPPING NINETEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS -- THE THERE
WAS A FACILITY THAT WAS BUILT
ADJACENT TO THE BORDER WAS
CRITICIZED WHY THEY BUILDING AT
THEIR IT WAS -- 80% AND ROLLED --
THREE MONTHS BEFORE THE THE THE
CAMPUS WAS EVEN COMPLETED.
THIS IS -- AN AREA THAT HAS A AS
I MENTIONED A MILLION PEOPLE.
BUT ALSO WITH AN ADJACENT --
CITY JUST TO THE SOUTH.
LARGELY CONCENTRATED ALONG THE
BORDER ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE ALSO IN THE THE CITY OF
OF OF THE ONE OF WHICH IS
CLOSELY APPROACHING.
A TWO MILLION RESIDENTS -- F.
QUICKLY APPROACHING TWO MILLION
RESIDENTS SO THIS IS AN AREA
THAT WOULD NOT ONLY BE WELL
SERVED BY A UNIVERSITY BUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
WOULD BE WELL SERVED WITH.
A UNIVERSITY IN THIS AREA TO IT
IS -- OF THAT.
WHAT I CALL A GLOBALIZED
COMMUNITY ON AREA THAT IS IN THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY?
THAT WOULD -- CREATE A CAMPUS IN
AN AREA WHERE WE CURRENTLY IN
THE ENTIRE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAVE NO CAMPUSES NEAR THE BORDER.
NEAR ALL THAT INFRASTRUCTURE
NEAR -- AN AREA THAT IS IS VERY
THRIVING ECONOMIC PLAYBOOK AND
THAT IS A GLOBAL LIFE THAT IS --
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY.
THIS SITE IS -- OF A VERY
STRATEGIC SIDE AND AND AND
WITHIN THE THE THE CITY'S AREA
IT.
AND ALSO IS ADJACENT.
ON ELITE TRAINING FACILITY THOSE
THOSE UP -- BUILT TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES TO OLYMPIC ATHLETES
THIS FACILITY IS NOT ONLY
GROWING IS IT SEE MORE PEOPLE
COME TO THAT AREA FOR FOR THOSE
SERVICES THAT THEY PROVIDE.
AND IT WOULD MAKE A A WONDERFUL --
PARTNER WITH A UNIVERSITY IN
THAT AREA -- TWO THIRDS OF HIGH
SCHOOL.
STUDENTS GRADUATE IN A SOUTH BAY.
ATTEND LOCAL COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TWO THIRDS.
THAT IS JUST AN ENORMOUS NUMBER
OF PEOPLE NOT ONLY STAIN LOCALLY
IN SAN DIEGO BUT GOING TO LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AND AND WE REALLY NEED A FEEDER
UNIVERSITY ALL OUR UNIVERSITIES
IN IN SAN DIEGO ARE OVER AND
ROLLED THEIR IMPACTED.
HARD TO GET COURSE WORK AT SAN
DIEGO STATE.
I IS SOMETIMES IT TAKES US
STUDENTS IS SENDING A STATE UP
TO SIX YEARS TO GRADUATE BECAUSE
OF THE DIFFICULTY IN OBTAINING
COURSE WORK.
THIS IS A UNIVERSITY WOULD BRING
WITH IT -- IT INVESTMENT. TO
HELP US -- CREATE MORE MORE
SLOTS FOR STUDENTS BUT ALSO TO
MAKE.
UP THE UNIVERSITY MORE
ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE IN THE
SOUTH BAY.
IF YOU VISIT SAN DIEGO IT'S VERY
HARD I MEAN WE'RE BUILDING A
TROLLEY TO YOU SEE AS THE AND WE
BUILT TROLLEY. TO TO THE A TO
SEND YOU A STATE BUT IT IS CHILL
OF ESTá AND IN THE AREA IN THE
SOUTH BAY THERE REALLY IS NO
ACCESS TO A TROLLEY THERE IN
THAT AREA.
AND IT'S A ALTHOUGH THEY'RE
WORKING ON CREATING A MORE.
EFFICIENT TRANSPORTATION NETWORK.
IT IS STILL AN AREA THAT IS --
NOT ACCESSIBLE TO THESE SERVICES
IN THE UNIVERSITIES FOR THESE
KIDS ARE VERY HARD TO ACCESS.
THIS WOULD BE OF A WONDERFUL
THING FOR ALL OF SEND YOU WILL
COUNTY WHAT WOULD BE A WONDERFUL
THING. FOR OF THE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M ALL I'M
ASKING HERE IS THAT WE LOOK AT
THIS THAT WE CONSIDER THIS.
THAT THESE FUNDS THAT ARE BEING --
EARMARKED FOR OTHER STUDY OF A
OF A OF ANOTHER UNIVERSITY IN
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY ALSO
INCLUDE THIS.
AS AN OPTION OF BECAUSE I THINK --
IT'LL LEADER IF WE DO INCLUDED --
TO RANK VERY HIGH AS A WONDERFUL
OPTION HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND IT
WOULD MAKE SENSE. TO BUILD A
SOMETHING SOMEWHERE WHERE.
WE WILL HAVE A HIGH POPULATION
OF STUDENTS WANTING TO ATTEND.
AND OTHER STUDENTS FROM OTHER
PARTS OF THE STATE WANTING -- TO
ATTEND AS WELL.
SO THANK YOU AND IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS LOVE THE ANSWER
QUESTIONS WILL I WOULD NOTE THAT --
YOU SEE YOU SEE ISSUE SAN DIEGO
RATHER -- APPEARS TO BE AN
IMPACTED CAMPUS WITH THEM FOR
OVER ALMOST.
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND A STUDENTS
AT LEAST THAT'S THE DATA THAT --
THAT WE WERE PROVIDED IT ALSO
APPEARS THAT THE THIS MUST BE
SEE ISSUES SAN DIEGO SAN DIEGO
STATE OF HAS SOME.
WHAT THEY CALL OFF CAMPUS
CENTERS WITH I WOULD CALL THEM
SATELLITE CAMPUSES MAY BE IN
IMPERIAL VALLEY CALEXICO IN
BROAD?
OF FAIRLY SMALL AND DO YOU
CENTER YOU CONTEMPLATE THAT YOUR
STUDY WOULD ALSO INCLUDE THE
POSSIBILITY OF HAVING -- A
SATELLITE TO EXPANDING A
SATELLITE CAMPUS PERHAPS ON
STEROIDS MUCH LARGER THAN THE
SIX HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE FD
ENROLLMENT AT IMPERIAL VALLEY
CALEXICO.
THE SATELLITE CAMPUS PERHAPS
THAT YOU LIVE IS TO IN ADDITION --
TO STUDYING THE POSSIBILITY OF A
FULL FULL SCALE CSU CAMPUS OF
THAT WOULD BE WONDERFUL -- WE
ACTUALLY WORKED VERY HARD TO GET
SENDING A STATE NOT TO CLOSE OUR
SATELLITE CAMPUS THAT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS BEING
CONSIDERED -- ABOUT EIGHT YEARS
AGO -- WITH WITH SOME OF THE
BUDGET CUTS AND SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THE UNIVERSITY WAS
FACING BACK THEN [inaudible]
IT.
SEND YOUR STATE WITH THEIR
SATELLITE CAMPUS HAS BEEN ABLE
TO ATTRACT A LOT OF STUDENTS
FROM IMPERIAL COUNTY. TO ATTEND
SAN DIEGO STATE A LOT OF MOST OF
THE STUDENTS FROM.
OF IMPERIAL COUNTY THAT --
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE YOU GROUP
WILL GRADUATE FROM SAN DIEGO
STATE SO IT IS.
A ONE OF FOR A RELATIONSHIP THAT
HAS BEEN FORMED.
AND WE'VE BEEN ENCOURAGING
SENEGAL STATE -- TO PUT MORE
RESOURCES INTO THE CAMPUS AND TO
IMPERIAL COUNTY KEEP IT OPEN PUT
MORE RESOURCES THERE BECAUSE
THERE IS A VERY HEALTHY -- YOUNG
POPULATION AUTHOR THE BE VERY
WELL SERVED BY THAT AND THIS
PARTICULAR ONE IT'S THAT.
YOU'RE FOCUSING ON RIGHT NOW IS
ONE IN CHULA VISTA -- THE ONE
THAT -- I THINK THAT.
THAT -- IT IS VERY PART OF A
SOMETHING THAT IS A VERY
PRACTICABLE.
VERY ACHIEVABLE.
IS -- THIS FACILITY SIMPLY
BECAUSE OF ALL THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT'S ALREADY
BUILT AND BUILT AND IT'S NOT
JUST.
A VACANT THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE ACRE PARCEL IT'S A PARTIAL
THAT HAS ALL THE INFRASTRUCTURE
ROADS -- YEAH I MEAN PLUMBING
ELECTRICAL AND I MEAN EVERYTHING
IS IS IS IT CONNECTED TO THIS
PARCEL.
IN A WAY THAT WOULD MAKE IT VERY
ACHIEVABLE TO BUILD.
A UNIVERSITY QUITE AFFORDABLY
THEIR AND IT WOULD.
OF COURSE BE OF AGAIN IN AN AREA
OF A MILLION PEOPLE WOULDN'T.
IT WILL IT THEY WOULD BE AN
OVERNIGHT SENSATION ONCE IT
OPENS UP YOU HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
PEOPLE APPLYING TO GO THERE SO.
MUCH CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
NEEDS TO BE STUDIED BOTH OF FULL
SCALE CAMPUS AND ALSO -- AS I
SAID A SATELLITE CAMPUS PERHAPS
ON STEROIDS IS A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF BUREAUCRACY THAT TENDS TO BE
ASSOCIATED WITH THESE.
SEPARATE UNIVERSITIES BUT YOU
COULD CERTAINLY ELIMINATE THAT
COST ELEMENT IF YOU SIMPLY DOES
WHICH TO SOME EXTENT.
IF YOU DID AS A LARGER SATELLITE
CAMPUS TO SERVICE THE STUDENT
POPULATION. FOR EXAMPLE IN CHULA
VISTA I AGREE I AGREE I THINK
THAT'S MUSIC TO MY EARS MISTER
SHERMAN.
WE'LL GO WE'LL GO TO WORK ON
THAT SIR THANK YOU THANKS FOR
PRESENTING.
WE HAVE A PANEL ASSOCIATED WITH
THE NEW CAMPUS STUDY -- WHAT WE
CALL OF THE PANEL AND FINISH OFF
ISSUE NUMBER SIX AT THIS POINT
IN TIME?
AND WHILE THEY'RE COMING UP
LET'S DO SOMETHING NOVEL AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
THEY'RE ALL HERE THERE LEYVA.
YOUR THURMOND.
OKAY IF I COULD ASK MY PANELISTS
TO IDENTIFY THEMSELVES STARTING
TO MY LEFT YOU'RE RIGHT SIR
EUROPE.
MY NAME IS RAINSTORM I AM THE
ASSISTANT VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
BUDGET FOR THE OFFICE OF THE
CHANCELLOR.
THE STORM THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS BY SEN
ONE I'M ASSISTANT VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR CAPITAL PLANNING
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION FOR THE
OFFICE OF THE CHANCELLOR WITH
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY.
SOMEONE THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH KIRK
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IS KIRK
THANK YOU.
AUSTIN HOUSE AND LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE MISTER STEVE
HAS THANK YOU WHO WANTS TO START
[inaudible]
THIS HURT.
THANK YOU THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND FOR THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE. TO
UNDERTAKE A REVIEW OF A
POTENTIAL CAMPUS.
IN SAN JOAQUIN COUNTY LIKELY AND
STOCKTON.
THE ADMINISTRATION ANTICIPATES
THAT THE PROPOSED REVIEW WOULD
INCLUDE A STUDY THAT EXAMINES.
WHETHER A POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN
THE REGION IS WARRANTED.
AND OUTLINING CONSIDERATIONS FOR
INITIAL PLANNING.
FURTHER DETAILS ON THE PROPOSAL
WILL BE PROVIDED WITH THE MAY
REVISION IN BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE.
I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS ANY
QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
YES SIR ALEJO.
THIS IS THIS ISSUE IS MENTIONED
IN THE GOVERNOR'S SUMMARY OF THE
JANUARY TEN BUDGET.
BUT IS NOT BEEN INCLUDED YET IN
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE AS YOU JUST HEARD
WILL.
LEGISLATURE WILL BE EXPECTING.
LANGUAGE AT THE MAY REVISE.
IN THINKING ABOUT THE INITIAL
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE HAS --
COUPLE ISSUES TO CONSIDER.
OF THE FACT THE MINISTRATION IS
PROPOSING FUNDS FOR STUDY
SUGGESTS THE GOVERNOR.
WOULD LIKE TO ASSESS CERTAIN
CRITERIA CERTAIN FACTORS BEFORE
COMMITTING TO A NEW CAMPUS THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT YET
CLARIFIED WHICH FACTORS HE WOULD
LIKE TO CONSIDER.
A FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ASKED OUR OFFICE -- TO TO ASSESS
WHETHER PUBLIC UNIVERSITY WAS
JUSTIFIED BASED ON ONE KEY
FACTOR AND THAT WAS.
PROJECTED ENROLLMENT AND
PHYSICAL CAPACITY OF EXISTING
CAMPUSES AND IN THAT REPORT WE
FOUND THAT THE STATE COULD
ACCOMMODATE GROWTH IN MOST
REGIONS INCLUDING THE CENTRAL
VALLEY.
OF BY BUILDING OUT EXISTING
CAMPUSES.
THAT SAID THE ADMINISTRATION
MATE MIGHT HAVE OTHER FACTORS IN
MIND -- OTHER CRITERIA TO
CONSIDER WHICH MIGHT INCLUDE FOR
EXAMPLE THE COMMUTING TIME FOR
STUDENTS TO TRAVEL TO A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY OR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT.
OF A LOCAL OR REGIONAL AREA NO
LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT FACTORS THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS IN MIND WHEN
A JESSE.
ASSESSING THIS PROPOSAL.
LEGISLATURE OBVIOUSLY WILL ALSO
WANT TO KNOW A LOT MORE DETAILS
ABOUT HOW THIS TW MILLION
DOLLARS.
WOULD BE SPENT WHAT THE SCOPE
WOULD BE FOR EXAMPLE IS A
PROPOSED TWO MILLION DOLLARS.
FOR FACILITY PLANS AS WELL OR
FINANCING PLANS PLANS TO BUILD
OUT ACADEMIC PROGRAMS IS IT FROM
FIRE MENTAL REVIEWS.
SO LEGISLATURE OLDEST BE WANT TO
WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT THE
SPECIFIC PROPOSAL IS WHAT IT
ENTAILS.
AND WHAT THE DELIVERABLES WILL
BE.
THANK YOU.
THE RAIN STORM AGAIN FROM C.
ISSUE I THINK ONE THING THAT I
WANTED TO POINT OUT FROM -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THE LA -- WHEN HE
SAID THAT WE AGREE WITH THIS IS
THAT FROM OUR VANTAGE POINT WE
BELIEVE THAT WE DO HAVE
SUFFICIENT CAPACITY AND ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES THAT?
WE COULD BUILD OUT ARE ALL OF
OUR CAMPUSES AND ADD ADDITIONAL
ROMANCE IN OUR EXISTING TWENTY
THREE CAMPUSES.
BUT IF THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR ONE WHO AGREED -- TO
STUDYING SOME NEW CAMPUSES WE
HAVE A LONG ESTABLISHED POLICY
THAT THE BOARD EMPLOYEES.
IN REVIEWING WHETHER OUR CAMPUS
SHOULD OR SHOULD NOT BE DEVELOP
THERE'S A LOT OF CRITERIA THAT
ARE LAID OUT IN.
IN IN OUR POLICIES -- THE OTHER
THING TOO IS THAT WITH THAT
MONEY IF WE WERE TO RECEIVE THAT
MONEY WE WOULD DO ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU WOULD WANT US TO DO AND
ANALYZE WHATEVER SCOPE WORK THAT
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN IN IN US
PURSUING -- AND THEN -- I THINK
JUST THE BOTTOM LINE IS THAT IF
YOU WILL IF YOU ARE INTERESTED
IN PURSUING THIS THAN WE'RE
WILLING TO DO THE WORK.
OBVIOUSLY THOUGH THAT ONE THING
THAT IS SOMETHING OF CONCERN TO
THE C. ISSUE IN GENERAL WITH.
A NEW CAMPUSES IS THAT WE DO
LAUNCHER OR TAKEOVER PARTICULAR
CAMPUSES OFTENTIMES WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO IS WE HAVE TO AND THIS IS
GONNA SOUND LITTLE BIT.
COURSE BUT WE HAVE TO STARBUCKS
CAMPUSES IN ORDER -- TO TO
REALLY -- SUPPORT NEW CAMPUSES --
TO GET THEM TO CAPACITY IN TERMS
OF ECONOMIES OF SCALE THAT SORT
OF THING SO.
IN THE PAST WE'VE YOU KNOW HAD
THE DEVELOPMENT MONTEREY BAY --
WE'VE TAKEN ON THE MARITIME
ACADEMY IN THE EARLY NINETIES
ALSO -- I THINK SAN MARCOS WAS
ANOTHER CAMPUS WHERE IT WAS KIND
OF YOUR TAKE YOUR GOING FROM A
CENTER SORT OF POSITION TO
DEVELOPING INTO FULL BLOWN
CAMPUS WILL SERVE CHANNEL
ISLANDS.
WAS WHEN MOST RECENT ONES.
IT'S A TO GET THOSE CAMPUSES THE
CAPACITY.
OF FROM MAYBE NOTHING YOU'RE
LOOKING AT ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
RESOURCES TO GET A CAMPUS TO
ROUGHLY ABOUT FIVE THOUSAND FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS WHICH
IS KIND OF OUR KIND OF BALLPARK
OF WHERE WE THINK A SELF
SUSTAINING UNIVERSITY CAN BE.
DOES THAT INCLUDE THE CAPITAL
COST IT DOES NOT INCLUDE THE
CAPITAL COSTS OF THE OPERATING
COST OF ABOUT A HUNDRED TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS THAT DOESN'T.
INCLUDE OTHER CAPITAL COST MY
COLLEAGUE COULD TALK TO YOU A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT YOU KNOW
PRICE TAG OF VARIOUS ELEMENTS OF
THAT BUT I WOULD I MEAN I WAS AT
ONE OF MY QUESTIONS WERE.
GOING FIRST WHAT WE HAVE TO VIEW
THIS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE THE
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE BUDGET
LITTLE ON THE CAPITAL NEEDS OF
THESE OF THIS SYSTEM PLUS THE UC
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
IS THE STATE WHICH BY MY MATHIS
SOMEWHERE OR THE REPORTED.
TOTALS ARE SOMEWHERE BETWEEN.
EIGHT TO NINE BILLION DOLLARS
JUST ON THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
SIDE NOT.
TOTALING UP THE CAPITAL PROJECT --
NEEDS FOR FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION.
A SO WE HAVE THAT.
TO THAT'S THE CONTEXT WERE
OPERATING IN HERE.
SO HAVING STARTED A COUPLE AT
LEAST ONE OR TWO NEW CAMPUSES IN
THE LAST COUPLE DECADES WHY.
WHAT IS THE COST OF SETTING UP A?
A NEW C. ISSUE CAMPUS
[inaudible]
ALL IN.
WHAT WILL THEY THINK OF A UC
MERCED I WOULD SAY BILLION
DOLLARS?
BILLION.
IS THERE CAPITAL PLAN.
AND THEN YOU HAVE THE OPERATING
COSTS THE LABELS AND ON TOP OF
THAT YEAH WHAT WHAT I WHAT I'M
REFERENCING IS GENERALLY THE
OPERATING BUDGET FOR OUR CHANNEL
ISLANDS CAMPUS WHICH HAS ABOUT.
FIVE THOUSAND FULL TIME
EQUIVALENTS.
SO.
WHEN YOU'VE GONE THROUGH THIS
BEFORE SO WHAT CAN YOU IN LIKE
ME A LITTLE BIT AS TO WHAT THE
FACTORS ARE THAT YOU LOOK AT
WHEN YOU DECIDE TO SAY?
TO THE NEW CAMPUS SOMEWHERE.
WHAT WE WOULD LOOK AT THE
ENROLLMENT WE ALSO HAVE TO LOOK
CARE BY BOARD POLICY WHAT THE
IMPACT IS TO OTHER HIGHER ITS
INSTITUTIONS IN THE AREA?
SO DOES IT DETRACT FROM OTHER
OTHER -- INSTITUTIONS LIKE AND
HOW SAN DIEGO STATE IT AT ONE
TIME THE IMPACT IT HAD AN OFF
CAMPUS CENTER -- IN CHULA VISTA
SO WHAT ARE THE COSTS TO
MAINTAIN THAT AND CAN THEY
MAINTAIN IT ADEQUATELY.
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR PALM
DESERT CAMPUS IS THE STUDENTS
GOING THERE -- WANT MORE
SERVICES AND OFTENTIMES BECAUSE
OF ADMINISTRATOR EFFICIENCIES
THE HEAD OF THE HOME CAMPUS WILL
SHARE RESOURCES SO IT MAY BE A
FACULTY IS COMMUTING.
OR COUNSELORS COMMUTING
FINANCIAL A PERSON IS GOING FROM
ONE CAMP THE OTHER.
BUT OTHER FACTORS OF THEY WOULD
CONSIDER IS.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT WITH THE
COMMUNITY IS A COMMUNITY
WELCOMING WHAT ARE THE COSTS TO
CITE THE FACILITY IN THAT
COMMUNITY AS FAR AS TRAFFIC
IMPACTS -- ARE ARE THERE -- IS
THERE HOUSING AVAILABLE FOR
STUDENTS WE'VE SEEN THAT IS A
FACTOR.
SO WILL WE BE ABLE -- TO SINCE
IT'S A SELF SUPPORT PROGRAM A
CONSTRUCT HOUSING IN THAT AREA
FOR STUDENTS.
MAKE IT EASIER FOR THEM -- TO TO
GET THROUGH GRADUATION AND AND
RETAIN OF STUDENTS [inaudible]
OF FOR THOSE HURT WHAT WITH THE
ACADEMIC DEGREE PROGRAMS THEY
WOULD OFFER.
SO WILL THEY BE ABLE TO ACT
OFFER A FULL COMPLEMENT OF
DEGREE PROGRAMS WHAT DOES THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OFFER.
VERSES THE A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION.
SO THAT'S PART OF THE THE
TYPICALLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN WITH
OUR OFF CAMPUS CENTERS AS THEY
WOULD OFFER UPPER DIVISION
SELECT COMMITTEE COFFIN
COMMITTEE COLLEGES OFFER LOWER
DIVISIONS SO HOW THAT.
WORKS AS WELL SUBMIT DR IN IN
TERMS OF AND WE'RE TALKING
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY NOW
IN TERMS OF YOUR STUDENT
POPULATION YOUR STUDENT BASE --
WHAT PERCENTAGE GENERALLY ARE
COMMUTERS AS OPPOSED TO
RESIDENTIAL STUDENTS DOES IT
DEPEND ON THE CAMPUS?
RIGHT NOW I BELIEVE ALL OF OUR
OFF CAMPUS CENTERS ARE COMMUTER
CAMPUSES.
ALTHOUGH THEIR PLANS IN SOME OF
THE MASTER PLAN TO FIGHT HOUSING.
AND THEN THE MAIN SEE ISSUE OF
INSTITUTIONS.
FRESNO FOR EXAMPLE OR SYMBOL TO
DENOTE OR DOES IT DEPEND ON THE
CAMPUS IT DOES DEPEND ON THE
CAMPUS.
AS FAR AS THE NUMBER OF
COMMUTERS AND THE AMOUNT OF
HOUSING ON CAMPUS ALSO RANGES
FRESNO IS ON THE LOWER SIDE.
I THINK PROBABLY CLOSER 210%
COMPARED TO A MARITIME ACADEMY
WHERE THE REQUIRED. TO LIVE ON
CAMPUS AT SAVE UPWARDS OF 50%
[inaudible]
CAPACITY.
AND IF -- THE ADMINISTRATION
WERE INCLINED TO ADD A ANOTHER A
ANALYSIS TO THIS STUDY FOR
EXAMPLE OF WHETHER IT'S A
SATELLITE CAMPUS IN AN EXPANDED
SATELLITE CAMPUS OR A A NEW CSU
INSTITUTION IN CHULA VISTA HOW
MUCH.
HOW MUCH WOULD THAT ADD TO THE?
PRICE TAG OF THE STUDY WOULD
DOESN'T NECESSARILY DOUBLE IT
FROM TWO TO FOUR MILLION OR CAN
YOU ADD ANOTHER SITE TO THE
STUDY.
WAS IN THE TWO MILLION.
OR IS IT IMPOSSIBLE TO FOR YOU
ALL TO SAY AT THIS POINT YEAH I
WOULD GUESS IT WOULD NOT DOUBLE
IT.
IF IT WAS THE BUT BUT IT IS A
DIFFERENT AREA SO AS FAR AS
LOOKING AT THE LAND.
AND SOME OF THE DEMOGRAPHICS IT
IT COULD.
BUT THE I DON'T THINK IT WOULD
BE MORE THAN DOUBLE.
AND INFO AND IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE SINCE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITIES HAD A PRESENCE.
HAS A PRESENCE IN SAN DIEGO AND
AS HAVE APPARENTLY HAD A
PRESENCE IN CHULA VISTA WITH THE
SATELLITE OFF CAMPUS LOCATION
BEFORE.
THAT MIGHT SIMPLIFY THE ANALYSIS
A LITTLE BIT ANYWAY.
RIGHT SINCE THEY WERE SERVING
THEIR AT ONE POINT.
IT SHOULD MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT.
FOLKS ON THE FIRST FLOOR WILL
CONSIDER.
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY DELIVER
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I WANT TO TOUCH ON TWO THINGS
THAT WERE SAID STARVING OTHER
UNIVERSITIES AND A BILLION
DOLLARS SO BEING NEW TO THIS
PROCESS.
IS WHAT YOU'RE SAYING THAT WE AS
A STATE WOULD NOT GIVE YOU THE
MONEY.
AND YOU WOULD HAVE TO TAKE IT
FROM THE OTHER UNIVERSITIES ONE
AND TWO IS YOUR THOUGHT THAT IT
WILL BE A BILLION DOLLARS TO GET
A NEW INSTITUTION UP AND RUNNING.
WELL TO START OFF ON THE
OPERATING COST OF THINGS SO
ESSENTIALLY WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT.
EVERY YEAR YOU PROVIDE US AN
APPROPRIATION OF SOME SORT RIGHT
WHETHER THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE A SLIGHT INCREASE OR
WHATEVER THE CASES.
WHAT I MEANT BY STARVING IS IS
THAT THEN WE ALREADY HAVE
EXISTING TWENTY THREE CAMPUS?
AND THEY ALL HAVE VARIOUS GOALS
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO ACHIEVE
ESPECIALLY ON ENROLLMENT RIGHT --
WE HAVE A LOT OF CAMPUSES THAT
ARE IMPACTED WOULD LOVE TO
EXPAND THE PROGRAM TO BE ABLE TO
OFFER MORE ACCESS TO LOCAL
STUDENTS AND AND STUDENTS WRIT
LARGE ACROSS STATE.
WHAT YOU END UP HAVING IS THAT
THE MORE CAMPUS IS THAT YOU HAVE
AN ESPECIALLY IF IT'S A BRAND
NEW CAMPUS?
YOU YOU REALLY HAVE TO JUGGLE
THAT THAT.
FEEDING OF YOUR TWENTY THREE
THEN TWENTY FOUR KIDS RIGHT AND
YOU HAVE TO SPREAD A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT IS NEW TO
THE UNIVERSITY.
WE NEED MORE MONEY FROM US.
YES OKAY THAT'S PERRANCE WELL NO
OKAY GOOD GOOD AND THEN THE
BILLION DOLLARS SPECIALLY
SPECIALLY IF YOU KNOW YOUR WHEN
YOU'RE HIRING ADDITIONAL FOLKS
AND THEN IF THEIR SALARY
INCREASES SECOND RIGHT THERE'S
THAT DISTANCE A LARGER
UNIVERSITY MEANS OF LARGE COSTS
RIGHT.
TOTALLY MAKES SENSE THE BILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S WHAT IT COSTS TO
GET YOU SEE MERCED UP AND
RUNNING BUILT FALL -- FOR THEY
DID START WITH A SMALLER AMOUNT
JUST LIKE WE STARTED WITH
SMALLER DOLLARS IT CHANNEL
ISLANDS AND MONTEREY BAY AS WE
BUILD FACILITIES BASED ON
PROJECTED ENROLLMENT.
BUT OVER THE COURSE OF TIME IT
EASIER SAID THEY'RE GOING MUCH
FASTER THAN CERTAINLY WORK WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO DO.
THAT BALANCING THE NEEDS OF THE
OTHER CAMPUSES YEAH I WOULD
THINK A IMMEDIATELY OUT OF THE
GATE IT WOULD PROBABLY BE CLOSE.
TO AB SEVENTY EIGHTY MILLION AS
FAR AS INITIAL FACILITIES.
DID WE GIVE YOU THE MONEY FOR
YOU SEE MORE SAID MEANING THE
STATE THERE ARE SOME THEY'VE
DONE SOME SELF FUNDING BUT ALSO
SOME PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIPS
AND A LARGE AMOUNT.
OF THE CITY COMES BACK AND SAYS
A NEW CAMPUS IS WARRANTED IN
CHULA VISTA OR STANTON NO.
STOCKTON EXCUSE ME -- THEN WE
WOULD NEED TO COME UP WITH SOME
MONEY A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONEY FOR THAT SEVENTY TO EIGHTY
MILLION A LOT.
YES NOT A BILLION BUT A LOT.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU WHAT WILL I
ASSUME YOU DO YOUR CAPITAL
PROJECTS WITH BINDING CAPACITY
DON'T YOU.
MOST RATES WHAT RECENTLY WE'VE
BEEN USING OUR OWN CAPACITY
THAT'S CORRECT.
WELL SO IF IF IF IF THE
ADMINISTRATION PROPOSES AND
LEGISLATURE PROVES IN
CONJUNCTION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION.
A NEW CAMPUS.
IT'S INCUMBENT ON THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO PROPERLY FUNDED
BOTH IN TERMS OF OPERATING
REVENUE [inaudible]
AND SUPPORT FOR THE THE CAPITAL
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS ARE
NECESSARY WHETHER IT'S YOUR OWN
BONDS OR SOME OTHER MEANS OF
FINANCING THE CAPITAL
IMPROVEMENTS RIGHT.
I DIDN'T IN THE GOVERNOR'S AT
OUR PROPOSAL TODAY GOVERNOR WE
REQUESTED EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS
IN PERMANENT BASE FUNDING FOR
FACILITIES INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO IT WOULD IT WOULD NEED TO
INCREASE FROM THAT AMOUNT THE
GOVERNOR DID NOT SUPPORT THAT
BUT THAT WAS OUR REQUEST.
WELL AND OF COURSE THIS ISSUE IS
SIMPLY A STUDY NOT.
TO TALKING ABOUT ESTABLISHING
NEW CAMPUSES.
MY QUESTION WAS IF IF THE
ADMINISTRATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- WANT TO TRY TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR COLLEAGUE AND
TAKE A LOOK AT WHETHER THERE
SHOULD BE AT LEAST A SATELLITE
CAMPUS IT'S NOT SOMETHING ELSE
CHULA VISTA.
COULD THAT BE ADDED TO THE STUDY
AND I GUESS THE ANSWER IS YES.
AND THEN THE QUESTION IS HOW
MUCH ADDITIONAL MONEY WOULD BE
REQUIRED AND IT'S NOT DOUBLING
BUT IT WOULD CERTAINLY BE MORE
THAN THE TWO MILLION DOLLARS
CURRENTLY PROPOSED.
MISTER CHAIR IF I MAY JUST MAIL
ABSOLUTELY -- JUST TO PROVIDE A
LITTLE BIT OF CONTEXT AS WELL
FOR THE PROPOSAL THE
ADMINISTRATION IDENTIFIED THE
SAN JOAQUIN AREA SPECIFICALLY
FOR THIS PROPOSAL -- LARGELY
BECAUSE OF A FEW DEMOGRAPHIC.
FACTORS THAT WE'VE SEEN SO ONE
BEING THAT REAL PERSONAL INCOME
IN THE EGION IS CONSIDERABLY
LOWER THAN THE STATEWIDE AVERAGE.
AND ALSO THAT -- UNEMPLOYMENT IS
NEARLY DOUBLE THE STATEWIDE
AVERAGE THOSE ARE BASED ON
TWENTY SEVENTEEN INFORMATION.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN IN THAT REGION
AN INCREASING NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES ALTHOUGH
THERE'S A LOWER THAN STATEWIDE
AVERAGE NUMBER THAT MEET
CRITERIA CURRENTLY FOR YOU SEE
OR CSU ADMISSION.
THE PART OF THE RATIONALE IN
LOOKING AT A POTENTIAL CAMPUS IN
THAT REGION WOULD BE WITH THE
IDEA OF CONSIDERING WHETHER IT
WOULD HAVE.
ECONOMIC GROWTH BENEFITS IN THE
AREA WHETHER IT WOULD ALSO --
LAND KIND OF THE CULTURE OF
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN THAT
AREA AND KIND OF STOP SOME OF
THOSE HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES THAT
WERE CURRENTLY SEEING.
GRADUATING AT INCREASING NUMBERS
BUT NOT NECESSARILY CURRENTLY
MEETING THE ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA
THAT WE WOULD LOOK FOR OUR FOUR
YEAR INSTITUTIONS -- REGARDING
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT ADDING
POTENTIALLY CHULA VISTA TO THE
STUDY BUT SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD NEED TO TAKE BACK BECAUSE
AT THIS POINT.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS AS YOU
KNOW FOR THE PROPOSAL
SPECIFICALLY IDENTIFIED SAN
JOAQUIN BUT WE CAN TAKE THAT
REQUEST BACK.
AND AS YOU MENTIONED WERE NOT
PRESUPPOSING IN THE PROPOSAL
THAT THERE WOULD BE A NEW CAMPUS
ASSEMBLY THAT WOULD BE A STUDY
TO EXAMINE.
THE POTENTIAL MERITS OF HAVING A
CAMPUS AND THE DETAILS OF WHAT
CRITERIA WOULD BE EXAMINED AS
PART OF THAT STUDY WILL BE
FORTHCOMING.
WITHIN A REVISION IN THE BUDGET
BILL LANGUAGE BUT CERTAINLY ONE
ASPECT WE WOULD EXPECT TO LOOK
AT WOULD BE THE FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS IF THERE THERE WERE
TO BE A NEW CAMPUS PROPOSED.
WELL CLEARLY THERE A LOT OF
NEEDS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN.
OF THERE'S NO QUESTION IN MY
MIND THAT THIS IS PROBABLY ONE
OF THEM WHETHER IT'S FINANCIALLY --
PRACTICAL AT THIS TIME.
THAT'S WHAT THE STUDIES GOING TO
GOING TO REFLECT AND REVEAL
ALONG WITH THE DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
THAT YOU -- YOU REFERENCED BUT
PERHAPS YOU COULD TAKE A LOOK
SINCE WE'VE HAD A COLLEAGUE WHO
IS RAISE THE CHILDREN'S.
TO ISSUE. ONE ADDITIONAL COSTS
THAT WOULD -- WOOD.
WHAT ADDITIONAL COST WOULD
RESULT FROM ADDING THAT TO THE
STUDY? TO DETERMINE YES OR NO
HOURS OF THE CAMPUS RECITAL
LIGHT IS THERE A NEED -- NOT
THAT THAT'S AN ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL BUT I WOULD BE
INTERESTED.
IN HAVING SOME IDEA FROM FROM
FINANCES TO WHAT DO YOU THINK
THAT WOULD ADD TO THE TO THE
PROCESS I CAN CERTAINLY TAKE
THAT BACK THANK YOU PERFECT
THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT TO THE PRESENTATION I
LOOK FORWARD -- TO THE RESULTS
OF THE STUDY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR EFFORTS.
IF YOU SEARCH SIX IS A HOLD OPEN
ITEM WE WILL REVISIT THAT.
AT A LATER DATE LET'S GO BACK TO
THE BEGINNING OF THE AGENDA
WE'RE AGAIN WE'RE ON ITEM SIX
SIX ONE ZERO CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS
BUDGET OPERATION.
THAT THE SAME TEAM OKAY WHO
WANTS TO PRESENT.
YOUR RECORD DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED NINETY
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND
ONGOING FOR OPERATIONAL COSTS AT
THE CSU.
THIS FUNDING WOULD SUPPORT
CRITICAL OPERATIONAL NEEDS
IDENTIFIED BY THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
INCLUDING CONTRACTUALLY
OBLIGATED COMPENSATION
COMPENSATION COMMITMENTS.
NON SALARY COST INCREASES AND
OTHER.
OPERATIONAL COSTS.
THIS INVESTMENT AS PART OF MORE
THAN THREE HUNDRED MILLION IN
NEW ON GOING GENERAL FUND
INVESTMENT PROPOSED FOR VARIOUS
PER PRIORITIES OUT THE CSU IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
AS DISCUSSED IN A PREVIOUS
HEARING THE SIGNIFICANT OVERALL.
ADJUSTMENT THAT'S PROPOSED FOR
THE CSU IN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
COMES WITH AN ADMINISTRATION
EXPECTATION THAT TUITION REMAIN
FLAT.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THE
ACCESS INCREASES AND THAT TIME.
TO AGREE CONTINUES TO IMPROVE.
WE'RE PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
JANUARY BOARD OF TRUSTEES
MEETING CHANCELLOR WHITE
ANNOUNCED THAT TUITION WILL
REMAIN FLAT AT THE CSU.
FOR TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND I
AM HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU.
WITH RESPECT -- TO SUPPLEMENTAL
TUITION CHARGE IN ESSENCE THE
NON RESIDENT TUITION AND THE
ISSUE.
HOW IS THAT -- HOW IS THAT
HANDLED IN TERMS OF?
BEING DISTRIBUTED IS IT RETAINED
ON THE CAMPUS WHICH GENERATED OR
DOES IT GO INTO THE SYSTEM AND
THEN IS IT RE DISTRIBUTED. TO
ALL THE CAMPUS IS BECAUSE I
ASSUME WITHOUT REALLY KNOWING
THAT THERE.
ARE SOME -- SEE ISSUE
INSTITUTIONS TO DRAW MORE NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS AND OTHERS ARE
YOUR ASSUMPTIONS CORRECT ON ON
AS HAVING MORE NON RESIDENTS AT
SOME GAPS IN THE OTHER.
I'D WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT THE
CAMPUS -- COLLECTS THAT TO WITH
THAT SUBLIMINAL TUITION REVENUE
AND RETAINS IT AND USE THAT TO
EDUCATE THE STUDENTS THAT THEY
ARE -- EDUCATING ON NONRESIDENT
STUDENTS.
WE HAVE THE SAME ISSUE IT TO IN
THE UC SYSTEM AS WELL IT'S IT'S
SORT OF FASCINATED ME.
BECAUSE THE THE MARGINAL COST OF
EDUCATING THE STUDENT IS
PROBABLY THE SAME.
DOESN'T COST ANYMORE AN EDUCATED
NON RESIDENT SOMEBODY FROM
ARIZONA THAN IT DOES FROM
CALIFORNIA I ASSUME. FOR DOING
THE ADMISSIONS PROPERLY.
AND SO THERE'S A DELTA THERE AND
AND I'M WONDERING ABOUT THE
EQUITY IN IN TERMS OF ALLOWING
CAMPUSES TO RETAIN THE DELTA
JUST BECAUSE THEY OR ON THE
COASTER NEAR BEECHER PERHAPS
HAVE A SPECIALTY PROGRAM THAT.
THE TRACKS NONRESIDENT STUDENTS
WERE AS PERHAPS FRESNO WERE.
SAMBAR DINO OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
DOESN'T.
COULDYOU COMMENT A WELL IT'S
IT'S IT'S IT'S REALLY ADDED
THROUGH THIS REALLY REALLY A
TRICKY SITUATION -- SO IF WE GO
BACK MANY DECADES AGO THE WAIT
TO SEE ISSUE WAS STRUCTURED AND
FUNDED.
WAS AND A MODEL IN WHICH
WHATEVER TYPE OF PROGRAM YOU
OFFERED WOULD BE FUNDED BY THIS
BY THE MINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE.
ON A KIND OF A A TYPE OF DEGREE
SORT OF FUNDING LEVEL SO IF
ENGINEERING WAS MORE EXPENSIVE
THE C. SHE WOULD RECEIVE A TOUCH
MORE MONEY. TO TO PAY FOR AN
ENGINEERING MORE ADDITIONAL ARE
ADDITIONAL ENGINEERING SLOTS
PERSON MAY DISABLE A LIBERAL
ARTS SORT OF DEGREE.
SO THAT WAS A MODEL UP UNTIL
NINETY THREE NINETY FOUR TIME
FRAME.
THEN -- BECAUSE OF A SERIES OF
RECESSIONS THAT OCCURRED
INCLUDING THAT THAT ONE IN THE
EARLY NINETIES.
THERE WAS REALLY AID A DRIVE IN
THE SHIFT FROM THE STATE AS WELL
AS FROM THE C. ISSUES
PERSPECTIVE TO SHIFT TO MORE OF
WHAT WE CALL INCIDENT INPUT
MODEL WHAT WE HAD BEFORE MORE OF
A REVENUE MODEL WHERE.
WHATEVER THE STATE COULD PROVIDE
IN TERMS OF FUNDING OF THE
UNIVERSITY THERE IS AN AVERAGE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING ON A PER
STUDENT BASIS THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO THE UNIVERSITY. TO THAT
EDUCATE A WHOLE VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SO HE
RECEIVED.
WHAT WE CALL THE MARGINAL COST
OF ADDITIONS -- FUNDING.
WHICH YOU SEE IN YOUR IN YOUR IN
YOUR AGENDA.
THERE'S AN AVERAGE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT IS PROVIDED TO
SERVE ANY AND ALL TYPES OF
DEGREES GRADUATE.
DEGREES AS WELL AS UNDERGRADUATE
DEGREES RIGHT.
SO WHAT WE HAVE TO DO IS WE HAVE --
TO THEN -- ALLOCATE THAT FUNDING
TO CAMPUSES AND THEY HAVE TO
MAKE A DETERMINATION BASED ON
THAT FUNDING WHETHER THEY'RE
ABLE TO OFFER -- YOU KNOW MORE
ENGINEERING WITH THAT FUNDING OR
MORE LIBERAL ARTS.
SORTS OF PROGRAMS THAT SORT OF
THING.
NOBODY COMES DOWN -- TO THE IDEA
OF REGION ALLERGY AND THOSE
SORTS OF THINGS -- IT ALSO IS
VERY TRICKY RIGHT BECAUSE COSTS
ARE HIGHER IN DIFFERENT AREAS --
BUT ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE DO -- IS
IS ON AVERAGE -- YOU KNOW LIKE
YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT WE HAVE
AN AVERAGE.
COST PER STUDENT -- SOMEWHERE
BETWEEN FOURTEEN TO FIFTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS THIS IS YOU
KNOW WHETHER THEY'RE NON
RESIDENT RESIDENT STUDENTS.
AND THAT'S ACROSS ALL MODES IN
LEVELS AND THAT KIND OF THING.
AND SO ESSENTIALLY GETTING TO
YOUR POINT OF THE NON RESIDENT
NON RESIDENT.
TUITION BOTH THE SYSTEM WIDE
TUITION AMOUNT WHICH EVERY
STUDENT PACE FIVE THOUSAND SEVEN
FORTY TWO PLUS THE SUPPLEMENTAL.
THE NONRESIDENT PACE THAT
ESSENTIALLY COVERS -- THEIR
THEIR EDUCATION -- SO THAT YOU
DON'T HAVE A SITUATION WHERE THE
STATE IS AT ALL SUBSIDIZING NON
RESIDENT STUDENTS FROM A FISCAL
VANTAGE POINT.
SO I HOPE THAT'S HELPFUL WELL I
I AGAIN IT IS PROBABLY NOT.
THE PLACE FOR THIS.
FOR POLICY DEBATE I GUESS BUT IT
DOES INTEREST ME BECAUSE YOU
COULD EVEN REALIZE IT IN TERMS
OF FIGURING OUT WHAT YOUR MA
MARGINAL COST OF EDUCATION IS IF
IT SAN LUIS OBISPO IS MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN FRESNO THEN.
YOU COULDN'T FIGURE OUT WHAT THE
COST OF EDUCATING STUDENTS
[inaudible]
AT THE AT SAN LUIS OBISPO IS AND
THEY'RE STILL GOING TO BE A
DELTA.
BETWEEN WHAT THE A NON RESIDENT
PAYS AND WHAT THE COST OF
EDUCATING THAT STUDENT IS.
WHETHER IT'S ENGINEERING OR
WHATEVER YOU COULD EVEN.
PARTICULAR RISE IT TOO IN TERMS
OF DEPARTMENT OR SPECIALTY.
AND THEN OVER ABOVE THAT YOU
HAVE A DELTA SO FOR THOSE IN
THIS BUILDING WHO WERE
INTERESTED IN.
MAKING SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS GET INTO A PARTICULAR
SCHOOL.
IF THEY'RE QUALIFIED.
SPREADING THE NON RESIDENT DELTA
AMONG THE VARIOUS CAMPUSES WOULD
NOT ONLY SEEM TO ME.
BE MORE EQUITABLE SITUATION SORT
OF MAKING THE CANS IN THE CAMPS.
OUR HAVES AND HAVE NOTS SORT OF
EQUAL BUT IT MIGHT ALSO SERVE AS
A DISINCENTIVE -- WITH RESPECT
TO NON RESIDENTS OF APPLICANTS
SELECTION ENROLLMENT LOW'S REGIS
MY COMMENTS AND YOU DON'T HAVE
TO TAKE A POSITION ON THAT BUT I
I WOULD LIKE TO HAVE A CONTINUED
CONVERSATION BOTH WITH C. ISSUE
AND WITH YOU SEE ON THAT AND AND
AGAIN IF I'M WRONG WHICH IS.
TRUE.
A LOT OF THE TIME.
YOU'RE FREE TO LET ME KNOW BUT
JUST THINK ABOUT THAT WHICH WHAT
THE WHAT THE ONLY POINT ALL ALL
ALL ALL.
ALL MAKE HERE AT THIS POINT
BEFORE.
SO WE CAN KEEP THE HEARING GOING
ALONG.
IS THAT -- SYSTEM WIDE -- ABOUT
6% OF OUR STUDENT POPULATION ARE
NON RESIDENT STUDENTS SO IT'S
RATHER INSIGNIFICANT PRETTY
INSIGNIFICANT YOU KNOW THERE ARE
SOME MORE DESIRABLE CAMPUS
CAMPUSES AND OTHERS BUT IN TERMS
OF ARE WE AT YOU KNOW 203040%
WRIST AND NO NOT EVEN NOT EVEN
CLOSE IT'S PRETTY.
INSIGNIFICANT SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
SITUATION AT UC THAT'S CORRECT
SO YOU GET A GOLD STAR
[inaudible]
CENTER.
YES SIR QUESTION.
TOMORROW YEAH I I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION ON ON PAY HOW DOES THE
CSU COMPARE AND PAY TWO YEAR --
PROFESSORS TO OTHER UNIVERSITIES.
WELL WHAT WE DO -- IS WE THAT'S
A HARD QUESTION ANSWER.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN THE AUDIENCE WHO WILL
DISAGREE -- ON HOW I WOULD
ANSWER PER PERHAPS.
BUT GENERALLY SPEAKING I'LL SAY
HOW WE HANDLE IT FROM A SYSTEM
MY PERSPECTIVE.
WHICH IS OUR ATTEMPT IS TO
ALWAYS TRY OUR BEST TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SALARY INCREASES TO
OUR FACULTY AS MUCH AS WE CAN.
TO KEEP THEM COMPETITIVE IN THE
FIELD BUT AND ALSO KEEP THEM AT
A AT A POINT WHERE THEY CAN
ACTUALLY.
I LIVE IN THE AREAS IN WHICH
THEY LIVE -- AND AND I AND I
JUST ABOUT THAT SIMPLY BECAUSE
THERE ARE I'M SURE PLENTY OF
FACULTY MEMBERS THAT WILL SAY
WELL I TEACH IN SAN FRANCISCO
AND THAT'S COULD BE MORE
EXPENSIVE THAN WHEN YOU'RE
TEACHING MAYBE AN INTERLOCK KIND
OF A THING.
I THINK GENERALLY SPEAKING --
WHAT ARE -- COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING TEAM AT THIS AT THE
CHANCES OFFICE RESIDUES ALWAYS
TRIES -- TO DO INTERNAL ANALYSES
ABOUT WHERE ARE.
OUR PROFESSORS RANK IN TERMS OF
THE MARKET.
OKAY.
AND ONE THING THAT -- OUR
STRUCTURE ALLOWS IS FOR CAMPUSES
TO ATTRACT FACULTY AT THE
SALARIES THAT WILL ATTRACT THEM
TO THAT PARTICULAR CAMPUS -- AND
SO.
GENERALLY SPEAKING.
I I REALLY CAN'T SAY WHETHER.
SEE ISSUE.
FACULTY ARE PAID BETTER THAN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR YOU SEE
BECAUSE IT'S LARGER CAN BE
DEPENDED ON THAT PARTICULAR
FACULTY MEMBERS -- PREFERENCE I
MEAN AT THAT PARTICULAR FACULTY
MEMBERS -- POSITION IN TERMS
THEIR HIRING.
AND I REALLY DON'T HAVE THE DATA
THAT WOULD CROSS WALK OUT
BETWEEN -- ALL THE SEGMENTS
WOULD YOU HAVE WOULD YOU HAVE
ANY DATA LIKE THIS IN HIS COUNTY
MY COUNTY RIVERSIDE USERS COUPLE
SEE ISSUES THERE AS WELL AS A
NUMBER PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES THAT WOULD
THEY'RE ALL.
ECONOMICALLY OUTLINED PROBABLY
THE SAME HOUSING PRICES WHICH HE
SAID WOULD YOU HAVE ANY.
EMPIRICAL DATA ON OUT I DON'T
HAVE IT AT HAND RIGHT NOW BUT I
COULD ALWAYS PROVIDE SOME
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE
LATER ON IF YOU LIKE YEAH I I I
JUST WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT --
HOW'S YOUR RETENTION WHICH A
RETENTION RATE.
WELL I BELIEVE EVERY YEAR IF I
REMEMBER CORRECTLY -- THERE ARE
ABOUT SIX TO SEVEN HUNDRED TEN
YEAR TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
ODDS OF PERSONNEL THAT.
RETIRE SEPARATE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY -- SO WHAT WE DO IS
THAT WE ARE OBVIOUSLY EVERY YEAR
ATTEMPTING TO TRY.
TO FILL THOSE POSITIONS BACKED
OFFICE POSITIONS AS AS THEY
LEAVE -- AND GENERALLY -- OVER
THE LAST I THINK THREE TO FIVE
YEARS -- WE HAVE GAINED ON NET
ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED MORE --
TENURE TENURE TRACK FACULTY --
SO WE ARE LOSING FACULTY TO
OTHER INSTITUTIONS OR TO
RETIREMENT BUT WE ARE -- WE'RE
ALSO BACK FEELING AND AND ADDING
TO ONE OF THOSE ELEMENTS THAT
WERE KEENLY AWARE OF IN TRYING
TO MARRY OUR FACULTY TO IS THE
OUR GRADUATION ISSUE OF TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS THE NOTION
THAT WE ACTUALLY NEED TO OFFER
ADDITIONAL COURSES FOR ALL OF
OUR ALL OF OUR CURRENTLY.
ENROLLED STUDENTS SO THEY CAN
TAKE ADDITIONAL COURSES SO THEY
CAN GRADUATE.
IN A MORE TIMELY MANNER IF THEY
CHOOSE.
SO ONE OF THE BIG EFFORTS YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT LATER IS THAT
GRADUATION INITIATIVE AND PART
OF THAT IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF
THAT IS HIRING OF ADDITIONAL
FACULTY ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
RING SO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW.
DO YOU USE -- COMPARATIVE AND
COMPARED TO OR IN INSTITUTIONS
IN A IN TERMS OF SETTING SALARY
SCHEDULES FOR YOUR FACULTY.
I THINK WE DO FOR IN TERMS OF IN
TERMS OF DISCUSSING THAT ON IN
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING -- I THINK
IT WILL DEPEND UPON -- APART ON
A CASE BY CASE BASIS ON THE
CAMPUSES.
ABOUT THEIR PARTICULAR HIRING
PRACTICES BUT I I DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING AND FOR ME THAT I CAN I
CAN SHARE IT.
DID YOU OKAY.
YEAH YEAH YES SIR AND JUST.
TO ADD SOME MORE INFORMATION OUR
OFFICE ACTUALLY RECENTLY LOOKED
AT SALARIES OF PROFESSORS AT THE
CSU.
AND UC COMPARED TO PEER
INSTITUTIONS SO FOR CSU WE
LOOKED AT CSU TENURE TRACK
TENURED TENURE TRACK FACULTY
SALARIES COMPARED.
TO OTHER PUBLIC MASTERS LEVEL
INSTITUTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY.
AND WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT CSU --
ARE ON AVERAGE HAD HIGHER
SALARIES NOW THAT'S COMPARED TO
OTHER INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE LESS
EXPENSIVE PLACES LIKE IOWA BUT
THEY THEY TEND TO BE HIGHER WE
CAN GET YOU THAT.
WE WE JUST HAD A PUBLICATION IN
JANUARY THAT INCLUDED.
OTHERS DATA.
WITH REGARD TO RETENTION.
THE ONLY THING I'M AWARE OF IS
BACK IN THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
PRESENT A DID A COMPENSATION
STUDY AND PRESENTED ON THAT AT A
BOARD MEETING AND WHAT THEY
FOUND WAS THAT.
RETENTION RATES AMONG FACULTY ON
AVERAGE WERE LOWER THAN PEER
INSTITUTIONS AND THAT THEY WERE
GENERALLY ABLE TO ATTRACT A
COMPETITIVE POOL OF CANDIDATES
AND HIRE WHO THEY WANTED TO HIRE.
A SAID THAT WAS THE LAST A STUDY
I'M AWARE OF I I KNOW THAT.
CSU PERIODICALLY DOES THESE
SORTS OF STUDIES TO SEE WHERE
THEY STAND RELATIVE TO THEIR
PEERS IN THAT CAN HELP INFORM
THEIR BARGAINING COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING -- PROCESS SEES.
INTERESTING BUT IT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE DON'T YOU KNOW REGULARLY --
GO TO THE BOARD EVERY YEAR WITH
AND AND INFORM THEM OF IT'S IT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE PERIODICALLY
DO AS NEEDED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO WERE ISSUE
NUMBER TWO OBVIOUSLY ONE OF THE
HOLD OPEN ISSUE NUMBER TWO IS
ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDES SIXTY
TWO MILLION ON GOING GENERAL
FUND TO SUPPORT 2% ENROLLMENT
GROWTH AT THE CSU WHICH IS
EQUIVALENT TO APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN NEARLY ACTUALLY SAY.
SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENT.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
JOINT MERE PROCEED IF YOU WOULD
SIR THAT WOULD BE FINE YES SO
ENROLLMENT GROWTH IS JUST ONE OF
THE FUNDAMENTAL -- ISSUES THAT
THE LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO DECIDE
ON EVERY YEAR -- LEGISLATURE
REALLY HAS SEVERAL FACTORS TO
CONSIDER THIS YEAR WHEN
DETERMINING.
THE LEVEL OF ENROLLMENT GROWTH
FUNDING TO PROVIDE CSU.
FIRST TO ANSWER INTERESTINGLY
THE NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
IN THE STATE IS ACTUALLY
PROJECTED TO DECREASE SLIGHTLY.
THIS YEAR ARE WHICH WOULD MEAN
THAT ALL OF THE THING ST EQUAL
ENROLLMENT DEMAND FOR FRESHMAN
ADMISSION IN THE FALL.
FALL.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WILL
DECREASE SLIGHTLY AS WELL.
OF NOTE HOWEVER IS THAT CSU IS
BEEN DRAWING FROM WELL BEYOND
THE STATE'S LONGSTANDING
FRESHMAN ELIGIBILITY POLICY
WHICH LIMITS FRESHMAN ADMISSION
TO THE TOP 33% OF HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES.
LAST YEAR THE LEGISLATURE
LEARNED THAT CSU HAD BEEN DRYING
FROM JUST OVER 40% OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES THAT WAS DONE
THROUGH A STUDY THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FUNDED.
ARE AN UPDATED INFORMATION FROM
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION SUGGEST THAT CSU IS
LIKELY DRAWING FROM A EVEN
LARGER POOL TODAY.
THE LIKELY DUE IN PART TO THE
DRYING FROM.
BEYOND ITS TRADITIONAL
ELIGIBILITY POOL IN FALL TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN ABOUT NINETEEN
THOUSAND FRESHMAN APPLICANTS
PLUS AN ADDITIONAL TWELVE
THOUSAND TRANSFER APPLICANTS.
MET CS USE MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS BUT WERE NOT
ACCEPTED AT ANY.
CSU CAMPUS TO WHICH THEY APPLIED.
AND AS PAGE SEVEN OF YOUR GENDER
NOTE SEIZE APPLICANTS ARE KNOWN
AS DENIED ELIGIBLES THEY DIDN'T
GET IN ANYWHERE IT CSU EVEN IF
THERE WAS JUST ONE CAMPUS THEY
APPLIED TO THEY WOULD BE
CONSIDERED IT'S NIGHT ELIGIBLE
WITH THEM BUT THAT THAT'S THE
PROBLEM WITH THE STATISTIC RIGHT.
I MEAN IF I APPLY.
TO SAN DIEGO STATE AND DON'T GET
IN.
I AM A DESIGN ELIGIBLE EVEN
THOUGH.
I GUESS YOU'RE GONNA HAVE A
REDIRECTION POLICYTHAT YOU'RE
IMPLEMENTING EVEN THOUGH I
PERHAPS COULD HAVE BEEN AND
ADMITTED TO SEMBRA DINO OR
FRESNO WERE.
CHANNEL ISLANDS ARE MONTEREY BAY
RIGHT THAT THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S
RIGHT AND THAT'S SOMETHING THE
LEGISLATURE DOES NOT HAVE IS.
IS INFORMATION ON WHETHER THE
STUDENTS APPLIED TO A CAMPUS
BECAUSE IT WAS THEIR NEAREST
CAMP.
AND THEY WERE IN THAT REGION IN
THAT AREA THEY MIGHT BE ACROSS
THE STREET FROM SAN DIEGO STATE
IS DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO GO
ANYWHERE ELSE.
LEGISLATURE DOESN'T HAVE THAT
INFORMATION ALL WE HAVE IS THAT
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS.
ARE THAT APPLIED LAST YEAR THEY
DIDN'T GET IN INTO ANY CAMPUS
AND SOME CASES.
ARE YOU HAD YOU SEE STUDENTS
WERE APPLYING DOUBLE DOUBLE
CAMPUSES A LOT OF CASES THOUGH
IT'S APPLYING TO JUST ONE CAMPUS
MICHAEL LONG BEACH OR SAN DIEGO.
CAN WE JUST DON'T KNOW WHERE
THAT STUDENTS FROM THE IT WOULD
BE MORE TROUBLING IF THAT
STUDENT WAS OF A LOCAL STUDENTS.
AND JUST COULDN'T GET IN DESPITE
MEETING THAT MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS [inaudible]
SO.
KNOWING THAT THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
OF DENIED ELIGIBLES THE
LEGISLATURE.
MIGHT WISH TO PROVIDE ENROLLMENT
GROWTH TO TRY TO BRING DOWN.
THAT THAT UMBER THAT THIRTY
THOUSAND OR SO NUMBER.
IF THE LEGISLATURE WERE TO
DECIDE TO DO THAT.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND LEGISLATURE
MAKE IT CLEAR TO CSU WHAT THE
INTENTIONS ARE TO TO ADDRESS
THIS ISSUE OF TONIGHT ELIGIBLES
THAT WOULD BE REALLY HELPFUL FOR
CSU KNOWING THAT.
THEY CAN BETTER TARGET IN
CONCENTRATED ROMAN GROWTH FUNDS
IN THE CAMPUSES AND PROGRAMS.
THE HIGHEST ANNETTE ENROLLMENT
DEMAND.
AND AND AND BECAUSE OF THE
THIRTY THOUSAND THE DECLINE IN
WHAT HI HIGH SCHOOL ENROLLMENT
FOR EXAMPLE WE SEE.
IS REALLY NOT A RELEVANT.
STATISTIC IS AND WE'VE GOT
THIRTY THOUSAND FOLKS WHO.
CLEARLY.
MADE OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
AND ARE TRYING TO GET INTO SEE
ISSUE. ONE POINT ONE PHASE POINT
OR THE OTHER AND HAVE NOT BEEN
ABLE TO DO SO.
AT LEAST THE SCHOOLS WERE THEY
APPLIED.
WE'LL HAVE A CLEARER IDEA ONCE
WE GET THIS RE DIRECTION POLICY
IN PLACE MAYBE SOMEONE COULD
YEAH I DIDN'T MEAN TO CUT YOU
KNOW THAT'S THAT'S THE THE
SEGWAY REALLY IT TO THE CSU
CHANCES OFFICE TO TALK ABOUT
THEIR NEW.
AUTOMATIC REDIRECTION POLICY
THAT THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING RIGHT
NOW AND THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
WAS A HIGH PRIORITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE SO -- THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO SPEAK.
TO THE REDIRECTION POLICY AND
ALSO IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO KEEP IN MIND.
I END OF REALLY MONITOR WHAT
ACTUALLY HAPPENS WHETHER TO THE
EXTENT TO WHICH STUDENTS WHO ARE
REDIRECTED ACTUALLY DECIDE TO
ENROLL IN A REDIRECTION CAMPUS
BECAUSE I COULD HAVE SOME COST
SIMPLE -- IMPLICATIONS IN THE
OUT YEARS AT THE END SEE ISSUE
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT YOUR
REDIRECTION POLICY WHICH I HOPE
YOU'RE GOING TO DO -- WOULD YOU
ALSO TALK ABOUT THE THE SYSTEM
OF METRICS THAT I HOPE YOU HAVE
SET UP OR AT LEAST WILL CONSIDER
SETTING UP TO TRY -- TO GATHER
SOME INFORMATION ON THESE
QUALIFIED BUT DENIED -- FOLKS
THIS POOL AND WHY AND WHERE AN
THAT MAKES SENSE OKAY.
WHO'S UP THE MY KOLLEGAL BILL
THE NAIL ALL THOSE ALL THOSE
DOWN PRETTY WELL PERFECT.
GOOD MORNING I AM DOCTOR APRIL
GROWN DIRECTOR OF ENROLLMENT
MANAGEMENT SERVICES FOR ACADEMIC
AND STUDENT AFFAIRS THE CSU
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
YOU TODAY.
AS THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ACADEMIC YEAR BEGAN
OVER FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS WERE
ROLLED AND ROLLED ACROSS OUR
TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES.
THAT NUMBER REPRESENTS THE FIFTH
YEAR OF RECORD STUDENT
ENROLLMENT IN THE CSU AND NEARLY
THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS THAN JUST FIVE YEARS
AGO.
WELL THE CSU HAS BEEN LASER
FOCUSED ON IMPROVING DEGREE FOR
COMPLETION AND REDUCING TIME TO
DEGREE AS WILL BE DISCUSSED IN
THE NEXT ITEM WE'VE ALSO
MAINTAINED EMPHASIS ON OUR
MISSION OF ACCESS.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT POINT FROM
WHICH TO START OUR DISCUSSION
TODAY BECAUSE WHILE IN ROME IT
IS OFFER CONSIDER ONLY IN THE
CONTEXT OF ADMISSION OF NEW
STUDENTS.
THE MORE CRITICAL ELEMENT OF
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT IS SERVING
CONTINUING STUDENTS AS FOR THE
CSU THEY COMPRISE APPROXIMATELY
70% OF OUR ROOM IT.
THIS DELICATE BALANCE ACT OF
ENROLLMENT IS IMPERATIVE TO
MAINTAINING NOT ONLY ACCESS TO
THE CSU BUT AUTHENTIC ACCESS
WERE ALL STUDENTS SPOKE
CONTINUING IN NEW HAVE THE
SUPPORT THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND EARN A HIGH
QUALITY DEGREE IN A TIMELY
MANNER. FOR FALL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OVER THREE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS APPLIED FOR ADMISSION
TO THE CSU.
AS FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS. 77% WERE ADMITTED TO
THE CSU ULTIMATELY OVER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF
THOSE STUDENTS ENROLLED LAST
FALL.
A RECORD NEW STUDENT ENROLLMENT
AND OVER SEVENTEEN THOUSAND MORE
STUDENTS FOR THE FALL TERM THAN
JUST SIX YEARS AGO.
I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TREMENDOUS GROWTH OF THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR TRANSFER
PROGRAM WHICH WAS CREATED BY
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FORTY IN.
TWO THOUSAND TEN IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ALMOST TWENTY
TWO THOUSAND NEW TRANSFER
STUDENTS FROM CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARRIVED AT
THE CSU WITH AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE
FOR TRANSFER.
AND THAT'S ABOUT ONE THIRD OF
OUR ENTERING TRANSFER STUDENT
POPULATION.
THIS NUMBER IS A 60% INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF NEW TRANSFER
STUDENT WHO HAD EARNED IN AT T.
PRIOR TO TRANSFER COMPARED
220-001-42000.
FIFTEEN THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TREND BECAUSE TRANSFER STUDENTS
WHO HAVE EARNED IN AT T. ENTER
THE CSU BETTER PREPARED AND
HAVING COMPLETED SPECIFIC COURSE
WORK AFTER COMMUNITY COLLEGE
THAT SATISFIES AT LEAST HALF OF
THEIR CSU DEGREE REQUIREMENTS.
AT THE SAME TIME WE SEE THESE
TRENDS AND IMPROVEMENTS FOR
TRANSFER STUDENTS WE ARE
EXPERIENCING IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR THOSE STUDENTS ACTING HIGH
SCHOOL WHO SEEK TO ATTEND
COLLEGE AFTER GRADUATION.
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
EDUCATION REPORTS THAT ALMOST
50% OF LAST YEAR'S PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES COMPLETED THE
SET OF THE S. YOU AND YOU SEE
COLLEGE PREPARATORY COURSES
KNOWN AS A THREE G..
COMPARED 234% A DECADE AGO.
EACH YEAR WE CONTINUE TO SEE
MORE BETTER PREPARES STUDENTS
SEEKING A HIGH QUALITY
AFFORDABLE CSU DEGREE.
IN FACT OVER SIXTY EIGHT
THOUSAND MORE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS APPLIED FOR FALL
ADMISSION LAST YEAR THAN IN FALL.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN AS A
REFERENCE ERLIER PLANNING AND
MANAGING ENROLLMENT REQUIRES
CLOSE ATTENTION NOT ONLY TO NEW
AND FUTURE STUDENTS BUT AS
IMPORTANTLY ATTENTION TO THE
ENROLLMENT DEMAND AND CAPACITY
FOR CONTINUING STUDENTS.
ALL TWENTY THREE CSU CAMPUSES
USE A VARIETY OF STRATEGIES TO
MAX MAXIMIZE THEIR FINITE
ENROLLMENT CAPACITY THAT EXISTS
ON THEIR CAMPUSES. FOR EXAMPLE
CAMPUSES REGULAR.
CREATE AND REFINED AGREE ROAD
MAPS FOR FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
THESE ROAD MAPS ALLOW STUDENTS
AND COUNSELORS TO VIEW UPDATE A
SEMESTER BY SEMESTER PLAN.
CAMPUSES SUBSEQUENTLY USE THIS
DATA TO PLAN THE CLASS SCHEDULE
AND TO PROVIDE COURSES NEEDED
BASED ON THE STUDENT DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS PROVIDING OPTIMAL
PASSED FOR GRADUATION.
IN A TOOL FOR EFFICIENTLY
MANAGING ENROLLMENT.
STUDENT ROAD MAP DATA THE NUMBER
OF MAJORS PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS
AND PRIOR YEAR ENROLLMENT
PATTERNS ARE USED TO CONTINUALLY
ANALYZE COURSE DEMAND.
CAMPUSES PAY PARTICULAR CAN'T
ATTENTION TO HIGH DEMAND COURSES
PRIORITIZING CLASSROOM
SCHEDULING IN FACULTY
ASSIGNMENTS FOR THESE COURSES.
WITH SUPPORT FROM THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE CAMPUSES ARE
PROVIDING TRAINING AND RESOURCES
TO FACULTY TO REDESIGN COURSES
TO OPTIMIZE THE USE OF
TECHNOLOGY.
THIS INCLUDES MOVING COURSES TO
FULLY ONLINE OR HYBRID FORMATS.
IT ALSO INCLUDES THE USE OF
VIRTUAL LABS ENGAGING STUDENTS
IN EXPERIMENTS AND SIMULATIONS
THEIR INNOVATIVE ONLINE
TECHNOLOGIES.
FINALLY CAMPUSES ARE INCREASING
ADVISING RESOURCES AND
TECHNOLOGIES THAT SUPPORT
STUDENTS TO THEIR GRADUATION
GOALS AND HELP CAMPUSES MANAGE
ENROLLMENT.
ALL CAMPUSES USE A COMBINATION
OF THE AFOREMENTIONED STRATEGIES
TO MAXIMIZE STUDENT ACCESS TO
COURSES IN SUPPORT REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER OR NOT THE CAMPUS IS
IMPACTED.
HOWEVER ONCE THE STRATEGIES ARE
NO LONGER SUFFICIENT ON THEIR
OWN FOR MANAGING ENROLLMENT
CAMPUS MAY REQUEST TO DECLARE
IMPACTION TO BETTER CONTROL THE
ENROLLMENT OF NEW STUDENTS.
SHORTLY THE CSU WILL BEGIN THE
REDIRECTION OF FIRST TIME
FRESHMEN ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER AN UPPER DIVISION
TRANSFER STUDENTS.
WHO MEET CSU MINIMUM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND WE'RE NOT
ADMITTED TO ANY CSU CAMPUS THEY
APPLIED FOR FALL?
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN APPLICANTS
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE A FIRST
AND SECOND CHOICE CAMPUS TO HAVE
THEIR APPLICATION REDIRECTED.
ANY APPLICANT THAT DOES NOT
RESPOND WILL ALSO BE REDIRECTED
TO A CAMPUS THAT STILL HAS
CAPACITY TO ENSURE ALL CSU
ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS HAVE A SPOT
AT THE CSU IF THEY WANT TO
ATTEND.
IN CLOSING INDIVIDUAL CAMPUSES
IN THE CSU SYSTEM ARE CAREFULLY
BALANCING ENROLLMENT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR CONTINUING
STUDENTS SEEKING TO MAKE TIMELY
PROGRESS TOWARD THEIR DEGREE
WITH THE GROWING PERSPECTIVE
STUDENT POPULATION.
FROM CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOL AND
COMMUNITY CLLEGES WHICH IS
LARGER AND BETTER PREPARED AND
MORE DIVERSE.
CAMPUSES MUST CAREFULLY CONSIDER
AND EVALUATE THEIR CAPACITY AND
RESOURCES TO PROVIDE AUTHENTIC
ACCESS TO CONTINUING A NEW
STUDENT.
WITH OVER FOUR HUNDRED EIGHTY
FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS 94% OF
WHICH ARE FROM CALIFORNIA THE
CSU EDUCATES THE MOST APPLE.
I THINK ACNE KLAY ECONOMICALLY
AND ACADEMICALLY DIVERSE
UNIVERSITY STUDENT BODY IN THE
NATION.
STUDENTS FAMILIES AND SCHOOLS
HAVE ALL TAKEN THE RIGHT STEPS
TO PREPARE FOR COLLEGE BUT TO
MEET THE DEMAND FROM INCREASING
NUMBERS OF STUDENTS AND AS
IMPORTANTLY MEET CALIFORNIA'S
NEEDS FOR AN EDUCATED WORK FORCE
TO REMAIN COMPETITIVE IN THE US
AND GLOBALLY.
WE WILL NEED RESOURCES TO ENSURE
THAT WE CAN OFFER THEM A PLACE
THAT THE CSU.
THANK YOU MAY I BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
SO ON THE RE DIRECTION IF I AM
APPLYING AND I LIST OF SAN DIEGO
STATE IS MY NUMBER ONE AND CAL
POLY POMONA'S MY NUMBER.
TWO AND I DON'T GET INTO EITHER
ONE OFTHOSE IN MY RE DIRECTED.
SO CAL POLY AND SAN DIEGO STATE
WILL NOT BE ON THE LIST OF
CAMPUS IS THE STUDENT CAN CHOOSE
ALL WE HAVE A WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHT TO NINE CAMPUS NON
IMPACTED ONCE OKAY YES AND WE
ALSO HAVE A COUPLE ADDITIONAL
ONES THAT -- DETERMINED THAT
THEY NEED HAD CAPACITY TO
SUPPORT STUDENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE
EAST BAY AND SNOW MISSTATE HAVE
ALSO COMMITTED TO TAKING
REDIRECTED APPLICATIONS.
SO WE'RE GONNA HAVE EIGHT TO
NINE CAMPUSES MARITIME ACADEMY
ALSO HAS A COUPLE BUSINESS
PROGRAM SO FOR STUDENT WANTED TO
SELECT MARITIME ACADEMY THAT
WOULD ALSO WORK -- TO ANSWER ONE
OF YOUR EARLIER QUESTIONS WE ARE
ACTUALLY NOT ONLY ASKING THE
STUDENTS ARE THEY WHAT THEIR
FIRST AND SECOND CHOICE CAMPUSES
ARE WE ARE ALSO ASKING THEM UP
FRONT ARE YOU INTERESTED IN RE
DIRECTION.
IF THEY SAY NO WE'RE HOPING TO
AND HAVE THEM ANSWER A DROP DOWN
QUESTION AS TO WHY THEY'RE NOT
INTERESTED SO.
THEY CAN'T COMMUTE TO THE CAMPUS --
THEY'RE NOT INTERESTED IN THE
CAMPUSES THAT ARE AVAILABLE AND
THERE'S ALSO ONE OTHER -- THAT
THEY'RE ATTENDING ANOTHER
COLLEGE -- TO POINT OUT IN YOUR
AGENDA ON PAGE SEVEN THERE'S
SOME INFORMATION ABOUT SOME OF
THE STUDIES THAT WE HAVE DONE
ABOUT THE QUALITY.
IN HERE IT'S CALLED QUALIFIED
BUT DENIED STUDENTS AND WE
LOOKED AT THE STUDENT CLEARING
HOUSE DATA AND 75% OF THE
QUALIFIED BUT DENIED STUDENTS
ENROLLED.
ACTUALLY WERE AT OTHER HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS AND SPECIFICALLY
57% APPEARED TO BE ATTENDING A
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE EITHER YOU
SEE PRIVATE OR COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AND 18% ENROLLED IN OUT OF STATE
INSTITUTIONS SO ABOUT THIRTY
THOUSAND BETTER DENIED ELIGIBLE
A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF THEM ARE
BEING TAKEN CARE OF AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS WITHIN THE STATE.
BUT AS PART OF THE ROLL OUT OF
THIS RE DIRECTION POLICY.
I I YOU'RE YOU'RE GOING TO BE
COLLECTING DATA INCLUDING.
IF YOU DON'T WANT REDIRECTION Y.
KARATE SOME DATA POINTS THERE.
AND THEN PRESUMABLY GONNA YOU'LL
HAVE SOME DATA AS TO WHETHER
STUDENTS ACTUALLY ENROLL IN THE
SCHOOL TO WHICH THEY'VE BEEN
REDIRECTED -- WILL THERE BE SOME
REFINED -- DATA ANALYSIS AND
WILL THERE BE A REPORT THAT
GENERATES AT SOME POINT TO US IS.
TELL US HOW THIS PROP PROCESS IS
WORKING OF THIS PROGRAM IS
WORKING.
MAKES SENSE.
YES I'M NOT SURE IF THAT WAS
CALLED FOR IN THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE BUT I'M SURE IF IT WAS
REQUESTED WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
PRODUCE THAT ONCE WE HAVE FINAL
NUMBERS.
AFTER FALL NIGHT OF FALLS OUT
FALL TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
CENSUS GREEN BECAUSE IT WOULD
SEEM TO ME WHETHER WE GET IT OR
NOT YOU WOULD WANT IT RIGHT YOU
WANT TO KNOW.
HOW MANY OF THESE STUDENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN REDIRECTED ACTUALLY
ENROLL IN THE SCHOOL TO WHICH
THEY'VE BEEN RE DIRECTED?
YES BECAUSE WE NEED.
TO OF REDIRECTION IS NOT JUST A
AN INITIAL TIME PERIOD BECAUSE
WE NEED TO NOW SUPPORT THAT
INCREASE ENROLLMENT AT THE
CAMPUSES THAT THEY ACTUALLY
ENROLLED SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT THOSE STUDENTS OVER
THE FOUR YEARS OF THEIR DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS AS FRESHMEN OR TWO
YEARS AS TRANSFER.
STUDENTS SO WE ARE LOOKING AT
HOW.
WE WANT TO UNDER BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE
FOR DEMAND SO WE CAN HELP
CAMPUSES PLAN CORRECTLY IN THEIR
ENROLLMENT MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES
WITH THE CAMPUS IS THAT WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE RE DIRECTED
APPLICANT.
RIGHT AND IF THERE IF THE IF FOR
EXAMPLE THE NUMBERS SHOW THAT
THE 20% OF THE STUDENTS WHO WERE
REDIRECTED.
TO FRESNO DIDNOT OR MAYBE
THAT'S NOT A GOOD EXAMPLE CHICO
OR SOMEWHERE DID NOT IN ROLE
THERE THEN I WOULD THINK. TO THE
EXTENT THAT YOU CAN ENGAGE IN A
FURTHER ANALYSIS YOU WOULD WANT
TO KNOW WHY NOT.
BECAUSE MAYBE IT'S A MARKETING
EFFORT.
IT IDEALLY GIVEN THE COST OF
HIGHER EDUCATION WE WANT A
MAXIMA AND THE COST OF
FACILITIES AND ALL THE REST OF
IT.
WE WOULD WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE
CAPACITY WE HAVE IT ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO FILL THE HOLES AND
FILL THE GAPS AND FILL THE SEATS.
WERE THERE ARE SEATS STILL TO BE
FILLED SO I'M JUST CURIOUS YES
SIR WHAT CAN I ADD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT ABOUT THIS SO -- SO APRIL
TALKING FROM THE VANTAGE POINT
OF GETTING AS MANY THE STUDENTS
ARE ELIGIBLE OUT TO THE CAMPUSES
THAT HAVE SOME CAPACITY.
THE ONE CHALLENGE THAT WE HAVE
GOING FORWARD WITH THIS IS THAT
WE REALLY DON'T KNOW HOW MANY
WILL TAKE US UP ON THIS
REDIRECTION OFFER.
ON TOP OF THAT WE DON'T HAVE A
GOOD STE.
WE DON'T HAVE A SOLID STREAM OF
FUNDING.
AVAILABLE -- TO SUPPORT AND AND
AND AND AND A SIGNIFICANT
INCREASE ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
IF A NUMBER OF THE STUDENTS SAY
IF FIFTEEN THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
RE DIRECTED.
WE HAVE A COUPLE OF SPOTS OR
HANDFUL SPOTS ON SOME CAMPUSES
WHERE THEY ARE UNDER THEIR
FUNDED ENROLLMENT TARGETS
MEETING THERE'S THERE'S FUNDING
THAT IS ON THAT CAMPUS THAT
COULD.
ACTUALLY EDUCATE THOSE
ADDITIONAL SUITS AT SHOPPING GET
TO THAT FUNDED PERFECT.
FUNDED TARGET LEVEL.
IF WE HAVE A LOT MORE THE
STUDENTS.
END UP LANDING ON SOMEBODY'S RE
DIRECT CAMPUS WE HAVE TO FIND A
WAY TO PAY FOR THAT ADDITIONAL
ACCESS. ONE OF THOSE WAYS THAT
WE HAVE PLANNED FOR IS TO USE
THE ONE TIME ENROLLMENT FUNDING
THAT WAS PROVIDING THE BUDGET
LAST YEAR.
LAST YEAR RECEIVED RIGHT ABOUT A
HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
WE STILL HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILLION OF THAT THAT WE WOULD BE
ABLE TO TEMPORARILY.
SUPPORT THE STUDENTS FINANCIALLY
FOR THEIR FOR THEIR COURSES
THEIR SUPPORT SERVICES THAT SORT
OF THING.
BUT THAT'S ONE THING THAT WE ARE
VERY NERVOUS ABOUT WITH THIS
REDUCTION POLICY IS.
WHILE THE WELL WE DID HAVE A
REDIRECTION POLICY SET UP FOR
THE AT T. STUDENTS AND THERE ARE
VERY FEW OF THEM THAT TOOK US UP
ON THAT RE DIRECTION OFFER.
WE OUGHT WE DO BECAUSE WE DON'T
KNOW THE ANSWER TO THIS WE WE'D
WE'D WE'RE NOT SURE WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW MANY OF THE
STUDENTS WILL ARRIVE -- THAT
WILL TAKE US UP ON THAT RE
DIRECTION OFFER AND AND HOW WE
CAN SUSTAIN THEM NOT ONLY IN IN
A SHORT TERM BASIS FOR THOSE ONE
TIME MONIES BUT OVER THE LONG
HAUL.
THAT'S A SERIOUS ISSUE IN IRAQ
INCLUDING UNDERSTAND IT BUT I
ALSO AND I ALSO THINK THAT -- WE
NEED TO HAVE SOME ONGOING
CONVERSATION WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE IT'S THE SAME BUDGETING
ISSUE THAT YOU WILL FACE ANYWAY
WHERE.
YOU KNOW IF YOU'VE HEARD PLAN.
THE WAY WE BUDGET FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION WITHOUT HAVING SOME
SORT OF FUND.
THE KIDS SORT OF FLOATED IN AND
PROVIDE MONEY THROUGH
CONTINGENCIES FOR YOU.
THIS IS AN EVEN MORE SERIOUS ONE
BECAUSE APPARENTLY WE DON'T HAVE
THE DATA -- TO REALLY DO
ACCURATE PLANNING.
BUT WILL THE DIRECTION.
AS OF YET FIRST YEAR RIGHT RIGHT
NOW WHAT WE HAVE DONE THOUGH IS
THAT THE OF THE FUNDING THAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE.
ALLOCATED IN ROLE THAT
ENROLLMENT OF 2%.
ABOUT TO US SEVENTY THREE
HUNDRED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS WE HAVE ALLOCATED THAT
OUT TO ALL THE CAMPUSES.
RIGHT WE'VE WE'VE SPREAD THAT TO
THAT ENROLLMENT GROWTH.
AND TOLD THEM IF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL HOLDS YOU SANTA SPADE
HAVING THE ABILITY SERVE AN
ADDITIONAL SEVENTY THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS.
THAT MAY CUT DOWN ON THE NUMBER
OF REDIRECTED FROM YOU KNOW
THOSE PEOPLE WHO APPLY TO FRESNO
STATE.
AND YOU KNOW THERE'S MORE
CAPACITY THAN FRESNO STATE SO
THAT MAYBE THEY ARE HAVING TO BE
RE DIRECTED SOMEWHERE ELSE.
SO WE MAY BE ABLE TO HELP.
WE MAY BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH THE
FISCAL IMPACTS WITH AN F. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED 2% HOLDS.
AND THEN WE WILL BE ABLE TO USE
THE ONE TIME FUNDS TO A KIND OF
BRIDGE ANY ADDITIONAL STUDENTS
AND THEN REVISITED AND EVERY
VISIT LATER RIGHT ON REGIONAL
SUBSEQUENT YEARS RIGHT.
GOOD VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE I MEAN
IF YOU BELIEVE THE FOLKS AT TO
TALK ON THESE ISSUES THEY SAY WE
NEED ANOTHER MILLION.
BACHELOR'S DEGREE EMPLOYEES IN
THE WORK FORCE AND I THOUGHT
THAT DATE WAS TWENTY THIRTY I
COULD BE WRONG ON THAT IF THAT'S
THE CASE.
WE ABSOLUTELY NEED TO FILL THE
SEATS IN THE SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
CAPACITY AND WE NEED TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE TO GET THE MONEY. TO
TO DO THAT IF THE STUDENTS ARE
WILLING. TO GO TO CHICO OR
MONTEREY BAY CHANNEL ISLANDS SO
ENDED TALK ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
ISSUE VERY BRIEFLY -- OBVIOUSLY
SEE ISSUE AT ITS SCALE AND SIZE
WE MAKE ABOUT HALF OF THE
DEGREES THAT NEED TO BE EARNED
BY THAT TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE.
AND SO WHAT OUR PLAN IS IS -- TO
FOLD.
THAT WE CAN BRING MORE DEGREES
TO CALIFORNIA THROUGH OUR
GRADUATION ISSUE OF EFFORTS SO
THAT NEEDS TO BE FUNDED OVER TH
SIX YEAR SPAN.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT IS A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT ON
ENROLLMENT -- ON APRIL SIDE
RIGHT THAT WE ANTICIPATE THAT
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO ADD UPWARDS
OF 5% OF NEW ENROLLMENT PER YEAR
IN THE VERY NEXT TWO THREE FOUR
YEARS.
IN ORDER TO TO NOT ONLY HAVE
GREATER THROUGHPUT OF OUR
EXISTING GROUPS IT'S BETTER THAN
ALSO YOU AFTER HALF MORE
STUDENTS.
THAT ARE EARNING DEGREES BETTER
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO UNIVERSITY
RIGHT NOW.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO BALANCE THAT
WITH OUR BUDGET ASKING THAT'S
WHY YOU SEE US A CONSISTENTLY
COMING TO THE TO THE TO THE
CAPITAL REQUESTING GRAD ISSUE
FUNDING.
AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL IN ROME
THE FUNDING ESPECIALLY THIS YEAR
5% INCREASE I'M COMPLETELY
COGNIZANT OF THE DELTA BETWEEN
THE THE PROPOSAL AND AND THE
REQUEST AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
ENGAGE IN A CONVERSATION WITH
THE WITH ALL.
STAKEHOLDERS POSI ISSUE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON HOW WE SORT OF
CLOSE THAT GAP OF THE CRITICAL
ISSUES. FOR INTERESTED IN
MEETING THE NEED WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT TO GET MORE
PEOPLE GRADUATED WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET
MORE FOLKS -- IN THE PROGRAM'S
FALL WITHIN THE CONFINES OF OUR
BUDGETARY CHALLENGES SO WE'RE
GOING TO WORK ON THAT.
ONLINE MA'AM YOU MENTIONED JUST
ONE OTHER QUESTION ONLINE
EDUCATION I WAS PLEASED TO SEE
THAT REFERENCED IN YOUR REMARKS.
AND I KNOW THAT SEE ISSUE IS
STEPPING OUT SMARTLY IN THE AREA
OF ONLINE EDUCATION.
ARE YOU ABLE TO IS.
WITHIN YOUR SYSTEM.
CAMPUS TO CAMPUS IS THEIR CROSS
UTILIZATION OF ONLINE EDUCATION
SO IF I'M AT CHANNEL ISLANDS.
AND THERE'S AN ONLINE COURSE IT --
SEVEN CISCO OR ONE OF YOUR OTHER
CAMPUSES IN MY ABLE TO ACCESS
THAT IN IS HOW USER FRIENDLY IS
THAT SYSTEM IF I AM.
SO WE DO HAVE A PROGRAM THAT'S
CALLED CSU FULLY ONLINE IT WAS
FIRST STARTED I BELIEVE IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN BASED
ON AB.
THREE EIGHTY SIX AND HAT THAT
PROGRAM ALLOWS IS FOR STUDENTS --
TO THAT OUR CURRENT STUDENTS AT
ONE CAMPUS BE ABLE TO REVIEW ALL
ONLINE OFFERINGS BY OTHER
CAMPUSES THEY DO HAVE TO MEET
CERTAIN CRITERIA SO THEY HAD TO
HAVE AT LEAST ATTENDED TWELVE
UNITS.
AND ALSO HAVE A A TWO POINT OH
GPA NOT BE AN ACADEMIC TROUBLE
BEFORE THEY START AN ONLINE
CLASS BUT THESE CLASSES WERE --
HELP ACTUALLY DEVELOPED USUALLY
SPECIFICALLY TO ADDRESS ANY TYPE
OF BOTTLE NECK OR DEGREE
REQUIREMENTS THAT STUDENTS HAVE
THAT THEY CAN'T GET AT THEIR OWN
CAMPUS.
SO WE HAVE MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS TO FURTHER PROMOTE THAT
PROGRAM AND ALSO -- REDO THE
WEBSITE THAT STUDENTS USED TO
MAKE IT MORE USER FRIENDLY TO BE
ABLE TO SEARCH ACROSS THE
CAMPUSES.
IF A STUDENT DOES FIND A COURSE
THAT THEY ARE INTERESTED IN THEY
CAN ACTUALLY ENROLL FOR THAT
COURSE THROUGH THEIR CAMPUS
PORTAL SO IF I GO TO CAL STATE
NORTHRIDGE AND I WANT TO TAKE A
COURSE AT SAN DIEGO STATE -- I
CAN GO ON TO MY SELF SERVICE
WEBSITE IN NORTHRIDGE AND ENROLL
FOR THAT COURSE AT SAN DIEGO
STATE AND THEN SAN DIEGO
ACTUALLY RECEIVED THAT
INFORMATION THROUGH OUR CENTRAL --
TECHNOLOGY STUDENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM AND IS ABLE TO PROCESS
THAT STUDENT ENROLL THEM IN THAT
ONLINE COURSE AND WE HAVE SEEN
SIGNIFICANT INCREASES IN THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS AS WE'VE.
OP MORE HOLY PROMOTED THAT
PROGRAM OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS WE JUST ONE QUICK DO WE
HAVE DATA POINTS WHAT WHAT'S THE
UTILIZATION WHAT'S THE TAKE RATE.
I WE DO HAVE THOSE DATAPOINTS
BUT I DON'T HAVE THEM HERE WITH
ME TODAY THAT'S A GOOD THANK
YOUS.
YES SIR ACTUALLY THE DOCTOR
GRUNBAUM MENTIONED A. B..
THREE EIGHTY SIX WHICH REQUIRED
CSU DEVELOP ACROSS ENROLLMENT
SYSTEM FOR ONLINE EDUCATION.
THAT LEGISLATION ALSO REQUIRED
OUR OFFICE TO DO A REPORT ON
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED AND HOW
IS.
CSU PROGRESSING.
WE REALLY SAT REPORT IS A LITTLE
OVER A YEAR AGO -- SO IT'S IT'S
BEEN A LITTLE BIT OF A LITTLE
WHILE WHAT WE FOUND IN THAT
REPORT WAS THAT UTILIZATION WAS
ACTUALLY QUITE LOW BUT YET BUT
IT WAS IT.
AT NEW PROGRAM AT THE TIME I
THINK IT WAS JUST A FEW THOUSAND
STUDENTS SAID AVAIL THEMSELVES.
OF THE OPPORTUNITY TO CROSS
ENROLL IN ONLINE COURSES AT
OTHER CAMPUSES I COULD BE DUE TO
MARKETING WELL THAT'S WHAT WE
FOUND AND AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT IS RELATIVELY
WAS NOT RELATIVELY NEW.
AT THE TIME STUDENTS TO KNOW
ABOUT IT THERE'S ALSO AN ISSUE
OF THE PORTALS ACCESSIBILITY
USER FRIENDLINESS IF YOU WILL.
AND SO WE WE HAD RECOMMENDED
THAT.
CS YOU TAKE A LOOK AT THEIR
SYSTEM AND AND MAKE IT EASIER.
TO REGISTER FIND CLASSES AND
THEN ACTUALLY REGISTER IN THOSE
CLASSES CLOSE LIKE THE LITTLE
YOU SOMETHING IT'S SOMETHING I I
KNOW THAT I I'VE BEEN RECEIVING
SOME COMMUNICATION IS SOMETHING
THEY ARE WORKING ON GREAT.
PERFECT THANK YOU FOR TOLERATING
MY QUESTIONS ON THAT SITTING
FURTHER.
LET'S TALK ABOUT -- ISSUE NUMBER
THREE WHICH IS THE GRADUATION
AND APROPOS OVER A CONVERSATION.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FORTY FIVE MILLION ONGOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
CONTINUED PROGRESS FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AS OUTLINED
IN THE AGENDA CSU IS MADE
CONSIDERABLE PROGRESS TOWARD THE
GOALS OF THIS INITIATIVE WHICH
WAS ADOPTED BY THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET INVESTMENT WILL AID THE
CSU IN FURTHERING TIMELY
COMPLETION.
FINALLY GRADUATION I SHOULD SAY
FOR FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS AS WELL AS DECREASING
AT ACHIEVEMENT GAPS.
ALSO SORT OF A PROPOSES THAT TO
THE LAST ITEM WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT ENROLLMENT AND TIMELY
GRADUATION ARE.
INEXTRICABLY LINKED AS WHEN YOU
HAVE TIME THE GRADUATION OF YOUR
CURRENTLY ENROLLED STUDENTS THAT
ALLOWS ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT
WITH THE UNIVERSITY.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PRIORITIZES BOTH OF THOSE
PRIORITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE A I I SHOULD LET YOU
WILL.
FINISH PRESENTING BUT LET ME
JUST THROW OUT THIS QUESTION DO
WE HAVE ANY IDEA WHY.
WE HAVE A VARIATION. TO SOME
EXTENT FOR A SIGNIFICANT
VARIATION IN GRADUATION RATES
[inaudible]
BY CAMPUS [inaudible]
JENNIFER QUESTION.
YEAH GOOD MORNING CHUCKLED I'M
WITH THE SYSTEM OFFICES WELL
REDUCER YEAH IT'S A REALLY GOOD
QUESTION.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT OUR
STUDENTS IN DIFFERENT REGIONS
COME TO US WITH A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT -- ASPECTS SOME OF
THEM ARE -- LARGELY STAYING ON
CAMPUS SOME OF THEM ARE LIVING
AT HOME SOME OF THEM -- YOU KNOW
ARE WORKING MANY JOBS OTHERS
AREN'T SO THIS VARIATION YOU SEE
FROM COMMUNITY TO COMMUNITY
ACROSS OUR GREAT STATE.
IS INDICATIVE OF THE SAME TYPE
OF VARIATION YOU SEE ON OUR
CAMPUSES WAS A DIM IS LARGELY A
DEMOGRAPHIC KITCHENS CORRECT.
INTEREST YESTERDAY WELL I WOULD
I WOULD ADD SOMETHING ELSE AND
THAT'S YOU WE WE TALKED EARLIER
ABOUT IMPACTED CAMPUSES.
SO YOU HAVE MINIMUM SYSTEM WIDE
ELIGIBILITY REQUIREMENTS. TWO
TWO EVEN APPLIED IT TO CSU. TO
IT HISTORICALLY THAT'S BEEN
ENOUGH FOR STUDENTS TO GET INTO
THEIR CAMPUS AND THAT'S STILL
THE CASE IN A LOT OF CAMPUSES
THE DOMINGUEZ HILLS.
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY IF
YOU LIVE IN SACRAMENTO.
YOU GET THAT MINIMUM.
GPA AND OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL OR
SAT SCORE YOU'RE GOING TO GET
INTO THAT CAMPUS IN AND
HOPEFULLY INTO A MAJOR AS LONG
AS AT MAJORS NOT IMPACTION.
IMPACTED NOW YOU HAVE CERTAIN
CAMPUSES AT CSU WHERE THEY'VE
IMPACTED.
ALL ARE VIRTUALLY ALL OF THEIR
MAJORS THE CAMPUS IS IMPACTED IN
THE MAJORS IMPACTED.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO INCREASE THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS FOR
STUDENTS TO GET IN SO I COULD
CAL POLY.
YOU CAN APPLY TO CAL POLY WITH A
THREE OH GPA OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL
BUT IT'S UNLIKELY YOU'RE GOING
TO GET IN [inaudible]
SO.
CAMPUSES BY DECLARING IMPACTION
IN THEIR MAJORS IN THE PROGRAMS
THEY'RE ABLE TO INCREASE THE
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS TO GET INTO
THE SCHOOL INTO THE PROGRAM AND
AS A RESULT THSE CAMPUSES TEND
TO HAVE BETTER PREPARES SUDENTS
COMING IN.
AND HIGHER GRADUATION RATES IS.
FOLLOWS FROM THAT A LOT OF TIMES.
I DIDN'T MEAN TO TAKE YOU -- WE
WERE NEXT ANYWAY ON THE
PRESENTATION I THINK SO.
YES I AM THRILLED YOU BUT I'M
GONNA PUT YOU BACK ON THE TRACK.
THE GOOD.
SO AS YOUR AGENDA NOTES ON PAGE
TWELVE A CSU CURRENTLY
DESIGNATES ONE HUNDRED NINETY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS.
IN ONGOING RESOURCES FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL WOULD
INCREASE SPACE FUNDING TO TWO
HUNDRED AND FORTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS.
WHICH IS A 23% YEAR OVER YEAR
INCREASE.
AS THE FIGURE ON PAGE TEN SHOWS
CSU CONTINUES TO IMPROVE
GRADUATION RATES FOR BOTH FIRST
TIME FRESHMEN AND TRANSFER
STUDENTS.
GAPS IN GRADUATION RATES IS MORE
OF A MIXED STORY GAPS AMONG
CERTAIN REGIONAL RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUPS.
HAVE NARROWED ALBEIT SLIGHTLY
AND IN ADDITION DATA INDICATES
STUDENTS ARE GRADUATING WITH
YOUR ACCESS UNITS WHICH IS GOOD
NEWS FOR THEM FOR THE STUDENTS
STAY THERE THIRDS PAYING LESS.
THAN THEY WOULD OTHERWISE GOOD
FOR THE STATE AND ALSO IT FREES
UP SOME COURSE LOTS RATHER
STUDENTS WHO NEED THE WHO NEED
THOSE COURSES GRADUATE.
SO OVERALL CSU SHOWING
IMPROVEMENT IN A NUMBER OF AREAS --
PERTAINING TO STUDENT
PERFORMANCE AND IF THE
LEGISLATURE CHOOSES TO CONTINUE
SUPPORTING THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE GOING FORWARD WE
RECOMMENDED LINK FUNDING -- FOR
FOR THE INITIATIVE TO AN
EXPECTATION THAT CSU CONTINUE TO
MAKE PROGRESS.
IN THESE KEY AREAS YOU KNOW AND
GRADUATION RATES NARROWING
ACHIEVEMENT CRACKED GAPS.
BECOMING MORE EFFICIENT BY
REDUCING EXCESS UNITS. ONE WAY
CSU COULD CREATE A BETTER
INCENTIVE FOR STUDENTS TO AVOID
ACCESS UNIT ACCUMULATION AND
MAXIMIZE AID FOR OTHER STUDENTS
WOULD BE TO MODIFY A POLICY.
ARE THAT THEY CURRENTLY HAVE ON
THEIR INSTITUTIONAL AID PROGRAM
STATE UNIVERSITY GRANTS.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS CAN RECEIVE A
CSU GRANT FOR UP TO ONE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY UNITS WHICH IS ONE
FOUR YEARS WORTH OF UNITS BEYOND
WHAT A STUDENT TYPICALLY NEEDS
TO GRADUATE WITH A BACHELOR'S
DEGREE.
BY CONTRAST STATE LAW LIMITS CAL
GRANTS THE STATE FUNDED CAL
GRANTS TO FOUR YEARS OF FULL
TIME.
ATTENDANCE OR ITS EQUIVALENT
WHICH IS A HUNDRED TWENTY UNITS.
ANOTHER WAY FOR CSU TO FURTHER
REDUCE ACCESS UNITS WOULD BE TO
LIMIT THE NUMBER OF TIMES A
STUDENT CAN.
TAKE AND REPEAT A COURSE. FOR
BETTER GRADE -- MOST CAMPUSES
ALLOW STUDENTS TO TAKE THE SAME
COURSE FOR UP TO THREE TIMES
STUDENTS TYPICALLY ARE ALLOWED
TO REPEAT UP TO TWENTY EIGHT
UNITS OF COURSE WORK IN THIS WAY.
WE RECOMMEND ENACTMENT OF A
SYSTEM WIDE POLICY THAT LIMITS
STUDENTS TO TAKING THE SAME
COURSE FOR BETTER GRAY TWO TIMES.
WHICH IS ACTUALLY ALREADY THE
POLICY AT A NUMBER OF OF CSU
CAMPUSES.
AND I ACTUALLY I KNOW I KNOW
YOU'RE FROM GIVEN WHERE YOU'RE
FROM US CAL STATE SAN BERNARDINO
IS LOOKING AT REDUCING CURRENTLY
THEY ALLOW STUDENTS TO TAKE A
COURSE THREE TIMES FOR A BETTER
GRAY AND THEY'RE LOOKING AT
REDUCING NEXT TO SO THIS IS
SIMILAR TO WHAT SALMON A DINO.
IS LOOKING TO DO -- AND GIVEN
THAT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
DOESN'T CURRENTLY COLLECTED ON
UNITS ACCUMULATED DURING TO DO
TO COURSE REPETITION THE
LEGISLATURE COULD REQUIRE CS YOU
REPORT THIS DATA.
AS PART OF ITS ANNUAL
PERFORMANCE REPORT THAT OUR
RELEASES IN MARCH TYPICALLY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WELL.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT I'M AS OLD
AS METHUSELAH -- HIGH -- THIS
CONCEPT OF TAKING COURSES TWO OR
THREE TIMES TO GET A BETTER
GRADE IS -- SOMETHING THAT I'D
NEVER HEARD OF UNTIL I CAME TO
CALIFORNIA SO.
BUT OF COURSE SAID YOU KNOW I
WENT TO SCHOOL IN THE DARK AGES
AND I DON'T REMEMBER BEING ABLE
TO DO THAT.
OR MAYBE I TO HAVE A BETTER
CAREER SOMEWHERE.
CAN CAN YOU ADDRESS THAT IS THAT
A REAL PROBLEM HERE IN THE STATE
I MEAN I DON'T I DON'T.
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND -- MAYBE
DID SO WELL THAT YOU DON'T NEED
A CLATTER HAVING YOUR APPEARING
OVERLY KIND -- I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THIS WORKS WELL
SO I'M NOT GONNA GO INTO A LOT
OF GIVEN THE BUDGETARY
CONSTRAINTS THAT WE HAVE IN THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE CAMPUS IS THAT --
CLOGGED UP IMPACTED AS WE SAY
AND TRYING TO GET STUDENTS AND
SEATS AND MEET THE MILLION.
BACHELOR'S DEGREE SHORT TARGET
BY TWENTY THIRTY YOU WE NEED THE
SORT OF FIGURE OUT IS A IS A BE
GOOD ENOUGH OR DO I NEED TO HAVE
AN A AND YEAH THAT TYPICALLY
DOES NOT HAPPEN AND I WOULD SAY
IN THE GRAND SCHEME OF THINGS OF
ALL OF THE ISSUES.
WE'RE LOOKING AT WE'RE LOOKING
AT SCARCITY OF ACROSS
ENROLLMENTS WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
AND ALSO WITH COURSE TASTING
COURSE COURSE TAKING WERE YOU
KNOW WE HAVE ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES
REALLY LOOKING AT THAT KNOWING
THAT IF YOU TAKE EXTRA COURSES --
YOU MAY BE TAKING THE SEAT OF
SOMEONE ELSE ESSENTIALLY SO
THERE IS SOME INSTANCES OF
STUDENTS REPEATING A COURSE FOR
EXAMPLE IN AN AREA THAT'S VERY
COMPETITIVE LIKE NURSING.
BUT BUT IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA
THAT WE USED TO HAVE ON THAT
WHEN THE PREVALENCE OF THAT HAS
GONE DOWN TREMENDOUSLY.
OUR CAMPUSES ARE REALLY MINDFUL
OF THE FACT THAT -- YEAH THEIR
POLICIES ARE LIMITED WHAT DO WE
HAVE SYSTEM WIDE DATA AND IF NOT --
MAYBE THAT'S SOMETHING WE NEED
TO TAKE A LOOK AT BECAUSE I
WOULD THINK THAT WOULD E OF
INTEREST CERTAINLY IS OF
INTEREST. TO ME AND AS LONG AS I
HAVE THIS ASSIGNMENT THIS BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE MAYBE THAT'LL AND
SOON -- BUT I THINK WE NEED TO
WE NEED TO START COMPILING SOME
SYSTEM I DID IF IN FACT IT'S
IT'S A PROBLEM THAT'S WHY IT'S
FOR OUR AN ISSUE THAT'S
WIDESPREAD I'M NOT CALLING IT A
PROBLEM I MEAN IT'S JUST TO BE
CLEAR THE POLICY OF THE CAMPUSES.
IS FOR STUDENTS THAT ET A THE
THAT FAIL WE'RE GONNA DE OR EVEN
A C. MINUS SO IF THEY GET A A C.
MINUS.
THEY WOULD BE ALLOWED TO REPEAT
THE COURSE IF THEY GET SAY
ANOTHER SEE MINUS A. B. L. LOUD
REPORT THE COURSE AGAIN
CURRENTLY IF THEY DO GET AN A OR
B. THEY ARE NOT ALLOWED TO
REPEAT A COURSE FOR THE PROBLEM
CAMPUSES.
CAMPUSES I'VE SPOKEN WITH HAVE
HAVE IDENTIFIED AS THEIR NOT
DOING STUDENTS ANY FAVORS IF
THEY'RE THEY'RE FAILING THEY
TAKE A GANDER FAILING AGAIN.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A DISCUSSION
ACTUALLY.
HOPEFULLY EARLIER ON AND WHEN
THE STUDENT GETS SAID INITIAL
LAUGH ABOUT.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN YOUR LIFE
LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR STUDY
SKILS LET'S TALK ABOUT YOUR
MATH SKILLS -- OR ENGLISH SKILLS
IS THIS REALLY THE RIGHT MAJOR
FOR YOU BUT IF IF YOU ALLOW THE
STUDENT TO FAIL.
FAIL AGAIN AND THEN TAKE IT A
THIRD TIME WHAT CAMPUSES.
ARE SAYING IS.
NOT NECESSARILY DOING STUDENTS
AND WITH AN EXPLANATION AXES
VERY VALUABLE TO ME SO FROM A
SYSTEM WIDE STANDPOINT I MEAN
WHAT.
THE THE SO THE POLICY ALLOWS
COURSES TO BE REPEATED BUT I
MEAN IS THERE SOME.
SUPPORT SYSTEM THAT THAT AND
THEN ATTACH IS TO THE STUDENT AT
THAT POINT.
TO BRING ABOUT A BETTER OR MORE
SUCCESSFUL RESULT IN IN DO YOU
HAVE THE THE COUNSELING STAFF TO
DO THAT ARE YOU UNDER FUNDED DO
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT I MEAN.
THERE IT SEEMS TO ME THEN BASED
ON THAT EXPLANATION THAT THERE
ARE A WHOLE.
LEVEL A SERIES OF ISSUES THAN
THAT THE POP ON THE RADAR SCREEN
AND NEED TO BE ADDRESSED RIGHT
YEAH THAT'S EXACTLY IT AND
THAT'S PART OF MY LARGER
TESTIMONY ON THE INTENTIONALITY
SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
THIS IS ONE ISSUE I DON'T MEAN
TO MINIMIZE IT NO BUT WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT -- EVERY ASPECT OF A
STUDENT'S ACADEMIC CAREER NOT TO
MENTION WHAT HAPPENS OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM.
THE REAL SPIRIT OF THE
GRADUATION THIS OF IS TO HAVE US
LOOK IN A DIFFERENT WAY.
OF HOW WE'RE SERVING OUR
STUDENTS -- AND WE'RE DOING THAT
ACROSS THE BOARD AND SO WHAT I
SHOULD DO IS LET YOU MOVE OF
WHOEVER'S NEXT BUT YOU MOVE ON
TO YOUR LARGER TESTIMONY AND
THEN I'LL.
HOLD MY QUESTIONS OR IS IT YEAH.
WONDERFUL ALTHOUGH I'M ENJOYING
THIS YEAH ME.
TOO BUT GO AHEAD YEAH CITY
THANKS AGAIN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
THIS IS REALLY A A PRIVILEGE FOR
ME TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY TODAY
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW ABOUT THREE
YEARS AGO WE SAT -- COLLECTIVELY
AS A SYSTEM SOME OF THE MOST
AMBITIOUS STUDENT SUCCESS
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE NATION.
AND EQUITY GOALS SUCH THAT -- BY
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WILL
BE BEAT THESE GOALS WE WILL
STAND ALONE AS THE PREEMINENT
FOUR YEAR PUBLIC COMPREHENSIVE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM IN THE NATION.
WITHOUT PEERS WHEN TALKING ABOUT
GRADUATION RATES AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT COMPLETION SO WE
REALLY SET THE BAR HIGH AND I'M
I'M FOR MARK I'M I'M I AM
THRILLED TO PRESENT.
SOME REMARKABLE RESULTS THAT
WE'VE HAD SO FAR SO ACROSS THE
BOARD NO MATTER HOW YOU LOOK AT
OUR GRADUATION RATES WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FIRST TIME
STUDENTS.
WE'RE TALKING MATTER TRANSFER
STUDENTS AND WHETHER YOU LOOKING
AT MALES FEMALES ALL GENDERS ALL
RACES WE ARE AT ALL TIME HIGHS
FOR COMPLETION RATES.
I MEAN THIS IS REALLY REMARKABLE
IN HISTORY THE CSU THERE IS
CURRENTLY NO BETTER TIME TO BE A
STUDENT YOUR OPPORTUNITY FOR
SUCCESS IS GREATER NOW.
THAN AT ANY OTHER TIME WHICH IS
SIMPLY REMARKABLE AND AS MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE LA A A LA --
MENTION AND I WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE INTENTIONALITY RASO LOOKING
DEEPLY AND TURNING EVERY STONE
IN TERMS OF EQUITY AND WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT IS WE'RE LOOKING
FOR OPPORTUNITIES.
IN THE CLASSROOM AND OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM TO IDENTIFY AREAS
THAT DISPROPORTIONATELY IN A
POSITIVE WAY AFFECT OUR MOST
UNDERSERVED STUDENTS OR STUDENTS
OF COLOR.
ARE LOW INCOME STUDENTS -- AND
THE SUCH AND SO IT'S BEEN A
REMARKABLE TRAJECTORY SO FAR I
CAN TALK ABOUT THE BIG NUMBERS
BUT BUT SPECIFICALLY YEAR OVER
YEAR. FOR THIS LAST YEAR FOR
WHICH WE HAVE DATA AND TING OVER
THE LINE OVER THE SUMMER WE
GRADUATED -- A HUNDRED AND SIX
THOUSAND UNDERGRADUATES WHICH
WAS ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL YEAR OVER YEAR FOR
THAT -- THE YEAR BEFORE IN TERMS
OF UNDERGRADS AND PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE IT'S EASY FOR US TO
THROW AROUND BIG NUMBERS LIKE
THAT BUT SEVEN THOUSAND LIVES
SOME THOUSAND FAMILIES SEVEN
THOUSAND COMMUNITIES AND THEN
THINK ABOUT THE RETURN TO THE
STATE.
AND SO THIS IS BUILDING UPON
YEARS AND YEARS OF THAT
INTENTIONALITY THAT I MENTIONED
A REALLY CHALLENGING OURSELVES --
TO BETTER FOR ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS AND IT'S REALLY
GRATIFYING TO SING THAT IT'S
PAYING OFF ACROSS ALL OUR
CAMPUSES.
SO YOU MAY ASK I ALWAYS ASK HOW
DO WE GET THERE IT WAS PART OF
THE DISCUSSION BEFORE THEIR THE
COMPLICATED ANSWER I TOUCHED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE VARIATION
CAMPUS TO CAMPUSES.
WE HAVE TREMENDOUS LEADERSHIP
THAT THAT THAT ARE -- EMPLOYING
DIFFERENT THINGS BUT MAYBE I'LL
JUST TOUCH BRIEFLY ON FOR HIGH
LEVEL ITEMS. ONE IS YOU MAY HAVE
HEARD THAT THIS LAST FALL MARKED
A REALLY A WATERSHED MOMENT FOR
US IN TERMS OF OR ACADEMIC
PREPARATION POLICY.
WE CHANGE THE WAY THAT WE SERVE
STUDENTS WHO WE USED TO DO HIM
AT IS NOT READY.
WE USED TO TELL THEM THAT YOU'RE
NOT QUITE READY TO BE AT THE CSU
YOU NEED TO TAKE REMEDIAL
COURSES THAT DO NOT COUNT
TOWARDS YOUR DEGREE THANK YOU
FOR DOING THAT.
YEAH I'M VERY PROUD OF THE
SYSTEM AND MORE PROUD OF THE
FACULTY WHO ARE FAIRLY SHORT
NOTICE CHANGE THEIR CURRICULUM.
LOOKED AT THE WAY THAT WE WERE
TEACHING A PROVIDED THE
WRAPAROUND SUPPORT SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS OF THE MESSAGE CHANGE
FROM
YOU'RE NOT QUITE READY TO BE
HERE AND IF YOU DON'T GET READY
WITHIN A YEAR YOU'RE GONE TO
WERE READY FOR YOU.
WE'RE GONNA PROVIDE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY FOR YOU TO SUCCEED
ED WERE THERE EVERY STEP OF THE
WAY WITH YOU AND SO IT'S EARLY I
WANT TO CAUTION US ON OUR
LEADERS WE JUST IMPLEMENTED THIS
IN THE FALL.
BUT LOOKING AT THE FIRST TERMS
WORTH OF DATA SO THIS LAST FALL --
IF YOU LOOK YEAR OVER YEAR IN A
COMPARISON LAST YEAR BEFORE THIS
POLICY WE HAD ABOUT A THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHO CAME TO US IN NEED.
OF EXTRA SUPPORT WHO --
COMPLETED A LITTLE LESS THAN A
THOUSAND WHO COMPLETED A COLLEGE
LEVEL MATH COURSE.
THIS YEAR THAT SAME GROUP OF A
UNDER -- THAT STUDENTS THAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT BETTER WE GAVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE THE
MATH COURSE RIGHT AWAY.
AND EIGHT TIMES THAT AMOUNT
ABOUT EIGHT THOUSAND STUDENTS A
YEAR OVER YEAR COMPLETED THAT
FOR CREDIT MATH COURSE SO
THEY'RE NOT SPINNING THEIR
WHEELS THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY WITH
MOMENTUM TOWARDS THAT AGREES SO.
AGAIN INCREDIBLY PROUD OF OUR
CAMPUSES AND PARTICULARLY OF OUR
FACULTY FOR PULLING THAT
TOGETHER AT COMPLETED AN
ACCEPTABLE LEVEL THE COMPLETED
EXCEPT AT A COLLEGE LEVEL
COLLEGE ON THE MAP OR SO INSTEAD
OF TAKING A PRETTY BACCALAUREATE.
NON CREDIT COURSE THAT DID NOT
COUNT THESE ARE FOR CREDIT --
BOB GLORIA LEVEL COURSES IN
MATHEMATICS SO JUST TREMENDOUS
AGAIN THAT SUPPORT -- MEANT THAT
INTENTIONALITY AROUND --
SUPPORTING OUR STUDENTS SO
THAT'S ONE EXAMPLE OF POLICIES
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT THE SECOND
EXAMPLE IS REALLY LEADERSHIP --
I THE PLEASURE BEING UP HERE A
FEW WEEKS AGO FOR A PRE HEARING
AND JUST ANECDOTALLY FOLKS
AROUND THE TABLE WERE SAYING HOW
ON THEIR CAMPUS VISITS THEY
NOTED THAT. TO A PERSON THAT
THEY MEET WITH THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
THEY'RE TALKING ABOUT SUPPORTING
STUDENTS IN WAYS THAT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN BEFORE.
SO I THINK THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN
BY ACCIDENT THAT'S THE
LEADERSHIP ON CAMPUS THAT'S OUR
FACULTY REALLY BUYING INTO WHERE
WE'RE HEADED ITS COLLECTIVE
MOMENTUM.
THE THIRD THING I'LL MENTION IS
DATA.
WERE AT A POINT NOW WHERE WE ARE
COLLECTING A LOT OF DATA ON
IMPEDIMENTS TO STUDENT SUCCESS
AND ALSO AREAS OR THEIR
SUCCESSFUL.
ENSURING THAT BROADLY ACROSS THE
SYSTEM ONE EXAMPLE OF THAT IS WE
HAVE A SYSTEM DASHBOARD WERE
EVERY FACULTY MEMBER.
CAN LOOK AT THE COURSES THEY
TEACH IN THEIR MAJORS AND THEIR
DEPARTMENTS AND SEE WHAT IS THE
GREAT DISTRIBUTION FOR STUDENTS
IN MY CLASS OR OTHER CLASSES ARE
THEIR EQUITY ISSUES ARE THERE
BIG DIFFERENCES. FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE GRADES THAT FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS ARE RECEIVING VERSES
THEIR PEERS AND IF SO HOW CAN I
LOOK UPON MYSELF. TO PERHAPS
CHANGE THE WAY I TEACHER PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR THE
STUDENTS THEY'RE STARTING TO
HAVE REAL STRONG INTENTIONAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IMPROVEMENT.
THE LAST AREA HOW IS IT BEEN
RECEIVED I ASSUME.
FACULTY HAD TO BUY INTO THAT
HOW'S IT BEEN RECEIVED
INCREDIBLY WELL I'LL TELL YOU
ONE OF THE ADVANTAGES WE HAVE IS.
WE'RE SUCH A MISSION DRIVEN
ORGANIZATION OUR FACULTY IN MANY
CASES COME TO US BECAUSE OF OUR
MISSION.
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO BETTER
BECAUSE OF THE STUDENTS WE SIR
AND SO PUTTING DATA IN FRONT OF
THEM THAT ARE PERSONAL TO THEM.
IN MANY CASES OPEN THEIR EYES
AND AND THEY'RE REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF OF THAT
INFORMATION.
THE LAST THING I'LL JUST MENTION
IN CLOSING IS RESOURCES WE COULD
NOT BE WHERE WE ARE NOW WITH THE
RESULTS WE HAVE WITH OUR
RESOURCES AND WE'RE VERY
GRATEFUL FOR THE BUDGET -- THE
PROPOSED BUDGET AND THE LAST FEW
YEARS OF FUNDING THAT WE'VE HAD
IT'S A LOUDEST TO HIRE
ADDITIONAL TENURE TRACK FACULTY.
IT'S ALLOWED US TO OPEN UP THE
NEEDED SECTIONS THE STUDENTS CAN
GET THE COURSES THEY NEED WHEN
THEY NEED THEM.
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HIRE ADVISERS
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO REALLY DOUBLE
DOWN ON THE DATA INVESTMENTS IN
THE TECHNOLOGY INVESTMENTS THAT
YOU HEARD A LITTLE BIT ABOUT AS
WELL.
BUT I WILL SAY IF IT'S SOMETHING
I ALWAYS SAY THAT STUDENT
SUCCESS IS NOT FREE.
IT DOESN'T COME EASY THIS
PROGRESS -- IS IN JEOPARDY IF WE
DON'T GET FUNDING AND CONTINUE
FUNDING WE HAVE TO BE ABLE TO
OPEN THOSE COURSES -- YOU KNOW
AND I JUST SAY THAT AS I WAS
LISTENING TO THE HEARING AND
LISTENING A LITTLE BIT THIS
MORNING TO SOME OF THINGS THAT
WERE GOING ON I'M CONVINCED I'M
BIASED BUT I'M CONVINCED THAT
THERE'S NO BETTER INVESTMENT
THAN THAT -- AND INVESTMENT IN
THIS THE STUDENTS OF THE CSU
WHAT CAN YOU -- THERE IS A DELTA
OF ABOUT THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS --
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL FORTY FIVE AND WHAT THE
ISSUE RECEIVED IN THE PAST AT
SEVENTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
GRADUATION INITIATIVE.
WHAT IS THAT DELTA THE THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ACTUALLY
REPRESENT IN TERMS OF A
GRADUATION INITIATIVE?
PROGRAMS IN IMPACT IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION THE WAY I LOOK AT IT IS
WITH THAT THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
WE WOULD BE ABLE -- TO LAUNCH AN
ADDITIONAL ONE THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED COURSE ACTIONS WHICH IS
ABOUT THIRTY THOUSAND OR SO --
THE YOU KNOW STUDENT ENROLLMENTS
IN THE SECTIONS AND SO -- YOU
THIS IS REALLY PART ONE OF THE
COURT WITH IF YOU TALK TO
STUDENTS AND I KNOW MANY WILL
TESTIFY LATER. ONE OF THE
BIGGEST IMPEDIMENTS TO
GRADUATING FOR THEM IS NOT BEING
ABLE TO GET THE COURSES THEY
NEED WHEN THEY NEED THEM.
AND SO FOR US THIS IS HIRING THE
FACULTY THAT WE NEED TO HIGHER
SO THAT WHEN A STUDENT NEEDS OF
COURSE WE CAN MEET THEM WHEN
THEY ARE.
AND OFF FROM THE COURSES THEY
AND THESE WOULD BE COURSES
OFFERED BOTH WHAT I WOULD CALL
DURING THE TRADITIONAL ACADEMIC
YEAR OF SEPTEMBER THE JUNE AND
ALSO IN THE SUMMER SESSIONS AS
WELL ABSOLUTELY YEAH.
WAS PRETTY CLEAR THAT WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT STUDENTS HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET INTO THE
COURSES THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
GET OUT THE DOOR.
AND IT'S OUR OBLIGATION.
TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
PROPERLY RESOURCES SYSTEM SO WE
ALLOW STUDENTS TO CROSS THE
FINISH LINE.
AND HOPEFULLY THE FINISH LINE ON
TARGET WHICH I KNOW IS WHAT
YOU'RE WORKING ON WHETHER IT'S A
SIX YEAR TURGOR FOR YOUR TARGET.
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT I MEAN TO
YOU AND I WE'RE WORST WERE
SINGING THE SAME TUNE HERE SO
WHEN WE SPEAK WITH THE CAMPUSES
WE SAY IT'S OUR JOB TO ADVOCATE
FOR THE GREAT WORK YOU'RE DOING.
THOSE ARE THE FOLKS THERE
ROLLING UP THEIR SLEEVES AND TRY
TO DO EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
HELP OUR STUDENTS.
CAN YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIAL AID
PIECE THAT THE LA -- MENTIONED --
WITH THE SYSTEM ALLOWS -- THERE.
I I WOULD CALL TO DISCONNECT BUT
IT'S NOT A DISCONNECT WITH NO
ONE FAULT ANYONE FOR PROVIDING
STUDENTS FINANCIAL AID.
CERTAINLY IN THIS ENVIRONMENT.
BUT APPARENTLY THIS THE SYSTEM
PROVIDES INSTITUTIONAL
FINANCIALLY THAT EXCEEDS THE
PERIOD OF TIME THAT WE PROVIDE
CAL GRANTS.
AND WE'RE TRYING TO ADD SOME CAL
GRANT TIME TO THE PROCESS
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THAT'S NOT
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW TO GET PEOPLE
OUT THE DOOR BUT SEPARATE APART
FROM THAT CAN YOU ADDRESS THE
INSTITUTIONAL FINANCIALLY CALICO
YOU KNOW THAT'S WHAT'S.
THAT'S ONE POLICY THAT WE'VE HAD
FOR A LONG TIME AND THAT'S ONE
THING THAT WE'VE BE
INSTITUTIONALLY AT FOR A LONG
PERIOD TIME JUST IN TERMS OF
BEING ABLE TO PROVIDE.
AS MUCH ACCESS AS WE CAN I THINK
THE ONE THING THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED AND I I I'VE BEEN TO
JEFF WOULD AGREE WITH ME ON THIS.
AS ONE OF OUR GRADUATION ISSUES
OURS IS THAT AND YOU GUYS ARE
BUT YOU'RE HERE CLOSE TO IT BUT
BUT THE ONE THING THAT -- IS
ALWAYS SOMEWHAT -- PRECARIOUS IS
THE THE HARD -- STOP OF A OF A
CAL GRANT. FOUR YEARS OF
ELIGIBILITY PERIOD AND NO
SUMMERS.
IN NO SUMMER ONLY UNLESS YOU AND
TO SHOOT RIGHT.
NOW ALTHOUGH THE THE ONE THING
THAT WE TRY TO DO IS WE TRY TO
DO IN A WAY KIND OF A WRAPAROUND.
INTENTIONALITY WITH
INSTITUTIONALLY OUR STATE
UNIVERSITY GRANT IN IN FACT SOME
INSTANCES WHERE STUDENTS HAVE
RUN OUT OF THEIR CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY.
WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO BUDGET.
PUT THEM OVER INTO OUR STATE
UNIVERSITY GRANT TO GET THEM
THROUGH BECAUSE ONE THING THE
THE THE I THINK THE ONE OF THE
GREATEST.
TRAGEDIES IN HIGHER EDUCATION IS
THOSE STUDENTS TO HAVE A HUNDRED
TEN UNITS THEY'VE COMPLETED OR
HUNDRED AND YOU KNOW TOWARDS
DEGREE.
AND MAYBE BECAUSE OF TIME AND
COMMITTEE COLLEGE OR ANOTHER YOU
YOU KNOW.
LIVE STUDY.
THEY DECIDED TO USE FINANCIAL
AID AND AND THEY'RE OUT OF THEIR
FINANCIAL AID.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REAL KILLERS
WOULD BE IF THERE'S ALWAYS
INVESTMENT ONE BY THE STATE BY
THE STUDENT AND THENALL OF A
SUDDEN ALL OF THE FINANCIALLY
DRIES UP.
INCLUDING THE STATE UNIVERSITY
GRANTS WE WOULD BE VERY WE WILL
BE VERY CAUTIOUS ABOUT WANTING
TO CHANGE THAT POLICY WELL YOU
AND I AND KEEP AND KEEP.
KEEP THINGS AFFORDABLE YOUR
ATTORNEY CRITICISM FROM MAY IN
FACT -- YOU KNOW THOSE OF US UP
HERE AND ELSEWHERE IN THIS
BUILDING -- PROPONENTS OF
INCREASING RATHER THAN
DECREASING.
STUDENT FINANCIAL AID IS NOT TO
SAY THAT THE LA WAS
RECOMMENDATION IS IS FINE TUNING
IS IS NOT WORTH FINE TUNING BUT
IT'S WORTH LOOKING AT TOO THOUGH
WELL I'M THINKING THAT IT'S MORE
OF OF CHANGING THE FOCUS LATELY
IT SEEMS TO ME THE FOCUS IS NOT
ON THE AMOUNT.
OF STUDENT AID OR THE LENGTH OF
IT.
IT'S ON THE COUNSELING THAT'S
PROVIDED TO STUDENTS TO TRY TO
KEEP THEM FOCUSED REDUCE EXCESS
UNIT ACCUMULATION.
FOCUS MOVING FORWARD IN A
STRAIGHT LINE FROM BEGINNING TO
END AND GRADUATION AS AS AS
EFFICIENTLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
POSSIBLE.
NOT REDUCING NECESSARILY THE
STUDENT AID IT'S IT'S A
TESTAMENT TO THE SYSTEM THAT YOU
HAVE.
INSTITUTIONALLY THE JURY WILL
PROVIDE OVER ABOVE THE CAL GRANT
PROCESS SO GOOD ON YOU.
AND WE JUST NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE PROPERLY RESOURCE
COUNSELING TEAMS ON CAMPUSES.
TO KEEP STUDENTS FOCUSED. TO
IDENTIFY STUDENTS EARLY WHO ARE
FAILING COURSES IN A BEEN A
MAJOR THAT THEY SELECTED THAT
THEY PERHAPS ARE NOT.
A CLIP TO TO TO MOVE FORWARD IN
AND AND SHIFT THOSE STUDENTS
EARLY QUICKLY INTO SOMETHING
THAT IS A IS A VIABLE CAREER
FIELD.
AND MOVE THEM ACROSS THE FINISH
LINE TO GRADUATION I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY WHERE WE GOT A
SPENDER.
TIME AND ATTENTION.
ANYWAY ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
COMMENTS.
ENJOY THE CONVERSATION.
THIS IS THE HOLDOVERS ITEM AS
WELL WE WILL AGAIN REVISIT THIS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ISSUE NUMBER FOUR PROJECT
REBOUND.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET NCLUDES
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT PROJECT REBOUND WHICH IS
AN EXISTING PROGRAM PROVIDING
ASSISTANCE TO FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
WERE EITHER SEEKING ATTENDANCE
AND ENROLLMENT OUT OF CSU OR
CURRENTLY ATTENDING AND ONE OF
NINE PARTICIPATING CSU CAMPUSES.
AND THANK YOU IN THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THAT YOU KNOW
WE SPEND A LOT OF TIME AND
ATTENTION HERE TALKING ABOUT
PUBLIC SAFETY AND ARE -- IN MAY
POPULATION AND OBSTACLES TO POST
INCARCERATION IMPLEMENTS AND HOW
WE KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF OUR A
PRISON AND JAIL SYSTEM AND
CERTAINLY EDUCATION.
AND OCCUPATION AND ABILITY TO
PRACTICE WHAT THEY LEARN IS
SOMETHING THAT WE ARE INTENSELY
FOCUSED ON HERE IN THIS IS A KEY
PIECE OF THAT SO.
SIR MUST BE YOU.
OIL OIL WHAT'S OF THE LA OKAY
FIRST I'M SORRY I'VE I'M GETTING
OUT OF ORDER BECAUSE I'M TALKING.
BUT THERE'S LIMITED.
CENTRALIZED DATA ON PROJECT
REBOUND BUT BASED ON A RECENT
SURVEY OF CAMPUSES BY THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
GRADUATES OF PROJECT REBOUND
APPEAR TO HAVE STRONG ACADEMIC
EMPLOYMENT OUTCOMES AND YOU CAN
SEE SOME OF THOSE OUTCOMES ON
PAGE SIXTEEN OF YOUR AGENDA.
GIVEN THE STATE'S INTEREST IN
REHABILITATING OFFENDERS WHICH
YOU JUST.
MENTIONED MR CHAIR THE
LEGISLATURE MAY AGREE THAT WITH
THE GOVERNOR THAT THIS.
GROUP OF STUDENTS IS IS HIGHLY
AS A HIGH PRIORITY YOU TO BE
SERVED AND IF SO.
THE AMOUNT PROPOSED BY THE
GOVERNOR TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING IT'S
QUITE SMALL I REALISTICALLY IT'S
ENOUGH FOR ONE OR TWO STAFF.
YOU KNOW.
TOTAL THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
SO RATHER THAN PROVIDING THIS
AMOUNT LEGISLATURE COULD
ENCOURAGE CSU TO LEVERAGE THE
MUCH LARGERPOT OF MONEY THAT
THE STATE PROVIDES.
IN THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
WHICH WHICH WE JUST TALKED ABOUT.
POTENTIALLY UP TO TWO HUNDRED
FORTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE BUDGET YEAR.
SO THE LEGISLATURE COULD
ENCOURAGE CSU TO LEVERAGE THIS
MONEY THIS GRADUATION INITIATIVE
MONEY -- AND USE IT FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THROUGH
PROJECT REBOUND DOING SO WOULD
BE ENTIRELY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
CAMPUS IS.
ALREADY DO HOWEVER HOW THEY
ALREADY USE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE MONEY FOR OTHER AT
RISK STUDENTS SUCH AS FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH ARE ENROLLED AT CSU
IN THAT HAVE SPECIAL PROGRAMS.
AND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS THAT
HAVE THEIR OWN PROGRAMS AND
RECEIVE GRADUATION MONEY OR USE
GRADUATION MONEY FOR THESE
PURPOSES.
SO WE WE DOES RECOMMEND
LEGISLATURE ENCOURAGE CSU TO
PLACE A HIGH PRIORITY ON USING
GRADUATION INITIATIVE FUNDS TO
SUPPORT PROJECT REBOUND
LEGISLATURE MIGHT ALSO WANT TO
SEE IF YOU TO REPORT.
MORE REGULARLY ON PROJECT
REBOUND.
ENROLLMENT IN ROMAN AND OUTCOMES
HOW MANY STUDENTS ARE ENROLLED
AT WHICH CAMPUSES.
WHAT ARE THE RETENTION AND
GRADUATION RATES WHAT ARE THE
JOB OUTCOMES OF THESE GRADUATES
AND OF COURSE DATA ON RECIDIVISM?
OF ALL THAT WOULD BE REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR LEGISLATURE TO
KNOW AND BE ABLE TO MONITOR YEAH
I THINK THAT'S CRITICAL I MEAN
I'VE I SUSPECT THAT THIS IS A
VERY VERY SIGNIFICANT PROGRAM
THAT.
SORT OF CROSSES A VARIETY OF
VERY BUDGET AREAS APPEAR IN
INTEREST AREAS OF MY COLLEAGUES --
FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE TO THE POLICY
COMMITTEE -- TO THE EDUCATION
POLICY COMMITTEE [inaudible]
AND IN Y LIMITED EXPERIENCE
WHAT I HAVE FOUND IS DATA
SOMETIMES DRIVES [inaudible]
BUDGET AUGMENTATIONS.
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO CENTRALIZE THE DATA
COLLECTION IDENTIFY WHAT THE
DATA POINTS ARE THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE IN ORDER TO SIDE WITH THE
PROGRAM IS PROPERLY RESOURCE STE.
WHETHER ADDITIONAL RESOURCES ARE
REQUIRED OR COMPELLED AND AND
HOW MUCH I MEAN I WOULD THINK
THAT THE THE BEST USE OF THE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND OR
WHATEVER IT IS IT WINDS UP IN
THE BUDGET MAY BE.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO CREATE A
CENTRALIZED DATA COLLECTION
SYSTEM THAT HAS DATA POINTS THAT
REPORTS ON A REGULAR BASIS AND
INFORMS THAT COULD INFORM
DECISIONS OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND AND THE
ADMINISTRATION ON ON FUTURE
BUDGETS BUT THAT'S JUST MY
GENERAL OBSERVATION BUT I THINK
SIR IT'S NOW.
YOUR TIME.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN --
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY --
MY NAME IS DOCTOR BRADY HEINER
I'M A PROFESSOR OF PHILOSOPHY AT
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY FULTON --
AND THE FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PROJECT WE'VE DONE A
CAL STATE.
FULLERTON I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE OF THE
CAL STATE UNIVERSITY PROJECT
REBOUND CONSORTIUM.
OF SOME SPEAKING TO YOU -- TODAY
AS A REPRESENTATIVE -- FROM NINE
CAMPUS PROGRAMS -- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- AND BEFORE I ENTER
INTO MY REMARKS TO SPEAK -- TO
THE COMMENT THAT YOU JUST MADE
ABOUT PERHAPS THE BEST USAGE OF
THE TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS -- IN IN CURRENTLY IN
THE BUDGET -- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION -- MIGHT BE -- TO
COLLECT COLLECT DATA -- I WILL
SAY THAT SO THUS FAR WE'VE BEEN
90% PHILANTHROPIC WE FUNDED --
THROUGH A GRANT TO THE RP
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE WHICH
COMES TO A CONCLUSION IN JUNE --
AND SO -- WE WOULD LOVE -- AND
HAVE BEEN -- UP PLANNING -- TO
DO HOLISTIC -- FORMATIVE AND
SUMMATIVE PROGRAM EVALUATION
BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
SUBSTANTIATE IN MORE ROBUST --
QUANTITATIVE AND QUALITATIVE --
WAYS THE THE SUCCESS THAT WE'RE
SEEING ON ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS
BUT WE HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
AFFORD -- TO DO THAT -- AND SO
REALLY -- THE BEST USE OF ANY US
STATE ALLOCATION THAT WE MAY
RECEIVE IT AND AND AND OUR VIEW
IS IS REALLY -- TO FUND THE THE
THE PERSONNEL -- FOR FOR OUR
PROGRAMS WHICH WILL GET INTO --
IN A IN A MOMENT HOPEFULLY
YOU'LL TELL ME WAS SO IT'S ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION AND THAT'S
GOING AWAY -- YES IN JUNE SO
HOPEFULLY YOU IN YOUR REMARKS
WILL TELL ME WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
THAT GOES WAY BECAUSE TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND IS NOT
ONE POINT SEVEN SO.
INDEED INDEED -- SO LET ME --
LET ME BEGIN BY THANKING THE
NEWSMEN MINISTRATION -- FOR
INCLUDING THIS ON GOING --
ALLOCATION FOR PROJECT REBOUND --
IN THE COMING YEARS BUDGET -
AND TO THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SAY A FEW
WORDS ABOUT THE WORK THAT WE DO --
AND WHY WHILE HELPFUL -- THE
ADMINISTRATION'S ALLOCATION.
FALL SHORT OF THE SUPPORT THAT
WE NEED TO SUSTAIN AND SCALE ARE
PROVEN MODEL OF SUCCESS --
MISTER CHAIRMAN THE MISSION OF
PROJECT REBOUND IS TO SUPPORT
THE HIGHER EDUCATION AND
SUCCESSFUL REINTEGRATION -- OF
THE FORMERLY INCARCERATED AND
THE CORNERSTONE OF OUR
PHILOSOPHY IS THAT THE
LEADERSHIP AND MENTOR SHIP OF
OTHER FORMERLY INCARCERATED
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS AND
GRADUATES.
FOSTERS A SENSE OF BELONGING AN
ACHIEVEMENT AMONG OUR FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENTS THAT
MAXIMIZES -- THEIR CHANCES OF
SUCCESS.
THIS IS WHY WE STAFF OUR ON
CAMPUS PROGRAMS WITH TRAINED
PROFESSIONALS WHO LIKE OUR
STUDENTS.
HAVE AN INCOME I HAVE EXPERIENCE
IN CAR SERRATION -- AND WHO
EXEMPLIFY THE SUCCESSFUL
TRANSITION TOWARD WHICH OUR
STUDENTS A SPIRE.
UP PROJECT RUBEN WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE UNIVERSITY -- BY
A SOCIOLOGY PROFESSOR NAMED JOHN
IRWIN -- AFTER SERVING FIVE
YEARS IN THE STATE PRISON SYSTEM
FOR ARMED ROBBERY -- WHEN EARNED
A BACHELOR'S DEGREE FROM UCLA A
PHD FROM UC BERKELEY -- AND
ESTABLISH PROJECT REBOUND AS A
PATHWAY TO MATRICULATED THE
FORMERLY INCARCERATED INTO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE.
UNIVERSITY -- OVER TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE PROJECT REBOUND
STUDENTS EARNED A BACHELOR'S OR
MASTER'S DEGREE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO STATE BETWEEN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN THROUGH AS
I MENTIONED THE OPPORTUNITY
INSTITUTES RENEWING COMMUNITIES
INITIATIVE. NINE CAMPUSES OF THE
CSU COLLABORATED THE PILOT THE
PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM
MODELED OFF THE ORIGINAL PROGRAM
AT SAN FRANCISCO STATE.
OF THE PROJECT REBOUND
CONSORTIUM CURRENTLY INCLUDES --
PROGRAMS AT CAMPUSES -- IN
BAKERSFIELD -- FRESNO FULLER TEN
LOS ANGELES POMONA SACRAMENTO --
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR DISTRICT
IT'S SAN BERNARDINO -- SAN DIEGO
AND SAN FRANCISCO -- SO THESE
PROGRAMS NOW PROVIDE A STATEWIDE
NETWORK OF SUPPORT FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS TO
ASSIST THEM IN ESTABLISHING
EDUCATIONAL PLANS A APPLY FOR
ADMISSION AND FINANCIAL AID.
SOCIALLY RE INTEGRATE AND
ULTIMATELY GRADUATE.
FROM THE CSU.
MOST OF ALL PROJECT REBOUND
OFFERS A COMMUNITY OF SUPPORT TO
STUDENTS WHO HAVE EXPERIENCED
THE TRAUMAS OF PRISON AND NOW
FACE A MULTITUDE OF SOCIAL
BARRIERS RELATED TO HOUSING.
EMPLOYMENT TRANSPORTATION FOOD
AND COMPUTER LITERACY BARRIERS
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
DERAIL THEIR LIVES AND AND LEAD
TO RE OF REST.
OUR PROGRAMS WORK.
THE STUDENTS IN OUR PROGRAM DO
NOT RETURN TO PRISON AFTER THREE
YEARS OF OPERATION THE PROJECT
REBOUND CONSORTIUM AS A 0%
RECIDIVISM RATE.
BY COMPARISON THE THREE YEAR
RECIDIVISM RATE -- AS I'M SURE --
IS IS NO NEWS IN THIS ROOM IN
CALIFORNIA IS 50%.
THE RECIDIVISM IS JUST A MINIMAL
METRIC OF OUR STUDENT SUCCESS
OUR STUDENTS NOT ONLY DESIST
FROM CRIME THEY NOT ONLY
PERSISTENCE SCHOOL THEY EXCEL.
PROJECT REBOUND REDUCES
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG STUDENTS
FROM HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED
AND EDUCATIONALLY DISADVANTAGED
BACKGROUNDS.
OUR STUDENTS 60% OF WHOM ARE
AFRICAN AMERICAN OR LATINO HAVE
EARNED AN OVERALL GRADE POINT
AVERAGE OF THREE POINT OH NEARLY
EVERY SEMESTER.
THAT'S ABOVE THE CSU STUDENT
BODY AVERAGE.
AT CAL STATE FULLERTON -- WHERE
I'M HOUSED THE THAT TO ADDRESS
HIGH RATES OF HOUSING AND
SECURITY AMONG OUR REENTERING
STUDENTS?
PROJECT REBOUND HAS PILOTED THE
FIRST REENTRY HOUSING INITIATIVE
FOR FORMERLY INCARCERATED
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS IN THE
NATION.
AND AMONG OUR STUDENTS WHO
RECEIVE HOUSING SUPPORT THE
OVERALL GRADE POINT AVERAGE IS
THREE POINT.
SEVEN THROUGHOUT THE CONSORTIUM
PROJECT REBOUND STUDENTS HAVE
SECURED SCHOLARSHIPS VOLUNTEERED
FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND LANDED
INTERNSHIPS AND JOBS -- IN THEIR
FIELDS.
BY THE END OF NEXT MONTH THE
PROJECT REBOUND CONSORTIUM WILL
HAVE GRADUATED OVER TWO HUNDRED
STUDENTS IN JUST THREE YEARS.
DURING WHICH TIME THE ENROLLMENT
IN OUR PROGRAMS HAS MORE THAN
DOUBLED. 87% OF A PROJECT
REBOUND GRADUATES SECURE
EMPLOYMENT OR ENROLLED IN POST
GRADUATE PROGRAM.
SO IN CONCLUSION -- AS I
MENTIONED -- LET ME JUST SAY
THAT NOW IS I BELIEVE THE
CRUCIAL TIME -- FOR CALIFORNIA
TO INVEST IN PROJECT REBOUND --
IN JUNE OF THIS YEAR -- THAT
PHILANTHROPIC SEE GRANT THAT I
MENTIONED WILL COME TO A CAN
CONCLUSION -- AND A HANDFUL OF
OUR PROGRAMS WILL HAVE TO SHE
WILL BE FORCED TO SHUT THEIR
DOORS IN THE ABSENCE OF
ALTERNATIVE LONGITUDINALLY
SUSTAINABLE FORMS OF SUPPORT.
AS I MENTIONED GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S ALLOCATION WELL WELL
HELPFUL IT'S STILL FALL
SIGNIFICANTLY SHORT OF THE THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS.
NEEDED TO SUSTAIN WHAT WE'VE
BUILT AND MEET ICREASING
DEMANDS WERE NOW OPERATING ON
NINE CAMPUSES MANY OF WHICH ARE
STAFF WITH ONLY PART TIME STAFF --
AND THERE ARE SEVEN ADDITIONAL%
CSU CAMPUSES -- WHO HAVE -- HAVE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH US -- P TO
THE PRESIDENTIAL LEVEL WHO ARE
INTERESTED AND SOME -- HAVE
ALREADY BEGUN -- ORGANIZING --
IN VARIOUS WAYS TO TO LAUNCH --
PROGRAMS ON THEIR CAMPUSES --
WOULD IF PROVIDED -- THE SUPPORT
TO DO SO -- SO WE WE REQUEST --
THAT -- THIS ON GOING ALLOCATION
OF FOR PROJECT REBOUND -- BE
INCREASED TO ENABLE US TO
SUSTAIN AND SCALE -- THIS PROVEN
MODEL OF SUCCESS TO BUILD SAFER
COMMUNITIES -- AND A STRONGER
ECONOMY UP FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTIONS -- BUT BEFORE I DO
THAT I'D I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE
YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE JASON BELL.
OF REGIONAL DIRECTOR OF PROJECT
REBOUNDED A MAN WITH OVER A
DECADE OF EXPERIENCE --
FOSTERING HIGHER EDUCATIONAL
SUCCESS AMONG FORMALLY --
INCARCERATED PEOPLE -- TO TO
TESTIFY.
OKAY WILL DO THIS I THINK YOU
CAN USE THAT MY CREDITOR SIR.
IS THIS ON ITS OWN.
SO SO I I GUESS I COME TO YOU
TODAY AS A AS A LESS THAN
TRADITIONAL COLLEGE GRADUATE
FROM SAM CISCO STATE THE THE
LONGEST STANDING PROJECT REBEL
CAMPUS.
AT JOHN LECTURES TO DEPARTMENT
SOMETIMES.
THREE AND IN THIS POSITION I
FIND MYSELF IN IS THE THE
REGIONAL DIRECTOR DIRECTED TO
HELP IMPLEMENT THE SAME MODEL
THAT WE'VE DONE AND UTILIZE FOR
YEARS THAT SERVICES WILL STATE.
ONE WHEN I SAY NONTRADITIONAL
KIND OF JUST ONE OF A WALK YOU
THROUGH THE THE THE PERSONAL.
JOURNEY THAT IT TOOK TO GET TO
THIS PLACE.
BECAUSE OF THE AS A YOUNG PERSON
I WAS DOING EVERYTHING IN MY
POWER.
TO AVOID COLLEGE.
I HAVE TO MEET IT IS KIND OF A
MIRACLE TO GET HERE.
AND A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH
REBOUNDS SPECIFICALLY.
SO SO IN IN HIGH SCHOOL I HAD A
YOU KNOW I'VE COME TO THAT THE
REALIZATION THAT COLLEGE WAS NOT
FOR ME I WOULD NEVER SMART
ENOUGH TO BE THAT SHOULD AYE
JUSTIN BELONG AS WELL THE FOLKS.
AND THE IN IN THINKING LIKE THAT
WHAT I CALL IT STINKING THINKING.
MAKE IT COST ME DEARLY AND
BECAUSE SHORTLY AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL I MADE IT THROUGH HIGH
SCHOOL MAINLY BECAUSE MOMS WOULD
ALLOW ANYTHING OTHER OTHER THAN
THAT IN THIS WORLD GIRLS WEDDING
AND I COULD PLAY BASKETBALL.
BUT BUT THE REALITY OF IT I MADE
IT THROUGH AND AND BUT SHORTLY
AFTER AT AGE TWENTY I FOUND
MYSELF FACED A LIFE SENTENCE FOR
MAKING SOME.
SOME PRETTY BAD MISTAKES.
NO I DIDN'T I DIDN'T ACCEPT THE
DEAL OF LIFE FIND OF GOING TO
TRIAL IN COMING OUT WAS
SEVENTEEN YEARS BUT THE THE
REALIZATION IS THERE'S STILL A
LOT OF YEARS THAT I GOT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO WITH
MYSELF AND AND AND BULL FORTY OR
EITHER SUCCUMB. TO THE THIS
PRISON LIFESTYLE IN AND MAYBE
NEVER MAKE IT.
THE PSYCHOLOGICAL AND EMOTIONAL
REALITY OF OF ACCEPTING THAT IS
HARD I SAW A LOT OF PEOPLE
REPUTABLE PEOPLE NOT NOT MAKE IT
TO IS SOMEONE CUT THEIR WRISTS
SOME OF THEM.
JUST SUBMITTED TO PRISON
POLITICS AND END UP CATCHING A
WHOLE BUNCH MORE TIME.
BUT BUT THE KEY THAT TEETERING
POINT FOR ME WAS AND IN THE
FIFTH YEAR OF OF SAN QUENTIN
CARSON SECTION IT WAS A IT WAS A
BROCHURE THAT HAD A OLD BROCHURE
FROM PROJECT REBOUND AHEAD A
LITTLE STORY ABOUT JOHN -- WENT.
AND I READIT AND IT HAD TO
ADDRESS ON IN IN THE KINDA
SPARKED SOMETHING IN ME SO I I
DIDN'T NUMBER ONE I DIDN'T KNOW
A LOT ABOUT COLLEGE.
I FOUND OUT ABOUT SOCIOLOGY
THROUGH WRITING.
PROJECT REBOUND AT THE TIME THE
DIRECTOR WAS A LADY NAME --
KINDA WALKER.
WHEN SHE TAUGHT ME WHAT I NEEDED
TO KNOW SHE BASICALLY?
IS SOME ACADEMIC ADVISING
THROUGH THE MAIL TO TELL ME THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN GENERATED AND
AND A MAJOR.
AND AT THAT POINT I KIND OF HAD
SOMETHING TO TO DIRECT MY MY
JOURNEY TO WORK BECAUSE IT'S
HARD.
TO REALIZE THAT YOU'RE NOT GOING
HOME NEXT CHRISTMAS OR THE ONE
AT THE END OF THE ONE AFTER THAT
AND I HAD QUITE.
QUITE A FEW OF THOSE TO DEAL
WITH.
AND BUT AT THAT POINT IN FIGURE
IN THE WHAT MY JOURNEY WAS ABOUT
AND AND THAT I CAN.
I WOULD LIKE A NATURAL BORN
SOCIOLOGISTS AND DIDN'T KNOW IT.
AND SO I HAD SOMETHING TO AIM TO
WHAT AT THAT LIGHT AT THE END OF
THE TUNNEL KIND OF GOT ME
THROUGH THAT TIME AND I DID THAT.
AND WHEN I FINALLY ARRIVED ON
THE CAMPUS AFTER.
AFTER NINE AND A HALF YEARS
LATER OF OF SERVING THAT
CALIFORNIA PRISON SENTENCE.
I FELT COMPLETELY EMPOWERED AND
BEING AROUND FOLKS THAT HAD HAD
GONE TO THE JOURNEY THAT COULD.
HELP ME AND GROOM ME TO TO BE A
SUCCESSFUL PERSON OUTSIDE OF
THOSE PRISON WALLS BECAUSE I
JUST REALLY DIDN'T KNOW WHAT TO
DO WITH.
I WAS AT A DIFFERENT STAGE OF MY
LIFE SO I KNOW WHAT HE DID I
LIVE THROUGH IT NOT ONLY TO ONE
DEGREE WITH A SECOND DEGREE AND
TO THE POSITION THAT I'M IN NOW
AND THEN TO BE ABLE TO SEE IN
SUPPORT OF WHOLE WENT TO OTHER
FOLKS. TO DO JUST THE SAME IS IS
IS AMAZING TO ME SO IF I CAN
STRESS ANYTHING I JUST WANNA
STRESS.
THE IMPORTANCE OF THE PROGRAM
AND AND WHAT IT'S DONE FOR A
WHOLE BUNCH OF FOLKS NOW BEING
ABLE TO SEE IT ON ALL THESE
OTHER CAMPUSES GO. TO LAND ON
ANY OF THE NINE CAMPUSES THAT
ARE EXISTING AND THE SEVEN
POTENTIAL ONES THAT AWAITING.
AND KNOW THAT THEY'RE THEY'RE
PEOPLE THAT ARE ENERGIZED AROUND
DOING POSITIVE THINGS OUTSIDE OF
PRISON.
I FEEL IT'S PRETTY IMPORTANT I
DON'T THINK THAT YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT RE ENTRY WITHOUT THE
INCLUSION OF HIGHER IT I DON'T
THINK THAT IS THE ANSWER FOR
EVERYONE.
BUT I THINK THAT IT DEFINITELY
HAS TO BE.
ON THE TABLE AND I THINK
CALIFORNIA SERVES AS A AS A
PRESS IS A LIKE A LIKE A MODEL
FOR THE REST THE UNITED STATES
BECAUSE ALL THE DIFFERENT --
SYMPOSIUMS EVERY EVERY USE
SUMMIT THAT I GO TO OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THEY'RE FINDING OUT ABOUT US IN
THIS IN THAT WE WANT TO DO WHAT
YOU DO HERE SO I THINK THIS IS
LIKE LIKE BRADY WAS SAYING THIS
IS THE TIME. TO STEP UP AND DO
THE BEST WE CAN IF I COULD SAY.
ANYTHING ELSE TO THAT REGARD I
THINK THAT.
THIS PRETTY IMPORTANT.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING IS VERY
IMPACTFUL.
THANK YOU MISTER ST THOMAS AND
ST GRADUATIONS.
WHAT DOCTOR ALL I CAN SAY IS A
GREAT JOB THANK YOU FOR DOING
WHAT YOU DO MAYBE WE SHOULD?
PUT YOU IN CHARGE OF THE REST OF
OUR REHABILITATION PROGRAMS IN
THE STATE -- YOU EAT I PREFER TO
TEACH PHILOSOPHY BUT BUT I'M BUT
WHAT WE'RE DOING -- AT THROUGH
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM -- I THINK IS
THAT A GREAT CONTRIBUTION TO THE
STATE -- AS MY COLLEAGUE MISSION --
AND CAN SCALE -- A SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM THAT CAN REALLY SERVE AS
A BELLWETHER MODEL TO OUR
COLLEAGUES ACROSS THE STATE I'LL
JUST SAY SO WE'VE WE'VE LOST
THAT HOUSING INITIATIVE THAT I
MENTIONED IN MY REMARKS -- IN
AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
AND WE'VE ALREADY HAD --
REPRESENTATIVES FROM FOR
UNIVERSITIES ACROSS THE COUNTRY
COME TO SEE -- WHAT IT IS THAT
WE'RE DOING -- AND AND IT WITH
AN INTEREST AND AND AND IN
REPLICATING -- WHAT WE'RE DOING
WELL EXTRAORDINARY JOB AND YOU
DID ANSWER MY QUESTION -- THE
LOSS OF THE ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION.
UNLESS IT'S REPLACED WILL RESULT
IN A SYSTEMATIC OF DISASSEMBLY
OF AT LEAST A SIGNIFICANT PART
OF THIS PROGRAM AT THE VERY SEE
ISSUE CAMPUSES AND IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT THAT'S PROBABLY
SOMETHING WE CANNOT AFFORD IN
THE STATE OF FOR INTERESTED IN.
TRULY INTERESTED IN
REHABILITATION -- AND
RESTORATION.
AND GIVING FOLKS OF LEGO -- OKAY
MANUALLY MARK IS LIFE WE DO
SPEND A LOT OF MONEY IN THE
STATE ON REHABILITATION AND
SEEMS TO BE WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT A WAY -- TO TAKE SOME
OF THAT THAT WE SPENT ELSEWHERE
PERHAPS NOT QUITE AS EFFECTIVELY
AND DIVERTED TO TO YOUR PROGRAM
AND PROPERLY FUNDED AND ACTUALLY
ADD SOME ADDITIONAL FUNDS TO SET
UP A DATA COLLECTION SYSTEM
BECAUSE I THINK THE DATA.
AND THE DATA POINTS -- WHICH I'M
SURE YOU WILL BE ABLE TO COLLECT
AND AND AND DISSEMINATE ARE
GOING TO BE A VERY POWERFUL
STATEMENT TOWARD WHY.
OF THIS PROGRAM SHOULD CONSIST
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE FUNDING THAT
ONLY IN THIS NEXT BUDGET YEAR
BUT AND BUDGET YEARS AFTER SO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR WHAT YOU
DO EXTRAORDINARY THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY -- ANYTHING ELSE PANELIST
ON THIS PARTICULAR.
YES SENATOR DISTRO QUICKLY FROM
A SYSTEM WIDE PERSPECTIVE --
OBVIOUSLY YOU SEE THE SUCCESS OF
THE PROGRAM -- WE ALSO WERE.
ABLE TO CONTRIBUTE SOME ONE TIME
FUNDING TO PARTNER WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY INSTITUTE -- TO
SUPPORT THE PROGRAM I THINK ONE
THING TO KEEP IN MIND -- A AND
MAYBE EVERY A SPECIAL REQUEST IT
SEEMS LIKE YOU AND OTHERS.
ALSO IN THE ASSEMBLY WOULD BE
POISED TO TO FUND.
OF THIS PROGRAM -- ONE THING
THAT I REQUEST THAT WAS IS THAT
IT BE ON TOP OF THE FULL FUNDING
OF A AT OF OUR GRADUATION IT
SHOULD HAVE. ONE THING THAT E
HAVE ALREADY LAID OUT IN THE
GRANT INITIATIVE PLAN.
IS WHAT WE PLAN TO DO WITH THAT
FUNDING IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
YEAR.
AND RIGHT NOW OUR CAMPUSES ARE
POISED TO DEDICATE ABOUT SIX
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS TO
PROGRAMS LIKE PROJECT REBOUND
AND OTHER -- PROGRAMS LIKE THAT
THAT ARE KIND OF A SIGNIFICANT
SUPPORT TO STUDENTS THAT COME
FROM A DIVERSE GROUP OF OF
DIVERSE BACKGROUNDS.
AND SO ONE THING THAT WE WOULD
JUST REQUEST IS THAT IF YOU
FULLY FUND THE GRANITE SHOULD BE
ALMOST GET A TWO FOR WITH THIS
ONE IS THAT YOU WE DO HAVE
CAMPUS IS THAT ARE POISED TO DO
MORE WITH.
YOU KNOW DHAKA STUDENTS -- WITH
VETERANS AND THOSE SORTS OF
GROUPS SO THEY'RE ALREADY LANE
THAT THAT THAT THAT WOULD
GROUNDWORK BUT THEN ALSO IF YOU
ARE POISED TO FUND THIS IT'D BE
ON TOP OF THAT.
A GRAND SHIP ABOUT RATHER THAN
SUPPLANTED REPLY I CERTAINLY
AGREE I MEAN THIS IS NOT BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER FIVE AND
PUBLIC SAFETY -- AND I'M HOPING
THAT MY PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE -- CONSULTANTS ARE
LISTING BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE THE
TRADITIONAL AS I UNDERSTAND IT
I'VE NEVER SEPTEMBER CHAIRED IT
BUT THAT'S WERE TRADITIONALLY
THE REHABILITATION MONEY PASSES
AND IT SEEMS TO ME THAT WE HAVE
ENOUGH MONEY PASSING THROUGH THE
SYSTEM IN.
THROUGH ANOTHER PIPELINE.
WHERE WE OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO
FIND -- THE MONEY TO FUND THIS
PROGRAM AS SUCCESSFUL AS IT IS
WITH RESPECT TO REHABILITATION
OF FORMERLY INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS.
I CAN I HEAR YOU -- AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH LET'S
MOVE ON THIS IS A HOLD OPEN ITEM
AS WELL AS MOVE ON ISSUE NUMBER
FIVE CAPITAL OUTLAY AND DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE
-- NEW TEAM.
OKAY FAMILIAR FACES AND ONE NEW
ONE SIR PLEASE IDENTIFY YOURSELF
FOR THE RECORD.
RANDI KATZ SUPPORT OF FINANCES
TO CATS THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH.
THOUGH THE CSU MAY I USE THAT
SUPPORT APPROPRIATION FOR
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS IT'S
JUSTIN NEEDS OF FACILITIES THAT
SERVE ACADEMIC PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION A EXISTING LAW
ALLOWS USE YOU TO FINANCE THE
COSTS OF DEFERRD MAINTENANCE
PROJECTS AND ACADEMIC FACILITIES
AND RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY CSU
SUBMITTED TWENTY TWO CAPITAL
OUTLAY REQUEST INCLUDING THEIR
STATEWIDE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS.
CONSISTENT WITH FUNDING
AVAILABLE THE APPROVED BY THE
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN FINANCES
PROVIDED PRELIMINARY APPROVAL
FOR ELEVEN QUALIFYING PROJECTS
INCLUDING THE SYSTEM.
AS WELL AS THE SYSTEM WIDE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS --
CURRENT LAW LIMITS ISSUES
CAPITAL EXPENDITURESTO NO MORE
THAN 12% OF ITS SUPPORT
APPROPRIATION NOTED THAT SIR.
ONCE FUNDED THE PROJECTED
MAXIMUM PERCENTAGE WILL BE NINE
POINT 7%.
WHICH IS ABOUT EVENLY SPLIT
BETWEEN BOND DEBT SERVICE AND
CASH. FOR THE S. SAN DIEGO
DRAMATIC ARTS INNOVATION PROJECT
OF FINANCE NOTES THAT CSU SPACE
GUIDELINES AUTHORIZE ALL CAMPUS.
THOSE WITH ENROLLMENT EXCEEDING
FIVE THOUSAND STUDENTS SUCH AS
THIS YOU SAN DIEGO THAT BOTH A
FIVE HUNDRED SEAT SMALL THEATER
AND A BLACK BOX THEATRE.
THE BLACK BOX THEATRE ALLOWS FOR
MULTIPLE STAGE CONFIGURATIONS
GIVEN THE FLEXIBILITY TO WHOSE
PRODUCTIONS SUCH AS THE EARNED
AROUND THE SIDLES AND DANCES
THAT MAY NOT WORK AS WELL IN A
TRADITIONAL THEATER -- IN
ADDITION TO THE THING LAW -- IS
THIS IN ADDITION TO THE CAP OUT
LATE PROGRAM THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET PROPOSES TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN MILLION IN ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE -- OR TWO AND
PROUVER EXPAND -- CAMPUS BASED
CHILD CARE FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
STUDENT PARENTS -- BUT WE ARE
HAPPY TO WORK WITH LEGISLATIVE
STAFF TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
REGARDING.
A PROPOSED CSU DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDING AND
ASSOCIATED PROJECTS TO ENSURE
THAT OF THE SPENDING ITS USES
SIDE OUTCOMES.
HOWEVER WE DO NOT A CONCERN WITH
THE BREAST AND SOME OF THE
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU.
WHAT'S YOUR FROM THE LA -- AND
I'M. TWO GLEE INTERESTED IN THE
SUGGESTION ABOUT THE PLAN TO
ELIMINATE BACKLOG.
BUT I WOULD CHOOSE.
I WILL NOT DERAIL YOU AND I WILL
KEEP YOU ON TRACK PAT IS TO TWO
MAJOR ISSUES HERE FIRST CAPITAL
OUTLAY THE PROPOSALS AND THEN.
THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL ON
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- INCLUDED
WITH THAT I GUESS IS THAT IT IS
THE CHILD CARE FACILITIES.
SO WITH REGARD TO CAPITAL OUTLAY
WE GENERALLY DON'T HAVE ANY
ISSUE WITH THE PROJECTS THAT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE HAS
PRELIMINARILY APPROVED.
AND CSU IS INDICATED THAT IT CAN
FINANCE.
THESE PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
EXISTING BUDGET.
I DO TO US SOME DEBT REFINANCING
AND SOME OTHER ACTIONS TAKEN.
WE DO RECOMMEND THE LEGISLATURE
CONSIDER THE TRADE OFFS OF THE
PROPOSED.
PETER PROJECTS AT SAN DIEGO.
A AS NOTED ON PAGES TWENTY AND
TWENTY ONE OF THE AGENDA THE
PROJECT ENTAILS RENOVATING.
AN EXISTING FEEDER TO MAKE IT
MORE ACCESSIBLE TO PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES.
AND I CONSTRUCTING A SECOND
THEATER.
IN ADJACENT LOCATION.
BY BUILDING A SECOND THEATER THE
CAMPUS WOULD BE ABLE TO STAGE
MULTIPLE -- PERFORMANCES AT THE
SAME TIME.
THE CAMPUS IS WRITTEN PROPOSAL
NOTES THAT AN ALTERNATIVE WOULD
BE JUST TO RENOVATE THE EXISTING
THEATRE.
AND NOT A AT THE SECOND THEATER
AND THIS ALTERNATIVE ACCORDING
TO THE CAMPUS WOULD COST ABOUT
HALF OF WHAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCES PULMONARY PRELIMINARILY
APPROVED FOR THIS PROJECT SO.
ABOUT SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS
LESS SO IN ASSESSING THIS
PROPOSAL THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
JUST WANT -- TO WAY WHETHER THE
BENEFIT OF HAVING TO THEATERS.
OUTWEIGHS THE ADDITIONAL COST
AND THE OTHER POTENTIAL PROJECTS
THAT COULD BE SUPPORTED WITH
SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLARS.
AND CHANCES OFFICE MIGHT HAVE
OTHER INFORMATION YOU.
YOU COULD CONSIDER IN EVALUATING
THE PROPOSAL.
THE REGARD TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE PROPOSAL --
WE THINK.
SAID THIS FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE -- FUNDING
FOR DEFERRED MAINTENANCE IS A IS
A PROVEN WAY TO USE ONE TIME
MONEY.
AS YOU CAN SEE ON PAGE TWENTY
ONE OF THE AGENDA WE DO THINK
THAT MORE LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT.
IS WARRANTED IT'S TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS SO
TO THE LEGISLATURE WILL WANT TO
BE CLEAR -- KNOWING AHEAD OF
TIME WHAT PROJECTS ARE CSU
INTENDS TO UNDERTAKE AND AND THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE HAS.
HAS PROVIDED SOME GOOD
INFORMATION -- INDICATING OF
THEIR TOP PRIORITIES FOR THIS
MONEY SHOULD THEY RECEIVE IT.
ON WE ALSO RECOMMEND HAVING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE REPORT
AFTERWARDS ON THE STATUS OF THE
PROJECTS.
IS HE IS HE SAID IT WAS GONNA
UNDERTAKEN WHETHER THEY WERE
COMPLETED OR NOT -- WE ALSO
RECOMMEND -- DIRECTING CSU
DEVELOP A LONG TERM PLAN. TO
ADDRESS ITS BACKLOG THREE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS BACKLOG
AND ALSO.
I'LL WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
ON STRATEGIES TO IMPROVE
MAINTENANCE PRACTICES GOING
FORWARD.
YOU KNOW IF IF THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO PUT MONEY INTO
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE AND THEN
THE PROJECTS THE CURRENT
BUILDINGS DON'T HAVE SCHEDULED
MAINTENANCE IS UNDERTAKEN YOU'RE
GONNA END UP WITH DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE ALL OVER AGAIN IN
LESS YOU ADDRESS THE ROOT OF THE
PROBLEM WHICH IS.
ON TIME MAINTENANCE USING
FUNDING THAT THAT MIGHT BE
AVAILABLE.
AS FOR THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
ON MAKING THESE FUNDS AVAILABLE
FOR CHILD CARE FACILITIES.
HI THE LEGISLATURE WILL JUST
WANT TO KNOW BASIC INFORMATION --
WHAT SPECIFIC PROBLEMS ARE THERE
AT THE IT IT BUILDINGS ON CAMPUS
IS WITH CHILD CARE FACILITIES?
WHAT SPECIFIC?
FACILITY UPGRADES WOULD NEED TO
BE DONE -- WHAT WOULD BE THE
COST OF THAT OF JUST BASIC
INFORMATION LEGISLATURE ALWAYS
ASK FOR FOR ANY PROJECT WHETHER
IT'S THE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECT
LARA MAINTENANCE PROJECT?
HAPPY ANSWERING QUESTIONS WELL.
FIRST LET ME ADDRESS THE THEATER
I MEAN I'M NOT AN ARTS PERSON I
DON'T HAVE AN ARTS DEGREE MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE THE SMALL
LIKE IS THE REFERRED TO AS BLACK
BOX THEATERS OR SEEM TO BE.
A THING NOW -- COMMUNITIES ARE
CONSTRUCTING THE ADDITION TO
LARGER SCALE AUDITORIUM TYPE
FACILITIES SO.
I ASSUME THERE MUST BE SOME
EDUCATIONAL REASON.
WHY YOU WOULD -- WANT THE
FACILITY LIKE THAT IN SORT OF
HARD FOR US TO JUMP IN THE
MIDDLE OF ACADEMIA AND TRY TO
DECIDE WHAT'S BEST FOR A FROM AN
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I
ASSUME THIS IS AN EDUCATIONAL.
THE FACILITY IS GOING TO BE USED
FOR EDUCATIONAL PURPOSES NOT
COMMUNITY ENTERTAINMENT.
NECESSARILY THIS IS THAT THAT
THAT.
THAT'S CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT.
AND THEN IS TO THE LARGER ISSUE
HAS TO DO WITH THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE THANK YOU FOR
DRESSING THE PLAN.
I IT'S ALMOST SO BIG I DON'T
EVEN UNDERSTAND I CAN'T GET MY
ARMS AROUND DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
ON UNIVERSITY CAMPUSES YOURS AND
SEE ISSUE SYSTEM WIDE AND AND
THE UC SYSTEM.
ARE YOU RECEIVING ENOUGH MONEY
TO GO TO THE COMMENT ABOUT.
STATUS QUO ARE YOU RECEIVING
ENOUGH MONEY ON AN ANNUAL BASIS.
KEEP THE BACKLOG FROM GROWING.
AND IF NOT WHAT'S THE PLAN.
SO SO ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
WEEK WE'VE BEEN WORKING THE LAST
NUMBER OF YEARS.
TO IT WILL PROVE THE ROUTE THE
ACCURACY OF OUR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE BACKLOG AMOUNT SO
THAT IS HAS BEEN DOLLARS WE'VE
BEEN INVESTING.
OF RECENTLY AND SO THAT'S WHERE
WE'VE HAD THIS UPDATE OF THE
THREE POINT SEVEN BILLION.
AND YOU KNOW I I THINK THIS
ISSUE AS MUCH AS WE TOOK
SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS IN THE
NEW TWO THOUSAND EIGHT NINE
PRODUCED.
A STAFFING END.
OF INVESTMENT OF PHYSICAL PLANT
WE WE ALSO THEN REALIZE WE'RE
DOING A PRETTY GOOD JOB BECAUSE
OF SYSTEMS THAT HAVE NOT LASTED
FORTY FIFTY YEARS ARE STILL
GOING.
SOAK BUT THOSE ARE THE SYSTEMS
THAT WE NEED TO REPLACE.
A LOT OF OUR BUILDING STOP WAS
BUILT IN THE SIXTIES WITH THE
THE GROWTH OF THE CSU BUT WE DO
HAVE I WANNA SAY 15% OF OUR
INVENTORY THAT ARE SIX YEARS OLD
OR MORE.
SO SO THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
ANNUAL AMOUNTS THAT WE NEED TO
REINVEST TO REPLACE BUILDINGS
THAT HAVE COME TO THEIR END OF
AGE IS ABOUT THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION.
THREE FIFTY THREE SEVENTY OF IT
AND THAT DOESN'T ADDRESS.
THAT'S JUST OF THINGS THAT ARE
COMING OF AGE THAT YEAR.
IT DOESN'T ADDRESS.
TRYING TO CHIP AWAY AT THE THE
BACKLOG THE THREE POINT.
SEVEN IF WE INCLUDE THAT THAT
NUMBER GOES UPWARDS OF SIX
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION PER
YEAR AND YOU RECEIVE CAREER WHAT
WOULD BE RECEIVING ON THIS
BUDGET WELL IN THIS BUDGET TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION SO
WE'RE GOING BACKWARDS.
WE'RE GOING BACKWARDS HOWEVER.
BREAKING THOUGH THIS IS RECORD
BREAKING IN TERMS OF ONE TIME
DEFERRED MADE BUT NO I'M LISTEN
I'M I'VE.
I APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THE
GOVERNOR'S DONE IN THIS BUDGETS
OF NOTHING I SAY SHOULD BE
DEEMED CRITICISM I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE GET A
HANDLE ON THIS NOW EVERYTHING IS
BUDGET CONSTRAINED AND I I'M
GLAD I'M NOT THE GOVERNOR AND
I'M GLAD I'M NOT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE.
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW HOW.
OF HE OR THEY BALLOTS THE
VARIOUS -- STAKEHOLDER --
REQUESTS AND FEND OFF THE HANDS
THAT ARE TRYING.
TO GET IN THE BUCKET BUT I AM
CURIOUS SO.
YOU NEED ABOUT THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION.
RIGHT IT AND SO ONE OF THE ONE
OF THE BUDGET REQUEST THIS IS
INCLUDED I MENTIONED EARLIER.
IS EIGHTY MILLION DOLLARS AND
BASS FUNDING FOR A FACILITIES
AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THAT WOULD BE ONE IF WE HAD
INCREASE SUPPORT BUDGET FUNDING.
THEN WE COULD USE THOSE DOLLARS
TO FINANCE SOME OF THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PROJECTS IN IN THAT
IS.
LARGELY WHAT IS -- SOME OF THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENT PROGRAM IT WAS WHEN
THE ITEMS THAT -- TO MISLI
INCLUDED IN THE AT WITH THE
AGENDA.
YEAH THOSE ARE ITEMS AT THE END
OF THEIR USEFUL LIFE.
REFER BOND FINANCING.
OF SYSTEMS THAT HAVE A LIFE OF
THE LIFE CYCLE OF THIRTY YEARS
FORTY YEARS FIFTY YEARS BASED ON
HOW LONG WE THEY'VE BEEN IN THE
U. SO FAR.
SO OUR REQUESTS REALLY OUR
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE
BACKLOG IS ASKING FOR PERMANENT
BASE SPENDING SO WE CAN FINANCE --
SO FOR THE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
NEEDS THAT'S THE WAY WE'RE GONNA
GET TO IT IN.
AND TO INCREASE OUR BASE FUNDING.
WE GET PROJECT WHO HAS FROM TIME
TO TIME IS THERE A IS THERE A
WRITTEN LONG TERM DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PLAN THAT.
IT'S SORT OF BEEN THOUGHT
THROUGH AND REDUCE TO WRITING --
WHETHER IT INCLUDES BOND
FINANCING OR ONE TIME MONEY OR
FUTURE ANTICIPATED BUDGET
REQUESTS -- THE GENERAL FUND.
WE HAVE WORKED ON A PLAN OVER
TIME IT DOES SOMETHING THAT
FALLS TO THE BACK BURNER SPARSE
COMPLAINING THAT REPORT.
BUT ONE OF THE THINGS WE HAVE
INCLUDED IN OUR FIVE YEAR PLAN
IS A BY CAMPUS LIST OF WHAT THE
BACKLOG IS PER CAMPUS FOR THE
BUILDINGS.
AND FOR THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S BEEN SOMETHING WE'VE
WORKED ON RECENTLY FOR THE PIPES
BETWEEN THE BUILDINGS AND AND
WHAT THAT COST IS THE WITH THEIR
LIFE CYCLES WERE STILL.
WORKING ON THAT ASPECT.
AND WE IDENTIFY HOW MUCH EACH
CAMPUS SHOULD BE FUNDING AND
DEFERRED MAINTENANCE WE'RE NOT
OUT THAT AMOUNT THAT WOULD EQUAL
THE THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY BUT
TRYING TO INCREASE THE
VISIBILITY OF THE NUMBER.
AND WE'RE NOW TRACKING.
WE'VE OF CHANGE SOME OF OUR
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM SO WE CAN
TRACK HOW MUCH ARE YOU SPENDING
CAMPUS ON DEFERRED MAINTENANCE
THAT WE CAN BETTER YOU KNOW MAKE
A JUSTIFICATION ON HOW MUCH WE
NEED AND ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE
REPORT TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE LEGISLATURE ILIO.
DID WE SPEND IT DID WE NOT YOU
WHERE WE FALLING SHORT.
AND I GUESS THAT'S WHY WE
CONSTANTLY HARP ON REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS A MINUTE IT'S A IF
IT.
IF THE IF.
IF THERE'S A PLAN.
AND IF THE REPORTS ARE CLEARER
AND PRESENTED TO US THAN IT IT
ALLOWS US TO HELP.
YOU HELP YOURSELVES IN TERMS OF
FUNDING BECAUSE WE TALK A LOT
ABOUT.
IN CASE YOU TWELVE PER PUPIL
SPENDING IN HIGHER EDUCATION YOU
KNOW.
DIRECTING FUNDS GRADUATION IS
INITIATIVES INCREASED ENROLLMENT
BUT IF WE DON'T MAINTAIN THE
FACILITIES WE HAVE IF WE DON'T
HAVE FACILITIES IN WHICH TO DO
THE TEACHING.
UNLESS WE'RE GOING TO PITCH
TENTS.
WE DON'T ACCOMPLISH OUR CORE
MISSIONS SO.
IT'S VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO ME
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU GET THE
MONEY THAT YOU NEED TO MAINTAIN
THE BUILDINGS THAT YOU HAVE.
LET ALONE BUILD THE NEW ONES
THAT YOU NEED TO BUILD IN ORDER.
TO DEAL WITH THE INCREASED
ENROLLMENT THAT WERE PRESSURING
YOU [inaudible] TO TO ACCOMPLISH
[inaudible]
SO.
THANK YOU AND JUST FROM A
FUNDING PERSPECTIVE ON THE PLAN
THAT'S THAT'S THE CHALLENGE
RIGHT MULTI YEAR PLAN FOR THIS
WOULD WE WE ARE FUNDED BY TWO
PRIMARY SOURCES.
STATE GENERAL FUND IN TUITION
FEE REVENUE RIGHT.
SO WHEN -- AND I KNOW THAT
NOBODY AT THIS TABLE AND NOBODY
ON THE DíAS ONCE TUITION TO GO
UP EVER.
BUT THAT'S ONE ELEMENT OF OUR
FUNDING STRATEGY IS WE HAVE
TUITION THAT SUPPORT US.
SO IF THAT'S OFF THE TABLE AND
IT IS OFF THE TABLE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION ALREADY.
AND WE HAVE ALREADY PULLED THAT
OPTION FOR NINETEEN TWENTY OFF
THE TABLE AS WELL.
THAT A FALLS ON THE GENERAL FUND
WHETHER THE GENERAL FUND COULD
SUPPORT THAT SO THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE
PREDICAMENT THAT WERE IN AS A
STATE UNIVERSITIES WERE FUNDED
BY. TWO REVENUE SOURCES ONE
THAT'S VERY LIMITED AND HAS TO
PAY FOR A LOT OF OTHER THINGS IN
THE STATE THE OTHER ONE THAT.
MOST FOLKS ARE NOT INTERESTED IN
SEEING CREE SO THAT'S THAT'S THE
CHALLENGE IN TRYING TO DEVELOP A
PLAN AND ACTUALLY FUND.
NO I UNDERSTAND.
AND YOUR CHALLENGES DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE SHOWN SO EVERYBODY'S
IN THE SAME BOAT TRYING TO
FIGURE THIS THING OUT WILL WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK IT.
ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS PARTICULAR
ITEM YES MA'AM.
IF I MAY I AM.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT -- WITH
THE LEGISLATION CHANGED IN TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WHERE THE CSU
COULD USE ITS OWN FUNDS TO
FINANCE CAPITAL WE DID THEN
START INCLUDING DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE PLANNING IN OUR FIVE
YEAR PLAN.
SO NOT ONLY FORWARD LOOK AT
CAPITAL IMPROVEMENTS BUT ALSO I
CAMPUS HOW MUCH THEY'RE LOOKING
TO SPEND OF THEIR OWN MONEY HOW
MUCH WE WOULD PUT IT.
OF FINANCE DOLLARS FOR DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
AND AS FAR AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OF COMMENT ON
REPORTING WE ALSO INCLUDE.
WHAT PROJECTS HAVE BEEN FUNDED
BY DEFERRED MAINTENANCE FUNDS
HAVE BEEN ALLOCATED TO THE CSU
FROM THE STATE?
THE WEAVER SEE ABOUT NINETY FIVE
MILLION OVER THE LAST NUMBER OF
YEARS SO THOSE PROJECTS ARE
IDENTIFIED BY CAMPUS.
SO THAT SINCE WE DO TRY TO BE
TRANSPARENT ON HOW WE USE THAT
AUTHORITY AND WHERE WE'VE BEEN
SPENDING THE DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE FUNDS BY CAMPUS.
I DO WANT TO TOUCH BASE ON THE
SAN DIEGO PROJECT.
WE WE HAVE SHARED WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT WE
COULD HAVE DONE BETTER IN
DEFINING THE BENEFITS OF THE
PROJECT.
SO FOR EXAMPLE THIS NEW.
NEW PROJECT WILL NOT ONLY
ADDRESS EIGHTY EIGHT PROBLEMS IN
THE TOWN HALL THEATRE.
BUT IT WILL ALLOW US TO ADDRESS
EIGHTY A PROBLEMS IN THE
EXPERIMENT EXPERIMENTAL THEATER
AND THE DANCE STUDIO SO THOSE
ARE.
TWO IF YOU HAVE BEEN TO SAN
DIEGO STATE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THAT IT'S VERY -- HILLY SO WE
HAVE BUILDINGS THAT HAVE
ENTRANCES AT MULTIPLE LEVELS.
CURRENTLY THE DON PAL FEEDER AND
SOME THE OTHER THEATERS YOU HAVE
TO GO IF YOU'RE A DISABLED
PATRONS.
YOU HAVE TO GO OUTSIDE OF THE
BUILDING TO ACCESS THE RESTROOM
WHICH IS NOT UNIVERSAL ACCESS.
SO THIS PROPOSED PROJECT.
IN AN ANALYSIS OF ALTERNATIVES.
WE THINK IF WE INCLUDED THE COST
TO BRING THOSE OTHER -- RECITAL
HOLES AND DANCE STUDIOS UP TO
EIGHTY EIGHT COMPLIANCE FIRE
SAFETY CODES IT WOULD PROBABLY
REDUCE THE DELTA SEVENTY MILLION
REDUCE THAT DOWN.
TO MAYBE SIX TO THE NINE MILLION
BECAUSE OF THE COST TO IN PROVE
THE OTHER SPACES.
AND SO IT SO I THINK THERE ARE
CERTAINLY EIGHTY ACCESS BENEFITS.
THERE IS A MAN OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE WILL BE TAKEN CARE
OF BY VIRTUE OF THIS PROJECT.
AND THE STUDENTS HAVE CAN'T GET
INTO THE DISABLED STUDENTS CAN'T
GET INTO THE LIGHTING STUDIO SO
IT'LL ADDRESS.
THE ACADEMIC PORTIONS OF THE
PROJECT THAT.
CAN'T BE ACCOMMODATED CURRENTLY
SO WE WE SEE HER SUPPORT ON THAT
PROJECT.
AND ON THE CHILD CARE CENTERS WE
HAVE BEEN COLLECTING INFORMATION
FROM CAMPUSES THIS IS WHERE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSALS WE LOOK AT
HOW WE CAN INCREASE.
OF THE NUMBER THE CAPACITY OF
STUDENTS CHILDREN.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE PROPOSALS THAT
RANGE FROM A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THIRTY MILLION.
SO WE'RE TRYING TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND WHO THE PATRONS ARE
IS THAT THE STUDENTS THAT HAVE
THEIR CHILDREN'S IN THE FACILITY.
OR IS THAT THE COMMUNITY IS A
FACULTY STAFF.
AND CAN OPERATIONALLY EVEN IF BY
FROM CAPITAL WE INCREASED IT CAN
OPERATIONALLY THEY THEY
ACCOMMODATE AN INCREASE BUT WE
ARE TRYING TO LOOK AT THOSE
FACILITIES THAT ARE STATE OWNED
FACILITIES.
THAT -- COULD BENEFIT FROM FROM
SOME OF THE IMPROVEMENTS -- SO
IT'S A WIN WIN.
I ASSUME THAT THE NEEDS VERY
CAMPUS BY CAMPUS.
THEY THEY DO THE PROGRAM'S
VARIOUS WEALTH OF SOME CAMPUSES
HAVE MORE OF A OF A CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM KINESIOLOGY
WHERE WHERE OTHERS MAKE THEY MAY
NOT HAVE THAT COMPONENT IN A
SHOP IN A STATE FACILITY.
WELL THANK YOU ANYTHING ELSE ON
THIS ON THIS ISSUE.
I APPRECIATE PRESENTATION WILL
HOLD THIS ONE OPEN LOOK FORWARD
TO REVISITING THIS -- AS WE MOVE
DOWN THE ROAD THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- THE FINAL ISSUE IS ISSUE
NUMBER -- SEVEN BASIC NEEDS
[inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
WE DIDN'T DRIVE YOU AWAY.
NOW.
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROVIDES
FIFTEEN MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND TO ADDRESS OR TO SUPPORT
CSU CAMPUS EFFORTS. TO ADDRESS
FOOD AND HOUSING AND SECURITY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
HELLO.
IN A SURVEY OF CSU STUDENTS
CONDUCTED THROUGHOUT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND 200017402%
OF SURVEY RESPONDENTS REPORTED
HAVING FOOD AND SECURITY ABOUT
11% OF RESPONDENTS RE SPORT
REPORTED EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS.
WITHIN THE PREVIOUS YEAR.
HAS PAGE TWENTY SIX OF YOUR
AGENDA NOTES RECENTLY THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED INCENTIVE
GRANTS FOR CAMPUSES.
TO HELP STUDENTS ENROLLING
CALIBRATION WHICH IS THE STATE'S
FOOD STAMPS PROGRAM.
AS WELL AS OPERATE OF FOOD
PANTRIES AND CREATE MEAL SHARING
PROGRAMS.
IN ADDITION TO THESE PROGRAMS
AND SERVICES VARIOUS CAMPUSES
OFFER OTHER SUPPORTS AND
RESOURCES TO STUDENTS.
SEARCHES EMERGENCY HOUSING AND
HOUSING VOUCHERS AND YOU MIGHT
HAVE SOME OF THOSE SERVICES IN
FRONT OF YOU WITH A HAND OUT
FROM THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
YES YOU STUDY FOUND AT LEAST AT
THE TIME.
THAT MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES WERE UNDER UTILIZED FOR
EXAMPLE THREE QUARTERS OF
STUDENTS WHO ARE IDENTIFIED BY
RESEARCHERS AS FOOD IN SECURE
HAD NEVER HEARD OF OR NEVER USED
A FOOD PANTRY.
IN YOUR AGENDA ON THE BOTTOM OF
PAGE TWENTY SIX DESCRIBES OTHER
FINDINGS FROM CS USE LATEST
LEGISLATIVE REPORT ON THE ISSUE.
SO THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED
FIFTEEN MILLION OLLARS ONE TIME
FOR BASIC NEEDS FOR PHIL CS USE
BUDGET REQUEST.
CSU INDICATES THAT WOULD USE THE
MONEY TO EXPAND PARTNERSHIPS
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES AND NON
PROFITS THAT SPECIALIZE.
IN A WORKING WITH FOOD AND
SECURE AND HOMELESS POPULATIONS
IT'S OUR UNDERSTANDING OF THE
IDEA WOULD BE FOR THESE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES TO CSU
STUDENTS AND LINK THEM.
WITH COMMUNITY RESOURCES.
WE HAVE A FEW ISSUES FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO CONSIDER HERE
FIRST THE ISSUE OF
SUSTAINABILITY.
ASSUMING CAMPUSES ARE ABLE TO
USE THIS MONEY THIS FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. TO REACH OUT.
TO NEIGHBORING -- AGENCIES TO
FORM PARTNERSHIPS THERE'S A
QUESTION ABOUT OKAY WILL ONCE
THAT RELATIONSHIP IS STABLISHED.
HOW WILL BE MAINTAINED?
IT'S THE MONEY RUNS AWAY SO
HOUSE A KIND OF SUSTAIN IN THAT
WAY SECOND THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
WISH FOR CSU TO ESTABLISH CLEAR.
GOALS TARGETS AND METRICS ALSO
THE LEGISLATURE CAN ASSESS THE
IMPACT OF ANY ADDITIONAL MONEY
THAT UP FOR CSU BASIC NEEDS I
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT THE
SURVEY THAT FOUND.
THIS SURVEY FROM TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN THAT CSU
CONDUCTED.
HOW A LOT OF THE SERVICES IN
FRONT OF YOU ARE?
UNDER UTILIZING LEGISLATURE WILL
WANT TO KNOW OKAY IF THE
LEGISLATURE PUTS IN FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS OR HOWEVER.
MUCH.
WHAT IS THE IMPACT OUR OUR
STUDENTS STARTING TO LEARN MORE
ABOUT THE SERVICES AND AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF THE SERVICES?
THIRD THERE'S REALLY THE OF A
MUCH MORE STEPPING BACK A MUCH
MORE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE ABOUT HOW
STUDENTS.
PAY FOR COLLEGE OF FINANCIALLY
FINANCIAL AID IS THE PRIMARY WAY
STUDENTS PAY FOR BASIC COSTS
WHICH IS ROOM AND BOARD.
CURRENTLY.
THIS IS SOMETHING YOU HEARD --
JUST TWO WEEKS AGO -- NEAR YOU
SEE CARRYING CURRENTLY YOU SEE
PROVIDES MORE AID FOR LIVING
COSTS AND CAL STATE UNIVERSITY
IS ABLE TO OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
TO AND STUDENTS AT CSU AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES MAY HAVE TO
WORK LONGER HOURS OR TAKE OUT
MORE LOANS IN ORDER TO COVER.
THEIR COSTS SO DESPITE YOU SEE
HAVING THE MOST RESOURCES FOR
STUDENTS LIVING COSTS.
THE GOVERNOR'S ONLY PROPOSING
ONGOING RESOURCES FOR YOU SEE
AND ONE TIME AGAIN FOR FOR CSU
IN AND ACTUALLY NO FUNDING
SPECIFICALLY FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES FOR BASIC NEEDS.
THE LEGISLATURE MAY WANT TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO PRIORITIZE
ON GOING FINANCIAL AID
ASSISTANCE TO CSU AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS AND ONE WAY TO
DO THAT WOULD BE TO INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING.
THE STATE PROVIDES FOR THE CAL
GRANT BE ACCESS AWARD WHICH IS.
WHICH IS A GRANT THAT A
COMMUNITY COLLEE IN CSU
STUDENTS USED DISPROPORTIONATELY
RELATIVE TO YOU SEE.
SO IT'S TAKING A LOOK AT FUNDING.
FOR STUDENTS WITH THE MONEY THE
STUDENTS RECEIVE AND HOW THEY'RE
ABLE TO USE THAT MONEY TO MAKE
ENDS MEET AND OF FIND THE FOOD
AND THE HOUSING THEY NEED TO BE
SUCCESSFUL STUDENTS.
OR A AND CAL GRANT BE FOR THE
FIRST YEAR THIS TUITION ONLY IS.
I FOR THE FIRST YEAR CAL GRANT
BE IS IS -- THEY RECEIVE A GRANT
AND ACCESS GRANT OF ABOUT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS THEY
DO NOT GET TUITION COVERED IN
THAT CASE -- IT'S LIVING EXPENSE
YEAH IN THAT CASE IT WOULD BE
THE CSU STUDENT UNIVERSITY GRANT
THE INSTITUTIONAL LATER YOU SEE
THAT HOPEFULLY WOULD WOULD PAY
FOR THAT AND SPACES WAS LIVING
EXPENSES RELATED COSTS FOR THE
FIRST YEAR UNDER BE RIGHT.
AND GET ABOUT SEVENTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS WHICH HAS NOT KEPT UP
WITH INFLATION OVER THE YEARS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YES MA'AM HI GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
MAD DENISE BADLY OVERSEAS
STUDENT WELLNESS AND THE BASIC
NEEDS INITIATIVE.
FOR THE CAL STATE SYSTEM.
I THIS IS THE BASIC MEANS
INITIATIVE IS A SYSTEM WIDE
EFFORT TO COORDINATE SERVICES
ACROSS CAMPUSES I TO HELP REACH
ALL STUDENTS IN NEED OF SUPPORT
THE INITIATIVE IS STRUCTURED
AROUND A COMPREHENSIVE FRAMEWORK
INVOLVING FIVE KEY AREAS.
ADDRESSING THE MEDIA NEEDS OF
STUDENTS.
GROWING CAMPUS BASED BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES SO THAT THEY CAN REACH
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS SCALING UP
PRESS PRACTICES FROM ONE CAMPUS
ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
PARTNERSHIPS AND COLLABORATIONS
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES AND FINALLY
ENSURING LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY OF BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES.
SO AS AN EXAMPLE OF A MEETING
AND AND NEED IMMEDIATE NEEDS --
FOR STUDENTS STRUGGLING WITH
FOOD AND SECURITY ALL TWENTY
THREE OF OUR CAMPUSES DO HAVE
EITHER A FOOD PANTRY OUR FOOD
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAM.
ALL CAMPUSES PROVIDE CAL FRESH
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE TO
ELIGIBLE STUDENTS SO THAT THEY
MAY HAVE HEALTHY EATING OPTIONS.
AND IN FACT FROM AUGUST TWENTY
EIGHTEEN TILL THE END OF JANUARY
TWENTY NINETEEN THERE WERE OVER
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND UNIQUE
STUDENTS SERVE THEIR ON CAMPUS
FOOD PANTRIES.
AND A MAJORITY OF OUR CAMPUSES
ALSO OFFER MEALS HEARING OR MIL
VOUCHER PROGRAMS MEANING THAT A
STUDENT CAN GIVE -- OR DONATE A
MEAL SWIPE FROM THEIR OWN
INDIVIDUAL MEAL PROGRAM TO
ANOTHER STUDENT IN NEED SO
DURING THAT SAME TIME WE HAD
ABOUT FORTY FOUR HUNDRED MEALS
THAT WERE DONATED IN FIVE
HUNDRED UNIQUE STUDENTS.
USERS ACROSS THE SYSTEM.
UP FOR GROWTH WE HAD ABOUT TWO
THIRDS OF OUR CAMPUSES OFFERING
ON CAMPUS EMERGENCY HOUSING --
IN VOUCHERS FOR OFF CAMPUS
HOUSING I WE ALSO HAVE SEVERAL
CAMPUSES THAT PROVIDE STUDENTS
FACING HOUSING EMERGENCY WITH
HOTEL VOUCHERS TO PROVIDE SHORT
TERM RELIEF.
AND THE CAMPUS ALSO CAN WILL
SERVE AS A COSIGNER ON LEASE
AGREEMENTS FOR STUDENTS -- IN
NEED OF HELP. ONE OF THE BEST
PRACTICES WE'VE SEEN IT USED TO
ADDRESS FOOD AND SECURITY HAS
BEEN TO CONNECT STUDENTS TO SELF
RASH.
WE'VE ESTABLISHED HOW FRESH AS A
PILLAR OF OUR BASIC NEEDS WORK
BY SCALING UP OUT OF REACH
SYSTEM WIDE.
WE'RE PROUD THAT IN THE CSU WE
HAVE TO GO STATE WHICH IS THE
LEAD FOR TRAINING AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR ALL
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
DOING CAO FRESH OUT REGION
APPLICATION ASSISTANCE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE FIRST CAO
FRESH CONTRACT WAS SIGNED IN
CHEEK ONLY WORKED WITH ABOUT TEN
CSU CAMPUSES.
NOW THEY WILL BE WORKING WITH
FORTY TWO CAMPUSES STATEWIDE
INCLUDING NINETEEN AND THE CSU.
OUR PARTNERSHIP HAVE ALSO
EXPANDED SIGNIFICANTLY THERE ARE
CLOSE TO EIGHTY UNIQUE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT OUR
CAMPUSES WORK WITH NOT TO
MENTION OUR CLOSE TIES WITH OUR
SISTER HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHER EDUCATION
BASIC NEEDS ALLIANCE IS A
COLLABORATIVE BETWEEN THE CSU UC
AND CTC SYSTEM WITH VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDER PARTNERSHIP -- THIS
YES YOU UNDERSTAND THE BASIC
NEEDS IS A PART OF A LARGER
ISSUE THAT BECAUSE GOES BEYOND
OUR CAMPUS WALLS AND BECAUSE OF
THIS WE NEED TO CONNECT WITH
PARTNERS THAT HAVE EXPERTISE AND
RESOURCES.
THAT OUR STUDENTS CAN BENEFIT
FROM.
AND FINALLY FOR SUSTAINABILITY
ONE EXAMPLE WE'RE HAPPY TO
REPORT ON IS THAT IN ADDITION TO
OUR CALVET APPLY APPLICATION --
WE ADDED A QUESTION THAT ASK
FIRST TIME STUDENT.
I IF THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
LEARNING MORE INFORMATION ABOUT
CAL FRESH.
JUST A SINGLE QUESTION HELPS
ESTABLISH WHICH STUDENTS ARE
INTERESTED AND POSSIBLY ELIGIBLE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S.
SINCE SEPTEMBER WE'VE HAD OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
STUDENTS CHECK THE YES BOX.
WHICH IS A LITTLE OVER HALF OF
ALL STUDENTS THAT APPLY TO THE
CSU.
THIS IS STABLE CHANGE ALLOWED
CAMPUSES TO SEE WHICH STUDENTS
ARE INTERESTED IN LIKELY
ELIGIBLE AND WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
TARGETED OUTREACH.
THE CURRENT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIMEFUNDING BUDGET
ASK IS ABOUT EXPANDING OUR
AGENCIES AS WELL AS THE
PROVIDING HOLISTIC SUPPORT AND
WELL BEING.
INCLUDING THE ENHANCEMENT OF
MENTAL HEALTH AND HEALTH
PROMOTION PROGRAMS ON CAMPUS.
A FEW EXAMPLES OF THIS INCLUDES
INTEGRATING WELL BEING
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORM ACROSS OUR
SYSTEM.
PILOT TESTING SEVERAL HOUSING
STRATEGIES CONNECTING WITH
CONTINUUM OF CARE AGENCIES
STATEWIDE ONGOING ASSESSMENT OF
CURRENT PROGRAMS AND SERVICES TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE BEST WAYS
TO ENGAGE STUDENTS.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THERE'S MUCH
MORE TO BE DONE HERE AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING OUR
PARTNERSHIP DIDN'T WORK WITH
LOCAL AND REGIONAL AGENCIES AND
STATEWIDE AGENCIES.
ARE TO HELP INSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
WITH REGARD TO THE ELECTRONIC
BENEFIT TRANSFER PROGRAM --
OBVIOUSLY NOT ALL THE CAMPUSES
[inaudible]
EXCEPT.
THAT.
WHAT'S THE PLAN.
TO BRING THAT OTHER CAMPUSES
GIVE A TIMELINE FOR AND IS THE
GOAL TO HAVE A 100% OF THE
CAMPUS IS -- ACCEPTING THE
BEAUTIES WE WOULD LOVE THAT --
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND ALSO HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE USDA
ABOUT THE APPLICATION FOR EBT --
AND NATIONALLY IN TRADITIONALLY
IT HAS NOT BEEN THE APPLICATION
IS NOT CREATED FOR COLLEGE
CAMPUS FOOD SERVICE PROVIDERS --
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE ABOUT SIX
CAMPUSES IN THE CSU THAT DO HAVE
EBT BUT THEIR ARMS THE
APPLICATION PROCESS WITH TVS.
ARMY AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO NOW IS SEE IF THERE'S A WAY
TO STREAMLINE THAT APPLICATION
IN OR CREATE A TEMPLATE SO THAT
ALL OF OUR CAMPUSES CAN APPLY
FOR EDT ARE THOSE THAT ARE READY
TO APPLY FOR EDT SO THE LIMITING
FACTORS THE APPLICATION PROCESS.
YES.
IS THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO TO
FACILITATE THAT.
WE ARE -- IN LIKE I SAID IN
CONVERSATIONS WITH CDSS ABOUT
THIS -- WE'VE TALKED TO THEM A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT -- ONE OF THE
CHECKS CHECK BOXES ON THERE --
ASKS WHAT TYPE OF ORGANIZATION
IS APPLYING -- AND MANY OF OUR
FOOD SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
PHYLLARIES SO IT DOESN'T REALLY
FALL INTO THAT -- WHAT THE BOXES
ARE CURRENTLY THERE I'M ALSO ASK
FOR PERSONAL INFORMATION ABOUT
WHO OWNS THE STORE OR THE THE
MARKET SO PEOPLE HAVE TO GIVE UP
THEIR PERSONAL INFORMATION THEY
HAVE TO GIVE THEIR DRIVER'S
LICENSE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO THAT
HAVE BEEN?
A BAY AREA THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING TO SEE THE FF AND USDA
PARTNERS ABOUT.
IF THERE'S A WAY TO WORK AROUND
THAT.
WELL I WOULD I WOULD APPRECIATE
IT IF YOU'D KEEP OF THE
COMMITTEE STAFF POSTED ON THAT --
ONYOUR EFFORTS I THINK WE NEED
TO MOVE THAT ALONG OKAY AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AS SOON IT'S
A PRETTY IMPORTANT -- ISSUED
THESE TO BE RESOLVED FOR FOR THE
SAKE OF THE STUDENTS SO.
I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING DILIGENTLY
TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE WORK JUST
AS DILIGENTLY ALONG SIDE YOU.
TO SEE IF WE CAN BRING THIS
THING TO CONCLUSION APPRECIATE
IT.
I'M IN THE AREA OF HOUSING I
NOTICED THAT THERE IS OF OF SOME
VARIATION IN THE WAKE.
CAMPUSES HANDLE -- MERGING SEE
HOUSING VOUCHERS AND THE LIKE --
IF THAT'S THE CASE SHOULDN'T WE
HAVE A MORRIS SYSTEM WIDE
APPROACH TO THE THE HOUSING OR
DID THE ISSUES VERY CAMPUS BY
CAMPUS -- MITIGATE AGAINST A
SYSTEM WIDE APPROACH.
I'D GO WOULD BE -- OUR CAMPUSES
DO VARY BASED ON CAPACITY AT A
IN THE DORMS IF THERE'S CAPACITY
FOR ON CAMPUS EMERGENCY HOUSING
THEN CAMPUSES ARE LIKELY TO DO
THAT BUT IF -- THE FACILITIES
ARE ALL FILLED UP -- TO STUDENTS
THAT ARE PAYING FOR HOUSING THAN
MOST LIKELY THAT CAMPUSES HAVE
TO DEVELOP RELATIONSHIPS WITH
LOCAL HOTELS AND MOTELS TO HAVE
HOTEL VOUCHERS WERE STUDENTS CAN
SAY FOR A SHORT LIMóN ARE
LIMITED PERIOD OF TIME
[inaudible]
WELL THE YOU KNOW I CAME OUT OF
THE MILITARY SO I TALK ABOUT
METRICS ALL THE TIME BUT JUST
BECAUSE THEY HAVE THIRTY TWO
YEARS OF SOMEBODY BEATING IN MY
HEAD WE HAVE.
DO WE HAVE METRICS ON THE ON
THIS ISSUE TO SIT TO MEASURE OF
SUCCESS OR FAILURE IF SINCE IT'S
NOT A SYSTEM WIDE.
APPROACH HOW DO WE KNOW WHETHER.
CAMPUSES ARE SUCCEEDING OR
FAILING.
SO WE'RE WORKING ON EVALUATION
NOW OF SOME OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE
IN THE BEGINNING STAGES OF
REALLY LOOKING AT WHAT THE
IMPACT IS IN LOOKING AT METRICS
THAT ARE BEING CAPTURED WITH THE
BASIC NEEDS WORK.
AND HOW THAT OVERLAP SOME SOME
OF THE ACADEMIC SUCCESS
INDICATORS SO WE'RE JUST IN THE
BEGINNING STAGES OF FRAMING THAT
OUT.
AT OUR ANALYSIS REFLECTS THAT OF
THE SYSTEM IS GOING TO CREATE AN
RFP ASSOCIATE WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL -- TO
INCLUDE A HOUSING COMPONENT WHAT
SORT OF HOUSING COMPONENT.
THIS DO YOU IN THE SYSTEM FOLKS
ANTICIPATE SO WE'VE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT A RAPID RE
HOUSING TYPE MODEL -- WHERE WE
WOULD BE ABLE TO WORK CAMPUS IS
WE'D BE ABLE -- TO CREATE A
SYSTEM WHERE A STUDENT WOULD BE
A UC STUDENT NEED WOULD BE ABLE
TO APPLY TO BE INVOLVED IN THIS
RAPID RE HOUSING WHERE.
THEY WOULD GET THREE TO SIX
MONTHS OF FINDING -- THAT WOULD
ALLOW THEM TO MOVE IN AND THEN
HOPEFULLY BUILD UP OVER THOSE
THREE TO SIX MONTHS WHERE THEY
WOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE ON THE
RENT ON THEIR OWN.
WHEN WE HIS WE HAVE AT LEAST ONE
LEGISLATIVE INITIATIVE -- THAT
IS -- ALIGNED WITH THAT EFFORT
AS WELL.
A MENTAL HEALTH.
FIVE I'M SURE YOU SAW OUR AGENDA
AND THE ANALYSIS AND I WAS.
READING IT AND I WAS -- SOMEWHAT
SURPRISED IN A LITTLE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SURVEY RESULTS -- AND
I'M NOT A MATH PERSON WHICH IS
WHY I'M.
AN ATTORNEY I GUESS BUT WHEN I
WHEN I WAS LOOKING AT THE SURVEY
RESULTS IN THE PERCENTAGES FOR
HOSE STUDENTS WHO WERE SELF
REPORTING -- INTENTIONAL SELF
HARM OR AT LEAST CONSIDERATION
SERIOUSLY CONSIDERING SUICIDE
ATTEMPT SUICIDE IT TOTALS ALMOST
TOTAL 20% [inaudible]
OF WHAT PLANS.
DOES THE SYSTEM HAVE TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS AND SPECIFICALLY.
JUST TO ASK A COMPOUND QUESTION --
OR WERE YOU PLANNING TO ADD
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS WITH
RESPECT TO THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL AND THE AMOUNT IT'S
GOING TO BE PROVIDED AT LEAST
PROPOSED TO BE PROVIDED.
DO YOU NEED MORE MONEY FOR
COUNSELORS TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE STUDENT NEEDS.
OF THE FACILITIES THAT YOU DO
HAVE -- ON CAMPUSES ARE THERE
SIGNIFICANT WAIT TIMES.
FOR SERVICES AND ARE THEY'RE
SUFFICIENT -- PSYCHIATRISTS AND
COUNSELORS.
PSYCHOLOGISTS -- SOCIAL WORKERS
AVAILABLE. TO TO DEAL WITH
STUDENTS WHO ARE IN CRISIS.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS YES I I'M
HAPPY TO BREAK THEM UP IF I CAN
REMEMBER THE SO WAIT TIMES
ACROSS OUR SYSTEM DO VERY -- IF
A STUDENT IS IN CRISIS THEY'RE
ABLE TO GET IN TO SEE SOMEONE
USUALLY WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
IF NOT SOONER.
IF A STUDENT COMES IN AND ME ARE
ASSESSED AS NOT BEING IN CRISIS
THEN VERY WAIT TIMES CAN VARY
FROM A DAY OR TWO TWO WEEKS.
SO THAT'S WHERE THE VARIATION
REALLY LIVE IF A STUDENT COMES
THAT AND THEY'RE IN CRISIS RIGHT
THAT IN THERE AND THERE IS TEST
AS BEING IN CRISIS.
THEY ARE ABLE TO SEE SOMEONE
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY MOST OF OUR
CAMPUSES DO YOU HAVE A PERSON
THAT ROTATES THROUGH.
ACCOUNTS THAT ROTATES THROUGH
THAT IS ABLE TO WITH THE EIGHTH
A STUDENT THAT COMES THEN THAT
IS IN CRISIS AND THAT IS AS FAST
AND CRISIS TO HELP THEM RIGHT
THEN AND THERE.
DOES THIS ASSESSMENT OCCUR.
IN A STUDENT HEALTH CENTER IS A
YES.
AND I REALIZETHE ISSUE IS IN A
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT POSITION
MAYBE A SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
POSITION THAN THE THAN THE UC
SYSTEM.
UC HAS HOUSES HEALTH CENTERS AND
HOSPITALS AND UC HEALTH PLAN ALL
OF THAT THAT DOES NOT EXIST ON
THIS IN THE CSU SYSTEM IN ON
YOUR CAMPUSES SO IT'S A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT.
A SITUATION.
SOON THAT YOUR OF FACILITY YOU
HAVE LET FEWER FACILITIES AND
PERSONNEL TO TO DEAL WITH THESE
SORTS OF SITUATIONS JUST BECAUSE
YOU'RE NOT A MEDICAL TRAINING.
OFTEN INSTITUTION.
OUR SYSTE [inaudible]
CORRECT OKAY [inaudible]
WELL OBVIOUSLY.
MY COLLEAGUES AND I ARE VERY
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE WELL
BEING OF STUDENTS.
AND I REALIZE BASED ON WHAT I
READ WHAT PEOPLE TELL ME -- EVEN
THOUGH I AM AS OLD AS METHUSELAH
THAT SITUATIONS HAVE CHANGED IN
EDUCATION TODAY.
IN ON CAMPUSES AND IN PARTICULAR
ON HIGHER HIGHER EDUCATION
CAMPUSES AND STUDENTS ARE UNDERS.
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF STRESS AND
THAT STRESS CAN SOMETIMES.
MOVE INTO MORE SERIOUS
SITUATIONS SO WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ARE PROPERLY
RESOURCE -- BOTH IN TERMS OF
FACILITIES AND PERSONNEL TO DEAL
WITH THIS CRISIS.
SOME STUDENTS FIND THEMSELVES IN.
AND THAT'S WHY I ASK ABOUT
WAITING TIMES THAT'S WHY ASK
ABOUT -- COUNSELORS AND
PSYCHIATRISTS AND PSYCHOLOGISTS
I'D BE INTERESTED IN IF YOU
DIDN'T YOU MENTIONED THAT I
MISSED IT.
YOU KNOW THE VACANCY RATE ARE
YOU ABLE TO RECRUIT TO THE
EXTENT THAT THESE YOU SEE ISSUE
HOLLY'S.
RECRUIT TO FILL THE POSITIONS
THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO ESTABLISH
WITH THE FUNDING THAT YOU ARE
PROVIDED.
AND IF THERE'S A VACANCY
SITUATION HOW WE DEAL WITH THAT.
YEAH BUT I DON'T THINK WE EITHER
OF US HAVE ANY INFORMATION ON ON
VACANCY RATES IN AND TURN AROUND
ON THOSE BUT BUT JUST FROM A
JUST COMING FROM A FUNDING
PERSPECTIVE ON MENTAL HEALTH AND
AND HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
GENERALLY SPEAKING ORIGINALLY --
THE THE C. ISSUE OF HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES WERE
SUPPORTED BY GENERAL FUND WAY
BACK DECADES AGO.
BUT OVER TIME WITH REPEATED
RECESSIONS AND YOU KNOW
REDUCTIONS TO THE C. ISSUE.
THAT IS REALLY MY REALLY CHANGED
TO A MODEL WHERE IT'S A FEE FOR
SERVICE -- SORT OF MODEL SO --
TYPICALLY IT'S A FEE THAT IS
ASSESSED ACROSS AN ENTIRE --
CAMPUS TO FUND THE HEALTH
SERVICES AS WELL AS A MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THERE IS A
LITTLE BIT A GENERAL FUND.
STILL REMAINING ON SOME CAN'T
SOME CAMPUSES THAT SUPPORT --
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
HEALTH SERVICES THE
PREDOMINATELY IT'S A IT'S A FEE
THAT'S THAT STUDENTS PAY FOR
EACH AND EVERY YEAR -- IT WAS --
LIMITATIONS ON WHICH YOU CAN
CHARGE IS A STUDENT I ASSUME IN
FEET NOT STATUTORILY IN IT AND
IT BECAUSE WE ARE IN BECAUSE WE
ARE KIND OF A LOOSE
CONFEDERATION OF UNIVERSITIES
RIGHT THERE ARE.
THERE ARE DIFFERENT -- RATES
THAT ARE THAT ARE -- COLLECTED
ON THE TO THE CAMPUSES AND SOME
OF THAT IS REALLY DEPENDENT ON
LOCAL OF FACILITIES ARE
AVAILABLE RIGHT SO YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE FOR EXAMPLE CAN OF HEALTH
SERVICES FEES AT A HIGHER AND
HIGHER COST A BIT HUMBLE BECAUSE
THERE AREN'T SO MANY -- SEARCH
COMMUNITY SERVICES AVAILABLE TO
THEM CONVERSELY IT'S IT'S LOWER
IN OTHER AREAS SO JUST WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT IN TERMS OF
WHAT DID HE SAID DESCRIBING.
WITH -- THE LEVEL OF SERVICE
THAT WE ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE AND
WE THINK THAT THAT WERE ABLE TO
PROVIDE IT AT A AT A CRITICAL
POINT WHEN IT'S NECESSARY.
WE DO SUPPORT THAT WITH A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF YOU KNOW
BASS LINE FUNDING.
THROUGH THESE FEES SO THAT
STUDENTS CAN HAVE THE SERVICE
THAT THEY NEED.
AND OBVIOUSLY I'M SURE FINANCE.
IS ALWAYS APPRECIATIVE OF OF
SOME SOMEBODY ELSE OR SOMETHING
ELSE RELIEVING PRESSURE ON THE
GENERAL FUND BUDGET BUT I THINK
THIS ISSUE IS IS EXTREMELY
CRITICAL AND I GUESS MY COMMENT --
IS IF THE STUDENT FEE FUNDING IS
NOT SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE.
BECAUSE THEIR PRACTICAL
LIMITATIONS ON THE AMOUNT OF
THAT THAT CAN BE SUPPLIED FROM
STUDENTS.
IF THE STUDENT FEE FUNDING IS
NOT SUFFICIENT TO PROVIDE THE
LEVEL OF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE
THAT WE NEED TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
IN THE STATE I THINK WE OWE IT
TO THE STUDENTS.
TO EXPLORE AUGMENTING THAT --
EVEN IF HISTORICALLY WE'VE MOVED
AWAY FROM THAT I THINK IT'S TOO
IMPORTANT -- TO ALLOW.
THE STUDENTS TO REMAIN IN CRISIS --
OR EVEN DEVELOPING CRISIS --
WITHOUT EXAMINING WHETHER WE CAN
AUGMENT THAT WAS SOME GENERAL
FUND SO WILL DEPEND ON THE
SYSTEM TO LET US KNOW -- WHAT
YOU'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE WITH THE
FUNDING THAT YOU'RE ABLE TO GET
FROM YOUR STUDENTS AND DIVERT
FROM OTHER?
RESOURCES ON THESE CAMPUSES.
AND IF THERE'S ADULTERER
SHORTFALL -- LET US KNOW SO WE
CAN EXPLORE OF TURNS
[inaudible]
WE WILL.
ANYTHING ELSE ON THIS ITEM.
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION THIS ALSO
WAS A HOLD OPEN ITEM.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL VERY
MUCH -- PUBLIC COMMENT.
YES SIR A GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
TO ENTER NGUYEN OF DIRECTOR
PRIMARY ABOUT SECOND STATE
UNIVERSITY I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT.
OF BUDGET ALLOCATION THIS BASED
ON MY OWN EXPERIENCE OF BEING
FORMING CAR STRAIGHT ABOUT ALSO
BASED ON STUDENTS EXPERIENCES
THAT I GET.
TO HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF WORKING
WITH EVERYDAY.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENT JUST
MA'AM HELLO MY NAME IS TAMMY
LYNN AND I AM CURRENTLY A
SACRAMENTO STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENT GRADUATING NEXT MONTH
AND THE PSYCHOLOGY PROGRAM
CONGRATULATIONS THANK YOU I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF PROJECT REBOUND
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU THAT
THERE ARE.
TIMES THAT I WOULD NOT HAVE
EATEN IF IT WEREN'T FOR PROJECT
REBOUND AND THERE ARE TIMES I
WOULD HAVE HAD SCHOOL BOOKS
FIRST SEMESTER IF IT WEREN'T FOR
PROJECT REBOUND.
AND I JUST ASK YOU TO PLEASE NOT
THE DON'T LET THIS PROGRAM GO
AWAY.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE YES SIR HI MY NAMES
CONOR JOHNSON I'M ALSO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED STUDENT NOW I'M AT
SECOND OUR STATE MEMBER PROJECT
REBOUND.
I WAS INCARCERATED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO IN THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF PRISONS AT EIGHTH
GRADE EDUCATION EARNED A GED AT
LOMPOC -- I WON AN IMMEDIATE
RELEASE IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHILE I WAS
INCARCERATED OR NAY A IN SOCIAL
BEHAVIORAL SCIENCE -- WHEN I GOT
OU I FOUND PROJECT REBOUND HAD
MOVED FROM SAN FRANCISCO TO
SACRAMENTO WHERE I HAD A HOUSING-OPPORTUNITY -- I WAS ABLE TO
ENROLL IN HIM GRADUATING THIS
SEMESTER AFTER THREE SEMESTERS
SO SEMESTER EARLY I'M
TRANSITIONING TO THE GRADUATE
PROGRAM NEXT FALL -- I THINK MY
SEALED SOCIOLOGY GOOD FOR YOU
THANK YOU -- I DON'T THINK MY
ACADEMIC SUCCESS WOULD HAVE BEEN
POSSIBLE WITHOUT THE ASSISTANCE
OF PROJECT REMOUNT THEY ALSO
EMPLOY ME MY FIRST LEGITIMATE
JOB IN TWENTY YEARS -- I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL FOR THIS PROGRAM
IT'S HELP ME SUCCEED
ACADEMICALLY AND ALSO HELP ME
NAVIGATE WATERS AFTER FIFTEEN
YEARS OF INCARCERATION.
EATING OUT WITH SUCH -- IT
DIFFICULT TRANSITION THAT THEY
HELP ME THROUGH.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR COMING KEEP
US POSTED ON YOU CONTINUED
SUCCESS AND RESOLUTIONS YES
MA'AM [inaudible]
AFTERNOON.
I'M MAYES MCCAULEY MS GOING I'M
A STUDENT AT SACRAMENTO STATE
UNIVERSITY AND I ALSO WORK AT
THE PROJECT READ ON OFFICE AT
SACRAMENTO STATE.
AS IN STUDENTS PERSPECTIVE I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT I LOVE
CONNECTING WITH -- PERSPECTIVE
STUDENTS THAT WANT TO CONTINUE.
ON CAN CAN YOU IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION BECAUSE THE YOU KNOW
GIVE ME A SENSE OF GRATITUDE. TO
BE WHERE I AM TODAY AND I JUST
WANTED. TO THANK YOU FOR ON
HEARING EVERYBODY OUT TO BEING
CONSIDER OUR PROGRAM TO NOT LET
IT SHUT DOWN BECAUSE I WHO LIKE
I JUST WANT YOU TO KNOW THAT A
LOT OF STUDENTS DO YOU.
OF APPRECIATE OUR PROGRAM AND
ARE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING HIGHER EDUCATION TO
BETTER THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US YES
MA'AM.
HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF PROJECT READ DOWN.
I JUST WANTED TO THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO US BECAUSE NOT ONLY
ARE WE AM I THIS INCARCERATED OF
PREVIOUS FOSTER CARE PREVIOUS.
IN MY GT TWO I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU. FOR CONTINUING TO
FIND PROJECT REBOUND.
NOT ONLY ARE CHANGING MY LIFE
BUT THE CHANGE HAVE BEEN BROKEN
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THAT THE NEXT GENERATION
[inaudible]
KEEP FIGHTING.
MA'AM GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
COUNTY SEAN AND I'M HERE ON THE
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ASIAN.
PACIFIC CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IN
JUST GIVE YOU BACKGROUND THE CAL
ASIAN CHAMBER OF COMMERCE IS THE
LARGEST STATE RIDE.
ETHNIC CHAMBER IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE WORK CONSISTENTLY ON CREATING
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES YOU
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND
FOCUSING ON PROVIDING ACCESS TO
EDUCATION AND OPPORTUNITIES FOR
THE STATE'S SMALL BUSINESS.
COMMUNITY ONE OF OUR FOCUS AREAS
IS WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO
ENSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMIC.
ECONOMY HAS.
THE SKILLED WORKFORCE NEAR TO
STRENGTHEN OUR COMMUNITIES
BUSINESSES AND THE LOCAL ECONOMY.
AND CAL AGING JUST WANTS TO GIVE
THEIR SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED BUDGET FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION AND CSU.
WE ARE PLEASED THAT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET INCLUDES FUNDING FOR
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AND
RESPECTIVELY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT FOR ON GOING INVEST
INVESTMENT AND ONE TIME
INVESTMENT FOR IMPROVING
STUDENTS ACCESS.
IMPROVING GRADUATION RATES.
AND COME COMPENSATING FACULTY
AND STAFF FAIRLY THESE
INVESTMENTS TO ALLOW THE CSU TO
KEEP PACE WHAT THE OPERATIONAL
COSTS AND ENSURE THAT GRADUATES
CONTRIBUTE TO THE CALIFORNIA'S
FUTURE WORKFORCE.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR JOINING US
[inaudible]
YES MA'AM.
HELLO MY NAME IS ALL THAT IS ON
A SOON AS CSU EAST BAY EARLIER
YOU ASKED A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND THE ANSWER TO THAT
WHEN THERE'S A CRISIS -- STUDENT
IS MY WITH THE COUNSELOR -- THAT
DAY OR WITHIN ONE TO TWO WEEKS.
I WOULD LIKE TO KNOW WHAT CAMPUS
THAT IS BECAUSE ON MY CAMPUS
THAT IS FALSE AND MANY OTHER
CAMPUSES THAT I'VE HEARD OF THAT
IS FALSE -- AND I THINK IT IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO PRIORITIZE A
MENTAL HEALTH OF STUDENTS.
THE FAA IS.
REQUESTING THAT TO THAT TWENTY
MILLION BE PUT ASIDE FOR MENTAL
HEALTH -- AND THAT WOULD BE.
TAKE CARE -- A RATIO OF ONE FULL
TIME COUNSELORS FOR EVERY ONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS --
AND I THINK THAT IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE WOULD
DEFINITELY APPRECIATED IF YOU
TAKE THAT INTO CONSIDERATION --
BECAUSE THERE ARE A LOT OF
STUDENTS THAT ARE COMMITTED
SUICIDE -- AND A LOT OF STUDENTS
AROUND.
STUDENT BUT NO THOSE STUDENTS
ARE AFFECTED AS WELL -- AND WE
HAVE TO PRIORITIZE.
THEIR LIVES AND WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT AND BECAUSE IT WAS
MENTIONED THAT THE CSU SYSTEM IS
ONE OF THE MOST DIVERSE CAMPUSES
WE HAVE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
BECAUSE OF OUR DIFFERENT
IDENTITIES -- THE STUDENTS DO
COME WITH A LOT MORE TRAUMA AT
THAT MAYBE OTHER STUDENTS MIGHT
NOT -- GO THROUGH SO WE ASK YOU
THAT YOU PLEASE PRIOR PRIORITIZE
THE SAFETY OF YOUR STUDENTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SHOULD YOUR REMARKS.
YES SIR HI MY NAME THE LAST
LITTLE -- I'M A STUDENT AT CSU
CHICO -- AND WANTED TO COME AND
SAY THAT -- THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION SUPPORTS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL FOR THE TWO
OF FOR THE FUNDING. TO THE 2%
AND ROAMING GROWTH AND WITH THE
TWO SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS --
ALLOCATED IS BUDGET -- HOWEVER
WE ASK THAT THE GROWTH BE
MEASURED INSTEAD OF HAD COME OUT
OF FULL TIME -- EQUIPMENT
STUDENTS TO END.
UP [inaudible]
WE OH SORRY WE WE ASK THAT THE
GROWTH BE MEASURED BY HEAD COUNT
AND SAID OF BEING BECOMING LIKE
TURNING BY FULL TIME ENROLLMENT --
EQUIP INCIDENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THE FUNDING IS SPENT -- TO
INCREASE AXIS AND WE ****
BECAUSE LESS TO THE CSU TURNED
AWAY OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS YOU KNOW AND
THIS FUNDING WOULD ENSURE MORE
QUALIFIED STUDENTS GET A SEAT AT
THE CSU -- THE GOVERNMENT A
UNIVERSITY TWO MILLION DOLLARS --
OPPOSE FOR IN -- FOR ENROLLMENT --
YOU KNOW THIS IS YOU COULD PAY --
FOR SEVENTY SEVEN THOUSAND TWO
HUNDRED FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS OR COULD PAY
480-005-0070 ONE STUDENTS BY
HEAD COUNT -- A YOU KNOW USING
THE CALCULATIONS ALONE FOR FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT.
FULTON OF FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
STUDENTS -- YOU KNOW WE SHOULD
BE USING THE FUNDS THESE THE
FUNDS THAT ALLOCATED IN THIS
BUDGET SHOULD BE USED TOWARDS.
TOWARDS ENSURING ACCESS INSTEAD
OF A YOU'RE TRYING TO GET MORE
CLASSES -- FOR THE STUDENTS
ALREADY ENROLLED THAT CAN BE
THAT THAT CAN BE FOUND IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE BUDGET -- WHERE THE
CSU TOO YOU KNOW -- TO REALLY BE
MINDFUL OF HOW LIKE THAT FUNDING
WITHIN THAT WITHIN SYSTEMS
ALREADY ALLOCATED -- YOU KNOW
JUST WHEN I WANTED TO BRING
SOMETHING SET UP SOMETHING THAT
WASN'T BROUGHT UP YOU KNOW OR A
SPECIFIED IN THE CONVERSATION
JOE HAD ABOUT.
ENROLLMENT WAS THAT YOU KNOW --
YOU KNOW A BIG PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
IS YOU KNOW THAT THERE'S SEVERAL
CSU CAMPUSES THAT ARE IMPACTED
YOU KNOW ONE OF THEM.
BUT ACTUALLY BEING CSU A LADY --
THAT'S GONNA BE NO QUESTION
SENTENCING -- AS A REMINDER WHEN
WE INCREASE STANDARDS YOU KNOW
THAT REALLY LIMITS ASPECT ACCESS
FOR SPECIFICALLY FOR MONTHLY
STUDENTS SPECIFICALLY STUDENTS
OF COLOR IN LOW INCOME STUDENTS.
YOU KNOW IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S THIS
MIDDLE CLASS AND WHITE STUDENTS
YOU KNOW WHO DO HAVE BETTER
ACCESS. TO YOU KNOW AT A CITY
PREP YOU KNOW EXIT EXIT OR THAT
YOU KNOW INCREASES THE
QUALIFICATIONS -- SO REALLY LIKE
FOR THE FOR YOU ALL TO CONSIDER
THIS THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR --
GREETINGS CHAIRMAN ROB MY NAME
IS DON SANCHEZ AND I'M A FOURTH
YEAR SEEM TO BE GRADUATING SOON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY MARITIME ACADEMY.
YEAH I WOULD HAVE THANK YOU AND
I'M BE HERE I'M HERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION -- THROUGHOUT MY
COLLEGE EXPERIENCE I'VE BEEN
BOTH A FULL TIME STUDENT AND
I'VE BEEN A PART TIME STUDENT.
AND AS MICHAEL YOU JUST
MENTIONED THE IMPORTANCE OF
MEASURING ENROLLMENT GROWTH FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE -- BOTH
ACCESSIBILITY FOR THE CSU SYSTEM
AND IN AN EQUITABLE MANNER -- IS
A CENTER PRIORITY IN REMAINING
TRUE TO THE C. S. HE'S MISSION.
IN PROVIDING QUALITY PROTEIN --
UNIVERSITIES FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS -- ESSENTIAL REMIND
YOU THAT THE CURRENT METRICS OF
USING F. T. E.'S AS A WAY OF
LOOKING AT ROMA GROWTH AND
LOOKING AT FINDING AN
IMPROVEMENT.
EVERYONE GROWTH -- HAS RESULTED
IN A SITUATION WHERE WE FOUND
OURSELVES WITH THIRTY THOUSAND
QUALIFIED CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS --
THAT'D BEEN LEFT OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM -- SWITCHING FOR FUNDING
BASED OFF OF ATTY CALCULATIONS --
INTIMIDATION BY HEAD COUNTS --
AS MY COLLEAGUE IT STATED IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR AN ADDITIONAL
19% OF STUDENTS TO ACCESS AND
HAVE ACCESS TO CSU SYSTEM -- AND
I THINK.
THIS IS BEEN A PRIMARY
DISCUSSION IS COMMITTEE BUT AS
WE LOOK AT DIFFERENT AVENUES AND
DIFFERENT SOURCES AND PULLS IF
WE'RE LOOKING AT WHAT F. T. E.'S
ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH WHICH
ARE HAVING MORE INDIVIDUAL
STUDENTS TAKE MORE UNITS THERE
MORE APPROPRIATE -- RATS OF
FUNDING IF WE LOOK AT OTHER
METHODS THAT ARE RECEIVING A
LARGE AMOUNT OF FUNDING SUCH AS
CSU STATEWIDE -- GRADUATION IS
THAT I THINK IT'S A LITTLE MORE
APPROPRIATE.
THAT WE LOOK AT THOSE SOURCES OF
FUNDING FOR INCREASING.
UNITS PER STUDENTS RATHER THAN
USING ENROLLMENT GROWTH THE KIND
OF MEET THOSE GOALS AND I
COURAGE IS COMMITTEE -- AS
REPRESENTATIVES TO LOOK AT THE
MAKE UP TO THEIR DISTRICTS -- TO
LOOK AT ASPECTS OF
NONTRADITIONAL STUDENTS WHETHER
THAT BE STUDENTS THAT ARE A
LITTLE BIT OLDER AND ARE
SUPPORTING A FAMILY -- WORKING A
FULL OR PART TIME JOB.
OR WORKING OR LIVING IN A
SITUATION.
THAT ALLOWS THEM TO ONLY TAKE A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF USE IS A PART
TIME AND THEIR FOR DISCOUNTED BY
F. T. E. OR FULL TIME EQUIVALENT.
MEASUREMENTS THAT WE LOOK AT THE
OPPORTUNITY AND THE MISSION THIS
UC SYSTEM. TO PROVIDE THE MOST
EQUITABLE TRANSPARENT AND
ACCESSIBLE SYSTEM FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ROTH MY
NAME IS LILLIAN PAYS AND I AM
CHAIR OF THE POLITICAL.
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS
POLITICAL ACTION LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE AND A PROFESSOR
EMERITA.
FROM CAL STATE LOS ANGELES -- IN
ADDITION TO SUPPORTING THE
GOVERNOR'S ALLOCATION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AS
WELL AS WE HOPE INCREASE SUPPORT
FOR THE WONDERFUL PROJECT
REBOUND -- I'M HERE TODAY TO
SUPPORT THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATIONS BUDGET REQUEST.
THAT THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
OF THE ALLOCATION BE DEDICATED
TO THE HIRING OF TENURE TRACK
FACULTY FOR THE CSU.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE VERY BEST
AND MOST EFFECTIVE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE IS TO HIRE MORE
TENURE TRACK FACULTY WHO WILL BE
AVAILABLE IN THE LONG TERM FOR
THE ENTIRE CAREER.
OF STUDENTS AS THEY MOVE THROUGH
TO GRADUATION THERE IS OVER
FIFTY YEARS OF RESEARCH THAT
CONFIRMS THAT FACULTY WHO ARE
ABLE TO MENTOR OUR STUDENTS
THROUGH THEIR PROGRAMS.
AND ARE GOING TO BE MORE
SUCCESSFUL IN SEEING THEIR
STUDENTS THROUGH TO GRADUATION
WHERE ARE THOSE FACULTY GOING TO
COME FROM WELL WE'VE POINTED OUT
REPEATEDLY.
THAT THE UNIVERSITY HAS A
SIGNIFICANT POOL OF OF FOR
QUALIFIED FACULTY ALREADY
TEACHING IN THE CSU ON TEMPORARY
CONTRACTS ARE LECTURERS.
THESE FULLY QUALIFIED TEACHER
SCHOLARS COULD EASILY BE RE
CLASSIFIED AS TENURE TRACK
FACULTY AND HELP ADDRESS THE
NEED TO THE UNIVERSITY.
ATTY I MIGHT POINT OUT A
SIGNIFICANT SAVINGS TO THE
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM WE URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT FUNDING TO INCREASE THE
HIRING OF TENURE TRACK FACULTY
FOR THE GOOD OF OUR STUDENTS IN
THE CSU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NEXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS MAITREYA THE
DONNIE I AM A PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF POLITICAL SCIENCE
IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE AT
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AT
CHICO.
I'M IN MY SECOND YEAR THERE AS A
TENURE TRACK FACULTY MEMBER
AFTER A TWENTY THREE YEAR.
CAREER AS AN ATTORNEY. SIXTEEN
OF WHICH SPENDING CRIMINAL
DEFENSE AND THE LAST EIGHT OF
WHICH SPENT AT THE INNOCENCE
PROJECT AT THE SANTA CLARA LAW
SCHOOL PRIOR TO COMING TO TO GO
STATE AND I TEACH IN LEGAL
STUDIES.
AND I TELL YOU THAT BECAUSE IN
ADDITION I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION AND IN ADDITION TO
MY INSTITUTIONAL INTEREST IN
SEEING PROJECT REBOUND GET
FUNDED ADEQUATELY.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM TELLS ME THAT
THERE IS NO BETTER AT NO BETTER.
A REHABILITATIVE PROCESS THAN
EDUCATION AND AND ON JOB
OPPORTUNITIES AND COMMUNITY
BUILDING THAT IS ALL PRESENT IN
THE PROJECT REBOUND SEC.
I AM HERE THOUGH FOR CFA TO TALK
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT OUR INTEREST
IN TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
PROPOSED BUDGET.
BEING SET ASIDE FOR THE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AND ACCESS TO
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS WE SUPPORT
A STATUTORY GUIDELINE NOT A
MAXIMUM BUT A MINIMUM OF ONE
FULL TIME COUNSELOR FOR EVERYONE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS.
AT CHICO STATE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A VARIETY OF TRAUMAS
OVER THE LAST CALENDAR YEAR
INCLUDING THE CAMP FIRE WHICH
AFFECTED A COUPLE HUNDRED OF OUR
STUDENTS STAFF AND FACULTY.
BUT WE ALSO HAD A LOSS OF IT
DEATH BY SUICIDE OF A STUDENT
LAST YEAR IN MY FIRST YEAR OF
TEACHING.
A STUDENT WHO -- DIED BY SUICIDE
FROM MY BUILDING THAT MY OFFICES
AND AND IT WAS.
OBVIOUSLY THAT STUDENT WAS IN
CRISIS THAT STUDENT ALSO BAD
EXPERIENCE GENERATED A CIRCLE.
CONCENTRIC CIRCLE OF CRISIS THAT
I FEEL ARE COUNSELING STAFF DID
AN AMAZING JOB OF ATTEMPTING TO
RESPOND TO IT AND PEOPLE FROM
THE COMMUNITY BUT CAME IN.
BUT IT REALLY WAS -- IT SHOWED
HOW INADEQUATE THE NUMBERS ARE
WE JUST DO NOT HAVE COUNSELING
STAFF IT CSU CHICO AND AS I
UNDERSTAND IT.
REALLY AT MOST OF THE CSU
CAMPUSES IT'S NOT TRUE AT OUR
CAMPUS THAT SOMEONE CAN BE SEEN
WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS.
THEY DO HAVE SOMEONE WHO WILL
IMMEDIATELY RESPOND IF THEY IS A
CONCERN THAT A STUDENT IS GOING
TO END THEIR OWN LIFE.
BUT THEY DON'T HAVE ANY FOLLOW
UP AVAILABLE FOR SOMETIMES THREE
OR FOUR WEEKS AFTER THAT ONE
TIME TWENTY MINUTE.
APPOINTMENT SO IT REALLY IS.
CREATING AT I THINK A VERY
SERIOUS SAFETY ISSUE FOR OUR
STUDENTS SO I WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT FULLY
FUNDING THE ONE TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLAR INITIATIVE THE
TWENTY MILLION SET ASIDE.
THANK YOU FOR COMING I THINK
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE
SYSTEM IS GOING TO HAVE TO DO A
DEEP DIVE ON THIS AND DO AN
ANALYSIS OF THEMSELVES.
I GUESS.
WE'VE CERTAINLY ESTABLISHED OUR
ABILITY TO DO TO DO SO FOR
INSTITUTIONS IF THEY CAN'T DO IT
THEMSELVES BUT I THINK THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM -- OWES IT -- TO
CERTAINLY THE STUDENTS AND ALL
THE REST OF US.
TO TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK AT HOW
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ARE
PROVIDED ON CAMPUSES AND WHETHER
THE STAFFING IS ADEQUATE WHETHER
THE FUNDING FOR THE FACILITIES
ARE ADEQUATE. TO DO IT OR ALL.
THREE YES OR NO AND LET US KNOW
SO THAT WE CAN.
AS A LEGISLATURE WORKING WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION ATTEMPT TO
DRIVE MORE DOLLARS.
DOWN TO THE CAMPUS IS TO ADDRESS
THESE NEEDS -- YOU'VE HEARD ME
BEFORE I THINK IT'S IT'S
CRITICAL AND I THINK WE OWE IT
TO STUDENTS TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
TAKEN CARE OF THANK YOU FOR YOUR
COMMENTS THANK YOU AND I WILL
JUST ADD IN THE TWENTY MILLION
SET ASIDE THE IDEAL THERE IS A
NINETEEN EIGHTEEN MILLION OF
THAT.
IS TO HIRE COUNSELING STAFF AND
TWO MILLION IS TO COLLECT DATA
SPECIFICALLY ON THINGS LIKE
SUICIDALITY AND OTHER CRITICAL
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AMONG THE
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU I THINK THEY'VE HEARD
IS BOTH SO WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
YES SIR AFTERNOON CHAIR ROSS --
MY NAME IS PRESTON RUDY I'M A
PROFESSOR OF SOCIOLOGY AT SAN
JOSE STATE -- AND I LIVE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I AM ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE CFA CHAPTER ON
MY CAMPUS.
I'M HERE TO SPEAK TO IN FAVOR OF
THE SEA A PHASE REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL AT MONEY TWENTY
THIRTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TO
HIRE SPECIFICALLY TO HIRE TENURE
LINE FACULTY.
THE HIGHER DENSITY OF TENURE
LINE FULL TIME FACULTY HAS A
DIRECT BENEFIT TO OUR STUDENTS
SUCCESS.
IN GAINING AN EDUCATION TO MAKE
THEM ACTIVE AND ENGAGED CITIZENS.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE
ALLOCATION LAST YEAR OF TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
PURPOSE.
HOWEVER WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
FOLLOW UP AND GREATER
TRANSPARENCY.
WHETHER AND HOW THAT MONEY WAS
SPENT AT SAN JOSE STATE IN SAN
FRANCISCO STATE IN PARTICULAR.
HAS BEEN OBSCURED BY THE CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATION WE DON'T KNOW
WHERE THAT MONEY HAS GONE.
TO LASTLY I WOULD SAY I AND A
CFA WE SUPPORT THE PROJECT
REBAPTISM GREAT PROJECT TO FUND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST WANT
TO NOTE I I DON'T I KNOW THAT
SEE A FACE YOU SEVERAL OF YOU'VE
SPOKEN ABOUT SOME BUDGET REQUEST
IS NOT ONE THAT I'VE SEEN I'M
I'M ASSUMING YOU'RE WORKING WITH
THE FIRST FLOOR.
WE ARE YEAH OKAY.
SO WERE YOU YOU'LL SEE IT.
YOU MAY BE PREACHING TO THE
CHOIR BUT HOPEFULLY THE REST OF
THE MùT LISTENING AND
HOPEFULLY MAKES GOOD MUSIC.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US YES SIR
GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR ROBB
THANK YOU UP I'M JAKE RENDER
WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY.
AND WANTED TO TOUCH ON A FEW
POINTS THAT WERE MENTIONED IN
THE HEARING TODAY -- ON THE
POINT OF ACCESS AND HELPING
SERVE MORE ELIGIBLE FOR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS YOU WERE
RIGHT ON THE MARK THAT WE HAVE
NOT ONLY GROWING STUDENT DEMAND.
DESPITE DECREASING HIGH SCHOOL
GRADUATES AN INCREASING NUMBER
WHO ARE GRADUATING HAVING
COMPLETED THE EIGHT THREE G.
CURRICULUM TO BE READY FOR CSU.
AND WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S-GREAT EMPLOYR DEMAND AS YOU
REFERENCED IN YOUR COMMENTS
WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE'S ONE
POINT SIX FIVE MILLION.
COLLEGE GRADUATES THAT WE WILL
LACK BY TWENTY THIRTY TO ME
CURRENTLY PROJECTED WORKFORCE
NEEDS.
ON THE SIX THAT'S ELEMENT IN ON
THE GRADUATION INITIATIVE THIS
IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE GRADUATION
INITIATIVE BUT WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU -- TO LOOK AT THE LA US
RECOMMENDATION AROUND --
DEFINING SOME GOALS AND AND TO
YOUR POINT THE NEED FOR METRICS --
THAT WAS MUSIC TO MY EARS THAT
THAT'S WHAT I'VE BEEN BE NEED TO
AFTER YOUR YEARS OF SERVICE --
BECAUSE REALLY RIGHT NOW WE AT
THE STATE LACK ANY DEFINED GOALS
FOR DEGREE PRODUCTION OR CLOSING
THE RACIAL EQUITY GAPS.
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN OUR
RESEARCH IS THAT IN FACT THOSE
GAPS BETWEEN -- RACIAL ETHNIC
GROUPS ARE NOT ONLY PERSISTENT
BUT THEY'RE ACTUALLY GROWING.
AND EARLIER THIS WEEK BUDGET SUB --
TO AND THEIR AGENDA THERE WAS
INFORMATION THAT SHOW THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY BEEN AN
INCREASE IN THE BIG GAP BETWEEN
PAL AND NON PELL STUDENTS --
DESPITE GRADUATION INITIATIVE
FUNDING SO REALLY WARRANTS --
SOME LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATION
AROUND WHAT GOALS THERE SHOULD
BE FOR THAT FUNDING WE DO THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT THERE BE
THIS FOCUS ON STUDENT SUCCESS
THOUGH.
AND THEN FINALLY START TO WRAP
UP MY COMMENTS HERE WE ALSO ARE
VERY PROUD TO HELP CONVENE THAT
CALIFORNIA UNDOCUMENTED HIGHER
EDUCATION COALITION.
AND I KNOW THAT'S GOING THROUGH
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES IT'S
LEGAL SERVICES FUNDING THAT GOES
THROUGH DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO SERVE.
THE IF YOU STUDENTS STAFF AND
FACULTY THERE'S A SEVEN MILLION
DOLLAR ONGOING PROPOSAL THAT
GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S INCLUDED MISS
BUDGET WERE ALSO VERY SUPPORTIVE
OF THAT GIVEN THE ONGOING.
LEGAL UNCERTAINTY IN CHALLENGES
THAT ARE BEING PRESENTED TO THE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMUNITY AT OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS YES
MA'AM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR CARE THREE
****GONE ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION COALITION WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED.
A PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE TWO
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN MILLION TO
SEE IF YOU FOR FACILITIES IN
PARTICULAR THE FOCUS TO EXPAND
CAMPUS BASED CHILD CARE FACILITY
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT
STUDENT PARENTS.
COMPLETION OF POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION IS THE KEY COMPONENTS
UPWARD MOBILITY AND IMPROVES
APPEARANCE CHANCES TO WORK IN
HIGHER PAYING JOB.
AND THEIR JOBS AND THEIR BY --
CREATING OPPORTUNITIES FOR THEIR
FAMILIES.
CAMPUS BASED CHILD CARE WILL
ALLOW STUDENT PARENTS ATTEND
THEIR CLASSES KNOWING THAT THEIR
CHILDREN WILL BE IN A SAFE AND
ENRICHING ENVIRONMENT.
AND PUTTING ON A DIFFERENT HAT
HERE ON BEHALF OF COPYING
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER WE WOULD
LIKE TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION
THE NEED FOR ADDITIONAL FUNDING.
FOR FACULTY FOR BILINGUAL
TEACHER PREPARATION PROGRAMS
THAT ARE YOU SEE CSU SYSTEMS AND
OUR PRIVATE UNIVERSITIES.
THERE IS A NEED TO EXPAND
EXISTING BILINGUAL TEACHER
PREPARATION PROGRAMS OR
ESTABLISH NEW ONES IF WE ARE TO
BUILD THE CAPACITY OF BILINGUAL
TEACHERS FOR BILINGUAL PROGRAMS.
INVESTING IN ADDITIONAL FACULTY
WOULD ALLOW GREATER
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ALL STUDENTS
TO BECOME BY LITERATE AND
BILINGUAL AS PROMISED BY
PROPOSITION.
FIFTY EIGHT THE CALIFORNIA MULTI
LINGUAL EDUCATION ACT AS WELL AS
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE QUALIFIED
BILINGUAL TEACHERS FOR E. L.
STUDENTS WE ASK THAT YOU
CONSIDER AB TEN TWELVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY HAS
INTRODUCED THIS YEAR.
THAT SEEKS SUCH AN INVESTMENT
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR JOINING US YES SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE ROTH MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST OF FIRST I
WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS THAT
MY COLLEAGUE JAKE FROM THE
CAMPAIGN MENTIONED -- AND ALSO
WON'T TOUCH ON A FEW THINGS SO
FIRST -- WE ASKED LEGISLATURE
APPROVED THE FUNDING FOR LEGAL
SERVICES FROM DOCUMENTED
STUDENTS FACULTY AND STAFF WERE
GLAD THAT CALIFORNIA'S TAKING A
PROACTIVE LEADERSHIP ROLE AS HE
MENTIONED THAT IS GOING TO
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES -- BUT
WE HOPE THAT WE ALSO SUPPORTERS
WELL SECOND WE ASK LEGISLATURE
TO APPROVE THE FUNDING FOR BASIC
NEEDS SO FOOD AND HOUSING AND
SECURITY.
WE ASKED TO GO AND WE ASK THAT
YOU GO A STEP FURTHER BY MAKING
THAT ONGOING INSTEAD OF ONE TIME
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY --
WE HOPE THAT WE COULD DO A
LITTLE BIT MORE -- TO HELP OUR
STUDENTS.
THIRD REGARDING THE CSU GRAD
INITIATIVE WE ASK THAT THIS
FUNDING BE APPROVED BUT WE ALSO
WANT TO SEE MORE AND BETTER DATA
REPORTING AND DATA TRANSPARENCY
FOR THE OUTCOMES THAT OUR
CAMPUSES IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE.
OF OUR REPORTING ARE WE REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE CSU
IS CLOSING A GRADUATION GAPS --
FOR MARGINALIZED
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS.
LASTLY ARE WHEN IT COMES TO
ENROLLMENT GROWTH FUNDING WE ASK
LEGISLATURE APPROVED THIS -- BUT
WE ALSO ASK THAT YOU CONSIDER
HOW THIS -- PROPOSAL INTERSECTS
WITH A PROPOSAL THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES S TAKING UP ON A
REQUIRING A FOURTH YEAR OF
MATHEMATICS IN QUANTITATE
QUANTITATIVE REASONING -- WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE SOME
INEQUITIES ON ACCESS TO A
THROUGH G. COURSES COLLEGE PREP
COURSES THAT ARE KEY TO TWELVE
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY FOR LOW
INCOME STUDENTS STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
AND THIS BOARD OF TRUSTEES
PROPOSAL COULD POTENTIALLY
EXACERBATE SOME OF THOSE FOURTH
YEAR MATH FOR EVERYONE.
YES.
IT'S A BOARD TRUST -- IN HIGH
SCHOOL YES IN HIGH SCHOOL YEAH.
I NEVER WOULD GRADUATING.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR --
HIT A BRAG START WITH THE CAL
STATE STUDENT ASSOCIATION --
CSSA IS VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
INVESTING MORE INTO THE
INSTITUTION WHICH WE KNOW WILL
HELP STUDENTS BE MORE SUCCESSFUL
HOWEVER WE BELIEVE THAT
AFFORDABILITY SHOULD BE MADE.
AN EQUAL PRIORITY THROUGH CAGR
GRANT REFORM -- WHICH WILL
PROVIDE MORE AID TO MORE
STUDENTS A LOW INCOME STUDENT AS
UNABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL WITHOUT
BOTH THESE THINGS --
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO SHOW OUR SUPPORT TO FUNDING
PROJECT REBOUND I BELIEVE THAT
IS EXACTLY THE TYPE OF PROGRAM
THAT WE SHOULD BE INVESTING IN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS YES
MA'AM CAN REALLY RESONATED WITH
AS HE I YOU AND WEARING PURPLE
BUT I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
AFFILIATES CFA IN CS YOU YOU --
CFA SAID IT PRETTY ELOQUENTLY
SOME IS GONNA HIT THE HIGH NOTES
WE SUPPORT THEIR ASK FOR FULL
TIME ENROLLMENT ANY OF THE
BODIES IN THE SEATS AND NOT JUST --
THE NUMBER PEOPLE DOING THE FULL
TIME CREDIT WE ALSO WANT YOU TO
CONSIDER -- INCREASING TENURE
TRACK AND EQUITY WITH THE UC AND
BRINGING MENTAL HEALTH DOLLARS
IN FOR ODD COUNSELORS NOW -- ONE
OF OTHER ITEMS FOR C. AS HE WE
YOU WE'VE.
MENTIONED SEVERAL TIMES BUT I WE
HAVE A CONCURRENT BILL HAPPENING
WHICH IS AYE WEBER IS AB THREE
SIX NINE TO ADDRESS THE STEPS
THAT WERE TAKEN AWAY
UNILATERALLY BY THE CSU ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS AGO.
WE'RE ASKING TO HELP THIS IS THE
THE CSU ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY
DOING INVERSION DOLLARS ALSO IN
THE BUDGET.
SO IT'S A ONE TIME ASK FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION THIS WILL JUST
ALL SIXTEEN THOUSAND WORKERS OUT
OF THOSE SIXTEEN THOUSAND
WORKERS OVER ALMOST ELEVEN
THOUSAND OF THEM HAVE INVERTED
SALARIES BECAUSE THEY HAVE NOT
RECEIVED STEPS FOR THIRTY YEARS.
AND WE'RE NOT TRYING TO GET INTO
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING BY ANY
MEANS BUT THE WAY HERE WORKS IS
THAT THERE IS AN ITS BENEFITS
THE EMPLOYER BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ACCOUNTABILITY
IN THE PURSE STRINGS.
AND SO SINCE IT'S BEEN THIRTY
YEARS THEN VERSIONS THEY WERE
AWARE OF SINCE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN HAVE DONE NOTHING HAVE
NOT COME TO TABLE ON IT FOR ASSN
THE LEGISLATURE TO HELP US.
HELP THESE ARE WORKERS.
HAVE DIGNITY IN THEIR WORK THANK
YOU THANK YOU ALL LOOK FOR THAT --
FOR THE MEASURE FROM DOCTOR
WHATEVER.
ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT.
SEEING NONE WE ARE ADJOURNED